hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the excel tutorial so in
this tutorial we will be learning the
end to end excel fill course
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn so without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's discussion
we will start off with the fundamentals
where we discuss the excel basic
knowledge later we will understand the
sorting and filter functions in excel
next we will understand some inbuilt
functions in excel that you use in your
day-to-day life with excel later we will
try to implement slicers in excel and
understand how to flash fill in excel
later we will understand how to
eliminate the duplicates in excel
spreadsheets then after that we will
understand how to lock or protect your
data in excel
then we will understand the fundamentals
like goal seek in excel how to create
barcodes in excel and how to generate
progress charts and circular progress
charts to measure the progress of your
team
then they will understand some important
fundamentals like converting the data
from various sources into excel for
example pdf then we will understand how
to set up your page in excel for
printing after that we will understand
the conditional formatting data
validation in excel later we will dive
into creating the mis reports in excel
once we are done with this we will look
into the lookup functions that are the
horizontal lookup vertical lookup and x
lookup in excel
later we will try to design a budget
template then we will try to understand
how to create a user form in excel after
that we will dive deep into the time
series in excel next we have some
interesting topics where we try to email
using excel and try to do mail merge in
excel after that we will understand the
pivot tables and charts in excel
then finally we will enter the important
stage in excel data analysis in excel
after that we will understand the macros
and visual basics in excel finally we
will try to create the interactive excel
dashboard later to make things more
interesting we will wind up this session
by discussing the most frequently asked
interview questions based on excel i
hope i made myself clear with the agenda
now without further ado let's get
started with our first concept
what is microsoft excel
so microsoft excel is a software product
designed and developed by microsoft for
storing data in an organized way that is
rows and columns
and
microsoft excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
followed by that
microsoft excel is also used to extract
the insights from the data and represent
it in the form of visually appealing
graphs and charts
now we have a basic understanding or an
overview of what a microsoft excel
software product is now moving ahead we
will understand the fundamentals of
microsoft excel
so following are some fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with microsoft excel
so basically when you install the
microsoft office in your computer you
will have various microsoft products out
of which microsoft excel is one of the
product so we will be dealing exactly
with that particular product that is
microsoft excel so when you get started
with microsoft excel this is what you
will see in the first page so this
particular page is called as microsoft
excel homepage where you will be having
various varieties of sheets microsoft
excel will give you some suggestions
based on the type of sheet you want to
work with we will see this in a better
way through the practical session so
once you get started with the sheet you
will have some more options so this
particular option is called as the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert draw page layout formulas data
review view and help so these are the
tools that you will be using to work on
your data using microsoft excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon so
when you select some or the other option
from the file home insert draw page
layout formulas data
review view and help buttons you will
have a ribbon so for example you can see
that i have selected the home tool here
so when i press on the home tool this is
the ribbon which microsoft excel gives
me so this ribbon has some options in it
which can perform various operations now
in a further more detailed way we will
have toolbar groups so when you see in
the previous slide we have a complete
toolbar ribbon so this particular ribbon
is segmented into groups so you can see
the first group as paste cut copy format
painter etc etc and the second group is
the font the size of the font and to
increase the size of the font to
decrease the size of the phone bold
italic underline etc etc and here you
can see the text alignment so each and
every group has separate functions
so each set is called as a group
and i think you can see a small arrow
option over here so this arrow option is
used into the toolbar groups when the
group is not able to fit all the
operations or all the functionalities in
one single provided section so when you
click on this particular arrow mark you
will have another dialog box so this is
called toolbar more options so you can
see that when i clicked on this icon you
can see a new dialog box which opens me
a new set of operations which are not
able to be fit in this particular group
so we will also see more about this in a
better way in the practical session now
moving forward we have cell and address
so when you open a microsoft excel sheet
you can find boxes so each and every box
is named as a cell and each cell has its
own address for example the highlighted
cell over here has an address b3 so b is
the column name and three is the rule
name
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets
and in the bottom right corner you have
an option of increasing or decreasing
the sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of microsoft excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so now we enter the demo inventory in
microsoft excel so we will be using
microsoft excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company
so basically an employee in the company
has employee id name and designation
salary etc etc so we will be trying to
create the same table using microsoft
excel but before that let us understand
the fundamentals of microsoft excel
through the practical demo first so i
have started my microsoft excel and this
is how the home page of microsoft excel
looks like
so you have a blank workbook over here
if you want to create a new workbook you
can select new option
so excel will provide you with various
variety of sheets you can see money in
excel adjustable meeting agenda
streaming shoulders small business cash
flow and many more if you're not able to
find what you're looking for then you
always have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers lists budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the excel is
loading few types of sheets
so you can see that excel has provided
us with some online varieties of sheets
for example any calendar business
expenses channel marketing budget budget
summary report blue product list etc etc
you can see construction proposal
invoice you name it excel has got it so
excel will provide you with some variety
of options based on your requirement now
for this session let's get started with
a blank workbook which looks something
like this since this tutorial is based
on the fundamentals we'll go with a
blank workbook
now over here you can see the toolbar
that we discussed earlier that has the
file home insert draw base layout
formulas data review view and help so
this is the toolbar and
under the toolbar i have selected home
and you can see this is the particular
ribbon what we discussed about this
particular ribbon belongs to home page
and when you select file option you'll
get back to whom and if you select
insert option you'll have another
different ribbon with different groups
etc etc so every particular tool has
different ribbons in them and remember
the extra options that we discussed when
you press over this arrow key this is it
so when you press the arrow key you'll
have few more settings which cannot be
fit in this particular section of groups
so you can have some variety of options
over here of changing the font changing
some effects to the text font size and
font style etc etc
apart from this we have also discussed
about the cells in every sheet so this
particular cell has an address so you
can see the address over here which is
b3 so b happens to be the
column name and three happens to be the
row name
now we also had a discussion about the
sheet tracker right now we just have one
sheet if you want multiple sheets you
can just feel free to select on the plus
option which will always create you some
extra sheets
and you can navigate through sheets just
by pressing on the sheet name
and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with hundred percent
now these are the few fundamentals that
you need to keep in mind before getting
started with microsoft excel now that we
know the fundamentals of microsoft excel
let's get started with a practical
session which is about the employees
details in a company
now let's select this particular cell
let's type in
employee
details
yeah we have the cell
now an employee details table will have
the information related to employees so
the information will be about name
it will be about employee
number it will be the designation
and maybe salary
and maybe blood group as well
and
let's take another one which is phone
number
yeah so so far so good
and uh you can see that we have some
problem with this particular column
the designation and the name uh the name
of the designation is practically
good but it is not visible so when you
uh when you're not on that particular
cell you can see that the name is
incomplete over here so you can always
fix that you can just you know manually
change the size of the row or sell or
you can also feel free to you know
double click on that cell which will
automatically you know set the size of
that particular cell
and same goes to the blood group just
let's try to double click on that and
same goes to phone number
great
so you can see that the employees
details are just confined to the first
two cells it's supposed to be somewhere
in the middle right so no problem we can
do that as well we can select all the
cells and
we have an option of merging them
you can just select this one which will
help you with merging and centering that
particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it
now let's get started by adding the
names of the employees
let's add the names joe
john
mary
mark
susan
and then
jennifer
let's type in mike
let's open them
chef jeffrey
yeah we have a couple of employees now
let's type in the employee numbers
you
here we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose uh joe to be the ceo of the
company
and john as the software developer
and mary as tester
mark and finance
susan also in finance
and jennifer and testing
and mike in
marketing
same goes for
tim
and again jeffrey into software
development
and
morgan into testing again
now let's click on a c so that it gets
you know resized according to the length
of the text
now it's done so let's get into salary
uh
ten thousand dollars
and
fifteen thousand dollars
nineteen thousand dollars
let's increase the salary of a ceo so
let's keep it one lakh dollars
and finance again twenty thousand
so yeah the salaries are allocated
again the blood group
here we have the
blood groups now let's type in the
mobile numbers
[Music]
yeah now we have typed in some random
mobile numbers as well
so uh yeah this is how you can add in
some data into your table
and now let us imagine that you forgot
to add or
remove a column so let's imagine that we
wanted to add a serial number as well
but somehow we forgot to add it now you
can always add a new row or column for
example here we wanted to add a new
column so we just have to right click on
a select the insert option
here we have a new row now
now let's type in serial number
and let's type one
now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right click
and
fill series now we have the employee
number starting from 1 to 10
that's how you do it and apart from this
you can also uh you know change the font
of the entire row you can change the
font to
say uh
irony
and you can always also change the font
and same goes to the employee table we
can select it
bold it and you can also increase the
size and again select a color for the
text
maybe a different color green would be
better
and
you can also select the entire cells
and align them to the center
looks more good
and you can select or double click the
row names so you'll have the proper
spacing between all the rows and columns
so we have double click on the column
right yeah so basically that's how you
make things happen
now let's save this
so i'd like to go to the save option and
amp data
let me save this in my local location
and just save it's done
so that's how you work on your excel
file with some basic data
in this session we will be learning
about slicers in excel but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
if you are a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with our one point
agenda that is slicers in excel
so slices in excel are software filters
used along with excel tables or excel
pivot tables over a large amount of data
not just filtering out data but slices
also help you with an easy understanding
of the information being extracted and
displayed on the screen now microsoft
excel slices are compatible with windows
and macintosh operating systems now let
us understand how to implement slicers
in excel so for that we might want to
get back to the practical mode that is
starting our microsoft excel
now we are on our excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table
this table from microsoft excel is been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement the slices in excel we might
want to create or convert the format of
database into a normal table for that
you can select all your data and just
press ctrl t
and that will allow you an option called
convert the data into table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that
select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and in the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employee id
employee name zone designation
department salary employees date of
birth and employee state of joining so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices
now let me select the first one that is
zone next designation department and
let's also select employee name
now press ok
and there you go we have our slices
now let us try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done now let us imagine that we want
to see or take a look at the employees
who are working in the east zone then we
have all the information displayed on
the screen who are working in the east
zone they are jack tony banner fred etc
and their department designation etc etc
all on one single screen so this really
helps you while you're presenting your
data in a presentation
now for a change let's try to select the
department
now if your client wants to select the
data
from only analytics department then you
might want to select on the analytics
key on the department slicer and there
you go you have an employee called luke
hopps who works in the east zone and his
department is analytics and his
designation is contract based
and the salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
uh you can see that we have only
selected analytics and
your client also wants data from it
support now you can see that analytics
is gone
but what if you want both analytics and
id support then you have an option
called select multiple
then you can select analytics and it is
supported if you want hr you can also do
that and in the zone if you want
west along with east then you can do the
same east and west and you have all the
employee details
and in the designation let's try to
select
senior trainee
okay select multiple senior trainee and
manager so that's how you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation
we will be learning about flash fill in
excel
excel flash fill is a feature of
microsoft excel where excel can sense a
pattern in a cell and apply the same
logic to extract the similar resultant
pattern out of the remaining cells in a
table
might be a little confusing right so let
us simplify it so let us imagine that
you have a text in one of the cells in
the excel sheet and you wanted to trim a
part of that text for example let us
imagine that there is an assembly and
assembly where the car parts are
assembled together to finish a car so
each and every part has a code the
serial number the product code and the
assembly code etc right and you wanted
to separate all those three
if you wanted to do that you might want
to use the trim function which might be
a little tedious to apply to all the
cells but what if i say there is a
simple key format using which you can
fill all the columns in the excel sheet
within a fraction of a second sounds
interesting right so that's exactly the
flash fill function in excel does
now before we get started let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies if you're a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
sinclair now without further ado let's
get started with the flash fill in excel
for that we might want to start the
excel to get in the practical mode
now we are on the microsoft excel and
remember the example we discussed so
this is a similar example now the first
column in the sheet is the product
detail so this product detail consists
of the product code that is one one two
next we have the product serial number
that is one zero zero two five six three
seven and lastly the assembly code that
is a s and x now we want to separate
this product detail into three columns
where we have the first column to be
storing the product code second one to
be storing the product serial number and
the last one to be storing the assembly
code so now if you want to do that using
trim function you might want to apply
the trim function here and trim out the
left part and again for the product
serial number you might want to use the
trend function again which might go into
a little complicated pattern so to avoid
the complications and and decrease the
time spent we might want to use the
flash fill in excel now let us help
excel
about the pattern that we might want to
generate so the pattern is one one two
and the next one is
three two two so now you can see that
the text was highlighted that was the
intimation from the excel that it
understood the pattern now going into
the next cell and holding the ctrl key
and pressing the e button will help us
to fill the remaining cells in the
column b
so that's how it is done and similarly
let's try out for the serial number
for that
the serial number is one zero zero two
five six three seven
now in the next cell we have one zero
zero three
six five eight
two now we can go to the third cell and
press ctrl e for windows and if you're
using a mac operating system then you
have to press command e and all these
serial numbers will be filled so this
will reduce the time in separating the
pattern and filling the columns
now let's try the last column that is
a s x which happens to the assembly code
next we have f g and v
now the
shortcut method that is ctrl e and there
you go
now you might be wondering will it work
only for numbers etc etc or the text
which is properly aligned or separated
using a hyphen no it can also be used
for some random text which is like this
so let us imagine that we have a text
which is of length like 20 or 30 and you
wanted to print only a part of it so
here i'm going to print the alphabets
from position fourth to position eight
so i've already tried the first one that
is taking out the
alphabets from fourth location to the
eighth location or the pattern of the
text that is i f er from jennifer lopez
and in the next cell we have the numbers
starting from the location four to eight
so that is seven seven six seven and
similarly we have the other cells
consisting of the names of few cars that
is alpha romeo bugatti veyron and next
we have superman returns text so now
let's press the shortcut key that is
ctrl e and make sure that all the
remaining cells are filled
so that's how the flash fill works
so the flash fill in excel will reduce
the time consumed to fill all the
columns by separating the text in your
main cell that is the column a which we
have here in this example and it also
reduces the complexity of using a trim
function in excel
we will learn about deleting the
duplicate elements in an excel sheet
now without further ado let's get
started with our one point agenda that
is delete duplicate elements from excel
now
for this particular task we will be
considering the student database
now let's get into practical mode and
start our excel so on my screen you can
see some data related to students
now let us try to duplicate some of the
rows here
so we have selected the rows 8 9 10 and
11
now we shall copy them
and paste them so now these are the
duplicate elements
right
now there might be possibilities about
the duplication of class because all the
students all the 10 students are in same
class so there might be a duplication
but we are not looking for such kind of
duplications right we are looking for
the duplication of the entire row for
example we have the details of mike over
here in the eighth row which has the
roll number or serial number as seven
name as mike roll number class blood
group and subject scores percentage
round of percentage and total marks so
the entire eighth row is being copied
here and it is in the
row number 12 we have the exact same
details so what if we have the exact
same rows duplicated so that's what
we're going to deal with we're going to
eliminate the duplicate rules all
completely together
now to carry over this task we have to
select the data from toolbar so you have
various options file home insert etc so
you need to select the data and inside
the data toolbar we have the ribbon and
inside ribbon you have got the duplicate
values or remove duplicates
option in the ribbon so select all the
data select remove duplicates and now
you can see that we have all our
column names over here
and make sure that you have selected my
data as headers and then select ok
and now you can see that excel has
automatically removed four duplicate
values
so four duplicate values are found and
removed then unique values remain
now another type of remove duplicates
can also be done so you can see that
here we have another data set which has
phone numbers or phone names that has
phone makers that are samsung huawei
vivo oppo etc so there are some
duplicate values and this have copy
pasted them so now you can also do that
so just select all the data
and now
go into home
and select conditional formatting and
here select highlight sell rules and
inside that you have duplicate values
selecting this option will help you
identify the duplicate values in your
data set but not to remove them
so you can select that and you can see
the duplicate values are highlighted
over here in the red column now again
you can get back to data and select the
option of remove duplicates and select
okay and the duplicate values will be
automatically eliminated
so that's how you delete or eliminate
duplicate values in a
data set and you can also see that we
have another duplicate in this
particular row and if you wanted to
select a particular row and eliminate
the duplicate signals to do that
now for that you need to go to the same
process remove duplicates and here
microsoft excel is asking you
if you had to expand the selection to
the entire data set or you want to
continue with the selected data set
etcetera or selected column itself so
for that you need to select the continue
with the current selection and remove
duplicates and press ok and you can see
one duplicate value is found and it has
been removed and six unique values
remain
so that's how you use the function of
removing duplicates in excel
in this session we will learn how to
protect and lock cells in excel
now why do we need to lock or protect
cells in excel
let us imagine that there is an excel
sheet with really confidential data and
you need to pass that data to your
subordinate or your currently to make
some minor edits
now let us imagine that the edits are
supposed to be done to only one or two
columns and the rest of the columns
should be left as they are
now there is a huge possibility that
sometimes unknowingly or unwillingly
there might be some edits done by your
colleague or your subordinate so to
avoid such kind of unexpected mistakes
you might want to protect and lock
yourselves that you don't want your
subordinate or your colleague to edit
now without further ado let's get
started with our one point agenda that
is lock or protect cells in excel now
let's get back into the practical mode
and start our microsoft excel now we are
on the microsoft excel and this
particular spreadsheet is related to
employee details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better
now let us imagine that this is our
confidential data
and you want to edit only two columns
that is the designation column and phone
number call now let us imagine that the
company has finished one annual year and
now there are some promotions happening
in the company and let us also imagine
that the phone numbers of the employees
provided by the company have undergone
some changes
so now the minor edits that you want to
make are related to the designation
column and phone number column
now you can see that all the columns
that is the blood group new salary
salary hike current salary and name of
the employee serial number employee
number everything is editable so in such
kind of scenarios when you pass on this
data there might be a possibility where
your colleague or subordinate might end
up making some mistakes right so you
want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename the sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can lock the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to lock the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password
now when you select all the cells in
this particular sheet you can just click
on this edge here and you have all the
cells selected and now right click
somewhere on the sheet and you can see
an option called format cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see
by default excel
keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns d
and i
and now let's right click
and
go into format cells and in the
protection option make sure that you
uncheck the locked icon
now select ok and now
okay so you cannot include the merged
itself fine we have a cell here which is
merged
okay let's remove that
okay now again select the entire column
right click
get into format cells
and uncheck the lock option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get edit and unlocking the cells
where you want to make some edits now
the second stage is protecting the sheet
now right click on the sheet name and
you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select log cells and also select
unlock cells so let us provide a
password here so
let us use some simple password so that
we don't forget that so i will be
selecting one two three
and now select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type 123 again now select ok and now
the sheet is protected
now we have successfully
locked and protected all the cells in
excel now let us verify that the cells
you wanted to protect are really
protected and locked or not so we have
unlocked phone number and designation
and everything else is locked now let me
try and edit the blood group so when i
double click or try to edit this
particular sheet then i'll be receiving
a warning from excel it says the cell or
chart you're trying to change is on a
protected sheet to make a change
unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unlocked
so you can see i can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable
now let us go through the designation
column and try to
edit this particular column now since i
said that there is a promotion happening
in the company so the deputy ceo is now
the current ceo of the company
and the software developer happens to
become the senior software developer
and the tester as well
let us imagine that he will become the
senior
and so on
okay
so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
now this is how you lock and protect
your cells in excel
hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel today we will be
discussing what is goal seek in excel
i hope most of the viewers will be
having the basic knowledge of ms excel
and some of the fundamentals like what
is paid setup etc if not don't worry
about that you will find the links in
the description box below which will
redirect you to those tutorials
now to understand what exactly is goal
setting in excel we will have to get
into the practical mode and get started
with that tutorial with the one pointer
agenda that is goal sake in excel
so for this tutorial we'll be
considering the students database
now let's get back to the excel
so now we are on the excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names role
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like math science computer
statistics social gk and the final marks
obtained percentage and total marks
right
so let us imagine that
a company has come for an interview so
all these students are going to attend
an interview and the minimum percentage
to attend the interview will be like 75
percent so you can see that we have 75
here and all the students have got above
75 except for the one student which is
mike
right so for mike to attend the
interview he needs 75 percentage or apa
so he can make some modifications in one
of these subjects right so there is
always an
exam after the exam called as
improvement exam so if you can
like to score some extra marks in the
subjects which you have scored less so
that you can make up to the percentage
what you're expecting you can do that so
here in this particular sheet
uh mike has six subjects right and in
six subjects you can see he has scored
76 91 45 71
94 and 62. so out of these he have
scored less in one subject
compared to all the subjects one subject
is really low that is computers
so
what if he can give an improvement exam
and increase his percentage to 75 right
so that can be done
so if we can do some brute force methods
like we can change the marks like 55 and
then check this particular one so it's
getting 74 right so using the brute
force method will be a little bit
lengthy
so
you can do this because it is just a
small table which has least number of
data and you just have one single cell
to modify so that can be done in small
tables but what if you had some table
with hundreds of rows or thousands of
rows that will be time consuming right
so for that we have some inbuilt
functionality in excel that is called
goal seek in excel
so for now let's eliminate the marks
here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65 now we need
the target as 75. okay so let's
write it as
mike's target right we need mike so
mike's
new target as
75
[Music]
okay
now to make sure that we need a mark
here which can get mic to 75 percentage
we will use the data operation so here
on the toolbar which has file
home
insert etc we have one other option
called as data so when you click on data
from toolbar you'll have this ribbon and
in this ribbon we have various options
so when you come into forecast group we
have an option called what if analysis
when you click on what-if analysis you
will have a set of options out of which
we have goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is m9
so we need the value 75 here right so
what is the cell that you need to change
here for that you need to select this
one and select this particular cell here
right and now you can select ok
now you can see that excel has
automatically run all the permutations
and combinations and has come up with a
number so that the overall percentage of
mic will be 75
right so the expected marks that
mike should be getting in his computer's
improvement exam should be equal to 56
or greater than 56 to get the final
target as 75 so that he can attend the
company's interview so this is how we
use goal set or goal seek in excel
in this session we will be discussing
about how to create a barcode in excel
now without further ado let's get
started with our one point agenda that
is how to create a barcode in excel
now for this let's get on to the
practical mode by starting our microsoft
excel
now we're on the practical mode that is
mfxn
now you can see that we have the first
column that is a column and the first
set of that is text and all the other
cells are
numbers but as a whole excel considers
the whole column as a general data
format so why are we discussing about
this so to create a barcode in excel you
have to make sure that all the elements
in the column are of text and data type
so the first step is to convert this
general data type to
text data type so you can do that by
going into the data type and selecting
text and now all the elements in your
first column a are type text
now the next step is
to convert these elements into barcode
now for that let's create a new column
called barcode
now our new column that is barcode has
been created
now the next step would be is to check
for the barcode font so the barcode font
looks something like this
but let me remind you the barcode font
in excel is not available by default
don't worry if it's not available we can
download it from open source
so let's go back to google
so on the google you want to search
for barcode font for excel
so the one that i would recommend is
three of nine barcode font
now you can download this phone by just
clicking on the download button over
here
now i've already downloaded this font on
my local system let's now try to install
that
now the 309 barcode folder will come in
the form of zip folder you have to unzip
that
and after unzipping you'll get the setup
file which looks something like this
which is three of nine new
select that and you'll be having the
installer file over here you can install
by selecting the install button over
here
so i have already installed it in my
local system so it is readily available
for me on my microsoft excel
now we might want to create the barcode
for this particular cell in a2
so let's create that so to create a
barcode we need to write in a formula
that is equals to
double quotes
star
double quotes and
ampersand symbol address of the cell
that is a2 another ampersand symbol
again double quotes
star symbol
and double quotes
so you can either use this or instead of
star you can use bracket system
so let's try brackets
now select enter
now this will generate another type of
code in your resultant cell
now we will change the font for this
particular resultant cell and we will
get our barcode
now you can just drag all these cells so
that you can apply the formula to all
the codes and i got all the codes over
here
now select all the cells get into the
fonts and here select the barcode font
and there you go you have the barcode
for all the
numbers you have in your column a so
that's how you create barcode in excel
we will learn about progress tracker in
excel
now let us imagine that you are the ceo
of an it company and you have taken up
multiple projects
let us imagine that you wish to keep
track of all the projects
so what if there was a tool which could
keep track of all the projects in the
form of a detailed visualization with
the percentage in the form of a graph or
a bar chart interesting right that's
exactly what we are going to design
today using microsoft excel
so without further ado let's get started
with our one point agenda that is
progress tracker in excel now to design
a progress tracker in excel let us get
back to the practical mode where we
might have to use our microsoft excel
now we are on the microsoft excel and we
have taken some sample data to make
things look simple so here we are
considering a set of students and their
attendance percentage so we will be
using this particular data and design a
progress tracker
now let us try to increase the size of
the cells
now select all the cells in the
attendance column
now we have selected all the cells in
the attendance column and in the toolbar
select the home tab
and inside the home tab you have styles
group inside the styles group select
conditional formatting and inside the
conditional formatting option
select new rule
so in the new rule we want to select the
first option that is format all cells
based on the values
now here you can see format style
since we are trying to create a database
we need to select the option of database
here
and
under the data bar options we have some
more options on the drop down menu
so here in the type select number
and
the minimum number is zero it is
automatically stored here
and the maximum value is again a number
and let us provide it as one
now here you can select the color for
your pass
now since we have already chosen green
for all the column headers let's choose
blue
and
select ok
now here you can see that the
values are being indicated using
bar graphs right and you can also see
the percentage values
but we can make it look a little more
better by shifting them to the left side
and
text could be given as white
so that it's more
uh vibrant to look at and now we can
also apply some conditional formatting
onto these attendance columns
so let us try to highlight the students
having attendance less than 65 percent
so highlight sell heroes
less than
65 percent attendance
with red color select okay
and there you go
you have the progress tracker right on
your screen
and using the same principles you can
track the attendance for all the
students
and also you can apply some conditional
formatting onto all your cells and
highlight the ones which are not on the
track now this is how you can implement
progress trackers using excel
i guess most of the viewers have the
basics and fundamentals of ms excel if
not then there is a link in the
description box below which will
navigate you to the basics of ms excel
from simply learn however there might be
most of the scenarios where you want to
represent your data in the most readable
and understandable format in the form of
a hard copy that is a printed copy but
there might be chances that your data
might not fit to your page or there
might be chances that the format of your
data is not in proper condition to get
printed so this video is all about the
same today we will learn how to set up
page and ms excel
so before we begin i would like to tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies if you are a tech
geek and a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the one point
agenda for today's session that is page
setup in ms excel
so to understand the page setup in ms
excel we will go through a demo
inventory in excel where we'll be
considering some restaurant data
now without any delay let's get started
with the practical demo
now we are on the excel sheet and this
is the data i was talking about the
restaurant data where we have the first
column that is rank and next we have the
restaurant name followed by that we have
the sales happening through that
restaurant and then we have the segment
category that is what kind of service
does that particular restaurant offers
now this is the list what we made and
what if we wanted to represent this data
in the form of a printed paper
right so i guess you can see all the
columns and rows here so you can see
that we have almost like 250 rows
so there is no chance or there is no way
to print all those 250
rows in one page of course it is
practically possible but
when you try to read the content it will
be so tough to read because all the rows
will be clubbed together so closely so
that you cannot read it
so uh you need to print them page by
page so and you need to also take care
of the data is aligned properly
according to the page size everything
and even you need to take care of the
margins of your page right so that's
what page setup basically means
so we had a detailed overview of our
data and what actually we are trying to
make now let us see how paid setup is
possible in ms excel so to go to the
page setup menu or go to the page setup
options we have three methods let's
start with the simplest method so the
simplest method is by just clicking on
file and go to print option
and you'll see all the page setup
options right over here
and
you can also go to print menu by
pressing a shortcut method that is
control p
so you'll directly end up on the page
setup options now let's look at the
second method
so the second method is you can see the
toolbar over here right which has file
home insert draw page layout formulas
data
review
view and help
so the second method we can use page
layout option from the toolbar
and you can see when you click on the
page option from the toolbar you have a
new ribbon over here so this ribbon is
all about page setup options so it will
offer you margins it will offer you
orientation size print area breaks
background print tiles etc etc right so
all these options or menus in this
ribbon belong to page setup
now let us look at the third method so
the third method is something similar
you have view option on the toolbar so
just select a view
and you can see we have few page setup
options over here as well the normal
page break page layout custom views and
we have grid lines formula bar heading
zoom and zoom out select to zoom free
certain panes right so all these are
also the page setup options so we have
the three methods to enter the page
setup options now we are familiar with
those now let's get started with the
practical mode on page setup for that
let me use the simplest method that is
holding the control key and pressing p
which navigates me to the print option
now we have various set of options here
we have no scaling normal margins letter
portrait orientation collated print
active sheets and
note 1 for windows you can see this
option is the printers option for
example if you are connected to a
printer
which is the hardware printer then your
ms excel will show the printer's name
here so other than printer you can also
make some other arrangements where you
can just directly print your complete
data in the form of pdf and then you can
export your pdf to your recipient that's
also possible
okay now let's get started with the
first option that is print active pages
okay to understand this better we need
to create a new sheet
not a problem
so you can see that we just have one
sheet over here
so let us kind of select all the items
and create a new sheet and try to paste
it over here
or let's try to paste it over here
okay
now let's try to extend these
yeah this should be fine now let's
rename this sheet
sheet
or
let's rename it
as restaurant
sheet 2
for our reference now let us get back to
the print sheet option so i'll use the
shortest method that is holding the
control key and press p now you can see
that here we have six pages in total
from the active sheets so the current
active sheet is
the top 250 sheet so this particular
sheet is the current active sheet so if
we print the entire data in this
particular sheet then we will end up
printing six pages now let us select the
other option where you have to print the
entire workbook
right so now you can see that there's a
change in the number that is 12 pages so
what is a workbook so basically workbook
is the collection of entire sheets in
your excel home page so in this
particular excel homepage you have the
first sheet that is top 250 and the
second shade that is the restaurant
sheet 2 right so the combination of
these two sheets make up a workbook
so when you select the entire workbook
option you'll have 12 pages so that's
how we use this setting where you select
the active sheets the entire workbook
and there is another option where you
can only print a selected item
so if you want to do this then let's get
back here
now
what if your customer or what if your
client wanted the top 10 restaurants
only so you can select the top 10
restaurants
by
doing this
now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to print
so you can see excel has automatically
selected the selection only print the
selected content only so you can see we
have only the top 10 restaurants or top
11 restaurants that we have selected in
our sheet and it is ready to get printed
so this is how we use the first option
now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again
now you can see the next option that is
collated
right so in collated you have different
different options that is one two three
one two three and one two three and the
next one which is uncorrelated one one
one two two two three three three so why
are these numbers present here and what
does collated mean anyway so this is
your question right now the answer for
this question will be a little
similar to your examination hall okay
let us imagine that you are an
examination hall
and you are the invigilator and you have
10 students in your room
so you wanted to provide question papers
to all the 10 students
okay so you have your question paper
distributed into three sheets that is
you have marked questions and your
questions are fit into three papers
right in this scenario we have 250 rows
and all the data is split into six
sheets that is sheet 1 or page 1 page 2
page 3 page 4 right now if you wanted to
print 10 copies then the arrangement of
papers will be page 1 page 2 page 3 page
4 page 5 page 6 in continuous order
right that is collated if you wanted 10
copies of different different ways where
you wanted to print the first sheet
first then you wanted to print the
second sheet second and the third sheet
third that is you'll have 10 copies of
first page 10 copies of second page 10
copies of third page and so on that
particular approach is called uncollated
approach and if you're printing the
pages in continuous order for 10 times
then that particular approach is called
as correlated approach so this is what
we had to learn about collated and
uncollated now let's get back to the
third option
now let's press again print now we have
our data over here
there's something wrong
select all the elements control p
yeah now we have our data pack
now we have the third option that is the
portrait orientation
okay so when we click that we have two
options that is portrait and landscape
so you might be having a good idea like
when you try to click a picture in your
phone we have two modes as well that is
portrait mode and the landscape mode so
when you click on the portrait mode this
is how your data will be looking
now to understand the difference
let's click the landscape mode so when
you click the landscape mode this is how
your data representation will change
you'll have a wider page to print so
this is why we use the page orientation
for now let's keep the page orientation
as portrait orientation
and we have now the fourth option so
what is the fourth option we have
various sets of options in here that is
letter and a4 size there are also some
more page options over here where you
can select
the page types you want to print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is a4 a5 a3 etc but here we
just have two that is a4 and letter so
basically you'll get those options and
followed by that next we have margins so
here you can see we don't have any
margins for our data
okay so now we can add some margins by
setting up this one as an option like
last custom setting or you can also
choose normal wide narrow
right so your page will be changed
according to your margin size
right so this is how you can change the
margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the
normal one
now we have the next option that is
scaling option
so here you can see we are trying to fit
the page so when you're trying to print
these sheets using no scaling then the
actual size of the page will be printed
now you can also modify that you can fit
and print the sizes so you can remember
the first option that i said of printing
all the 250 rows in one single sheet
this is how you can fit it so fit the
sheet on one page where you can see all
the 250 rows are fit into one page but
the data is not readable so but we don't
want this type of an approach right so
let's keep it as the default one which
is no scaling so these are the variety
of options in print
now if you wanted to print the all the
six pages into the pdf format and mail
it to your client you can also do that i
think i have explained it in the first
place so you can see we can do it by
just selecting this option where you can
print all the
six pages and into pdf format and then
you can mail them to your client
and you can also select the number of
copies you want you can increase the
copies to 2 3 and any number of
copies you want for now i'll keep it as
one copy
[Music]
now let's print this
now let us select the
location
rename it and publish
now let's get back to documents and see
if the page is printed or not
here you go here we have the restaurant
data in the form of pdf
so we have our entire six pages of data
in the pdf format
now we are back on the home page now we
had some limited functions in the print
functions over here we have tried to
export the data so you can also export
the data or try to print it from the
print option over here you can just
select that as well
yes the pages are printed now
there you go we have the restaurant to
pdf data
so that's how you can print all your
data you can either choose
the export option or you can either
choose print option
now when you see into the print option
we have limited number of page setup
options over here
now let's check out what we missed
so we are in the page layout here so we
had gone through the margins we had set
all the margins and then we have also
gone through the portrait and landscape
now you can see this size when we were
in the print menu option we had only a4
and letter but here you can see there
are a wide variety of options that is
other than letter we have tabloid legal
statement executed a3
right we have a5 and many more other
options and if you want some more paper
options you can go to more and you can
always select few more options
that's how you do it
and yeah we didn't had the break option
so remember when we had been through the
print option we did not have the break
option there
let's select this to normal a4 so you
cannot see the break option over here
right so here we have the break option
so what does break option does right you
can actually break the page
remember we spoke about the top 10
things or the top 10 rules you can
always do that so you can just keep the
top 10 restaurants in your first page
and then break the remaining after set
page breaks you can select the cell now
i need the top 10 so i'll select this
particular cell which is in the 11th
position
and now i'll try to implement the page
break insert a page break and now you
can see on my sheet there is a thin line
which is separating the two pages that's
how you can see the indication of a page
break implemented onto your page now how
do you say it you can see it by
selecting control p where you can see
the first top 10
restaurants being printed on your sheet
so there you go we have the first top 10
restaurants printed on our sheets so
that's how you use the page break
now let's try to eliminate all the page
breaks so you can select
breaks and
reset all page tricks so the page break
has been eliminated
now you can always choose a background
for your data as well you just
if you want you can add a picture to
your background i think that's not
available for now
okay you can work offline as well
let us select this one
so you can see that we have added a
background to our data
we can select all the
text files and then we can change the
color so that the text becomes a little
visible
yeah that's how you do it
now if you don't want the image to be
added on your file you can also remove
that delete page background and there
you go all the images are gone
now the next important part that is the
print titles
now why do we need print titles for that
let's try to print this
so now you can see the first page in the
first page we have the title rank
restaurant sales segment category but if
you go to the second page you don't have
that title right you don't have the
title rank name of the restaurant sales
and their service category so if we want
that then we need to add titles
now for that let's select the print
titles option
now
let's select the rows to repeat on top
now for that we need the first row
select the first row and this particular
row will be repeating into all the pages
now let's try to print it
so yeah now you can see the
titles are being added to all the sheets
you can see the page two page three page
four page five and page six so you can
see the titles added to all the sheets
so that's how you use the print titles
option
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of microsoft excel
so basically when you install the
microsoft office in your computer you
will have various microsoft products out
of which microsoft excel is one of the
product so we will be dealing exactly
with that particular product that is
microsoft excel
let's get started with our one point
agenda that is mis reports in excel so
first let's understand what exactly is
mis report in excel
so mis stands for management information
system mis reports provide data on
different categories for accurate
decision making
so mis in excel is a procedure to create
interactive report using microsoft excel
so mis reports help management to access
the performance of organization and
allow faster decision making so if you
know to create the mis reports using
various business intelligence tools such
as excel then you might find a very good
job opportunity in a well established
company now let us try to learn how to
create mis report using excel in a
practical mode so let's get back to the
microsoft excel if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here you can see that i've got some
sales data of various car manufacturing
companies and i've also got some slices
so using these slices i can get the
real-time information from the dashboard
so i'll select an ear from the first
slicer and i'll go into the second
slicer and i'll select a company
now i'll select bmw and suv type so we
have the data of all the suv types
cars manufactured by bmw car
manufacturing company in the year 2018.
now let's start and create something
similar to this one
so how did i create this mis report
let's go through this in a step-by-step
way
so on my screen you can see that we have
created a completely new excel workbook
and we have some sample data
with 5 rows and 20 columns
so this particular data is based on the
manufacturer year and the car
manufacturing company and the type of
the car manufactured and number of cars
manufactured in that particular year and
also the price of that particular car
now to create mis reports we need to
play around favorite tables so we also
have tutorials on pivot tables and you
can go through that in our simply learn
youtube channel and also we will try to
link those in the description box below
now let's select the entire data
and go into the insert ribbon
and there you can see the first option
that is pivot table
so after selecting the pivot table
option it will show this particular
dialog box where it will ask you for the
range of cells you need to select and
the next one is to
create the pivot table in this same
sheet or a new sheet so we'll take a new
sheet here
now select ok and there you have the
pivot table here so first you have an
empty pivot table and on the right side
you can see we have pivot table fields
now you can either drag these options
into the rows and columns or you can
also click it so now let's drag and drop
these
first we will select here
and
card followed by that we will take type
quantity and price to columns
so there you go we have our pivot table
now
let's select all the data in the pivot
table
and again let's get back to the insert
option
and here you can see an option called
pivot chart select that
and you will have various pivot chart
options here now you can select any one
which you can prefer or which you like
or whichever you think can represent
your data in a best way possible so now
let's go with column chart first
let's select okay and we have our column
chart over here
now this happens to be our first chart
now let's create a few more charts
so to create few more charts we will go
back to the same original data
select again insert and pivot table
now again a new worksheet
so here we have another empty pivot
table in the similar way let's drag the
same
data into rows and columns
there you go and again we will select
all the data and create a pivot chart
go to insert option
pivot chat and now let's try to select
pie
chart select ok
and we have our pie chart over here
now let's try to create one more
same procedure select table select pivot
table then create new worksheet for the
new pivot table
and now drag and drop the data
now let's go to insert again
let's select all the data
go to insert option and pivot chart
now let's try to select the bar chart
select ok and there we have our bar
chart
now
remember the first chart we created that
is in sheet 2 this one so we will try to
move all the charts to this particular
table or this particular worksheet
so let's get back to the sheet number
three right click
and you can see an option called pivot
chart analyze so from here you can move
the chart select the option of moving
the chart and don't select the first one
select the object in option and select
the sheet number to which you want to
move this chat for now we want to move
this chart to sheet number 2 select that
press ok
now we have the chart moved to the sheet
number 2
and in the same way let's go to the
sheet number four
and let's move this particular chart to
sheet number two
there you go the chart got moved to
sheet number two
now
you can insert the slices so we have
selected the third sheet or third chart
and inside the pivot chart analyze
option we have an option of inserting
the slicer now
we will insert the slices for ear
car
and
type
now select ok and you will have all the
three slices onto your sheet
now let's rearrange them
so i'm just organizing them in a
neat way
there you go
and you can also customize your designs
for all the charts
so that they look a little more better
now
if you see
if i make some changes only one chart
will be interacting for this
right so if i select ferrari and year
2020 and
option as sports you can see only one
chart is interacting to these particular
slices why because all these slices are
connected to just one chart here so you
need to make sure that all the slices
are connected to all the three charts
what we created so let's erase all the
filters and select one slicer at a time
right click and you will see an option
of report connections
select that and you see that the
connections are only connected to the
pivot table 3. so select the remaining
pivot tables as well select ok and in
the same way select the second slicer
select the report connection option
connect pivot table 1 and 2 and select
ok and in the same way the third one
so now all the slices are connected to
all the pivot charts now if you make
some changes here they will respond
automatically in the same way
now let's select the fourth company the
year 2019 and hatchback option and you
have all the cars which were made in the
year 2019 from ford company in the
segment of hatchback
so this was the sample data set that we
worked on now you can also work on some
complex data sets such as this
superstore data set now one thing you
need to make sure that when you're
working with excel mis they need to make
sure that all the macros are disabled on
your data set and you convert the entire
data into the regular table format of
excel right now excel is considering
this particular data as a database so
for that you need to select all the data
press ctrl t
and then convert the entire data in the
form of tabular data and also don't
forget to click this icon which reads my
table has headers so the first row is
the headers now let's select ok and your
entire data will be converted into
tabular form
now let's reset this to the normal
type which has the clear color not all
the fancy colors now the entire data is
converted from the dbms to the tabular
form and now you can start implementing
the mis reports and pivot tables so
that's how you work on mis report in
excel
microsoft excel let's look at an example
of
one more useful function
in excel and that is vlookup now vlookup
is used to see if a value exists in a
range of values and we can create a
range of values which is nothing but
a block of cells which has a name
and can be referenced so
mainly to use vlookup we need to create
a named range
and that can be referenced anywhere in
the workbook or the other option is you
can always drag and select
the range of data in which you would
want to search something now there is
also
uh other functions such as hlookup which
pretty much does the same thing however
it does it horizontally that is left to
right instead of vertically there are
other functions like lookup and x lookup
and so on so when we talk about vlookup
let's see how we do that so for example
this is the range of or this is the data
which has been given to you and here is
the question find the employee name with
employee id 107. now assume that you
might have huge amount of data and you
may want to search something so how do
we do it now here i have created some
column and then some basic formatting i
have given it as employee id i have
given employee name now what i can do is
i can create a range of data now how do
i do that or a named range so what you
can do is you can select the data and
then you can do a right click now here
you have something like get data from
table range so you can do that you can
define a name
so you can click on this
and here you can give a
name to the range what you would want to
call it so for example let's say our
search
now that's the named range i'm creating
and just say
okay so the scope is workbook and i have
created a named range which you can see
here so it shows for search our search
so you have created a named range now
how do we do a vlookup here so for that
we can use a formula so for example i
would want to search for employee name
where employee id is whatever you would
want to search for so employee id we can
give here 107. now that's what we would
want to search the employee name for
and employee name is what we are
interested now what we can do is we can
use the function
option here i can do a insert function
and that shows me different functions
which are here now vlookup is showing up
because i have recently searched for it
or
you can basically just type in here look
and you can do a go so that shows you
all the look of options what you have
like look up h look up match vlookup and
so on so we would be interested in
vlookup so let's select that and click
on ok
now that basically opens up this
function arguments and it shows what
does this function do so it says looks
for a value in the leftmost column of a
table
and then returns a value in the same row
from a column you specify
by default the table must be sorted in
an ascending order now you can
basically say this is what you would
want to search for what is the lookup
value if you place your cursor here it
says what is the table array that is
nothing but the range which we can use
our named range here we have the column
index number which basically tells me
what is the column number in the range
which we want so what is the value we
want from which column and then
basically you have range lookup which
basically is the fourth option
and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to give a particular value
which is nothing but
we would be interested in say employee
name
so i can
basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it so we are
saying we would want to search for
employee id which is 107. so what i can
do is i can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee id for which i would want to
search the employee name i could
actually select the cell here which is h
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so might
be we can select this one which is h6
and whatever value we key in here we
will be searching for employee name for
that employee id
now table array is we would want to give
a range so what we can do is we can give
our range so for example we had selected
something like our search
and if you see here that already selects
or shows me employee id employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now
column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so i can just
say 2
and that basically is the column number
and then you have to give a range lookup
which is a logical value so either you
give an exact match or
you can basically give a
closest match so we can say for example
do a 0 which basically means false or
you can say 1 which is true so let's go
for 0 now that's our formula so it says
vlookup
you will search for the value as per h6
in the range and then you are looking
for employee name which is column number
two and then true or false so let's
click on ok
and that basically gives me the value
which is parallel
birch
so here i'm searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this
for other columns and you can do that so
if it finds
employee
id here now say for example if we had an
employee id somebody enters an employee
id which is not in the range for example
let's try 121 and then you see this is
basically an error right because
it does not have any employee id with
121 now how do i take care of this so
there is a formula which is called if
error and that can be used to take care
of this
so if the value is not found then it
will show whatever i would want to
show here so what i can do is i can
still select this
and what i can do is i can search in
function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do is
we can test it here so for example if i
look in function and if i search for
error and say oh
go so there are lots of functions here
and this is the function we are
interested in if error so if i say ok
now this takes the value and what is the
value if error so for value what i can
do is basically i can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula and value if error
so for example i will basically say for
example not found so we can try this and
we can say okay now here it says not
found so whenever it is n a it is not
found
now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of h7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if i would say
107
like earlier
and then hit on enter so it says panel
of cruise and it shows us the value
right and if we enter something else
then basically
here it shows any and it shows not found
but what we want to do is we want to
merge these two so what i can do is i
can get rid of
or i can basically take this one
now
what i would want is i want this formula
to
be here
so what i can do is i can say if error
and then
basically
given your vlookup
option or function here and then say for
example not found here
not found now that basically will take
care of any kind of error if the value
is not found so when we say 121 it
basically says not found but if i say
107 which is found then it shows me the
value so we are using vlookup but then
we are also using if error which will
take care of our error message or
basically the not applicable
pound not applicable replaced with
whatever value we key in
similarly we can do the same thing here
so we have the find the job title so we
are interested in finding out the job
title once the employee name is given
now employee name can basically have a
value from the cell or whatever value
you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with our v lookup so that's the
function we are interested in
so you can just do a double click now
you are interested in finding out the
value whichever is given here
so that's the lookup value
and then you are interested in
finding out the job title from the range
so i will still give our range which
basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range and now i'm interested
in finding out the job title so that's
column number
four
and then i can just give 0 which is for
false
so now we have given our vlookup but
that shows not applicable because we
have not given any employee name so we
can key in the value here which says
fred stone and now
if we are basically giving the value so
fred stone now
we will have to search if there is any
job title which is fred stone so here is
the value so that should be showing up
let's check what has gone wrong so we
are giving our range
we are interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was
that when we want to search for a value
say for example let's take this vlookup
and let's replace this value of h2l with
the
value here so fred stone
and then basically
we will give our range we will save
which is the column we are interested in
and then give true or false so we can
also
basically take care of this error
message so for example let's take this
complete formula from here
and just
copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for h6 which was employee id now that's
not what we are interested in we are
interested in finding out the value
so let's take this one and replace this
with
the value given here
and then i give my range
i save which is the column i'm
interested in so i'm interested in
looking for job title
and then let's search so it basically
tells me
not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example
i go for function and then i select
vlookup and say for example i say okay
now just look at the description here
looks for a value in the leftmost column
of a table
now earlier the range which we had
selected had the left most column as
employee id and that's why it was giving
an error so how do we fix that so for
example let's
basically
remove this function from here
now what we want to do is we would want
to search for the stock broker now if
you see here
i have given a range which is b
1 to d 21
so we would want
the value for what we would want to
search say employee name that should be
the left most column so
so that's how
we have our function so let's do that so
say for example the name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data now am i
interested in salary no i'm interested
in job title right so i can basically
just select these three columns
and then i can define a name so i can
say our
search
to
and let's give a named range and that's
only because we would want to easily
reference or use that named
search or name range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say v
lookup
and then
you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes
so basically this is my function we will
say if the value is not found
then we will give this so you can create
an external structure
and then within your vlookup we will say
the leftmost column which we are
interested in
so
that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either i can directly select the value
here in the column b or i will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name
then i need to give a range so let's
select our range so that's your hour
search too
and then you need to select the column
number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give a
zero
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name
now
let's
try to find the job title of fred stone
so i can just select or i can say equal
and then i can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup
we have also used if error which
basically takes care of error message if
the value is not found so for example we
can test this
here we have fred stone
so for example
if i
just empty this and i point it to
something which does not exist so that
shows me not found or if you just select
this and then key in a value it shows
you this might be we can just type in so
if i say fred
then basically it says not found because
we are looking for exact match
now if we had changed this to the
closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this so there are different ways of
doing it so what we can do is we can
always go for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example i would be interested
in finding out
this one
and let's give this so you can search in
this way so you can also have statements
which can be searching one related to
other
now here the question was to find the
job title of fred stone so let's type in
fred stone and that basically shows me
the job title which we are interested in
so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interesting to see how
horizontal lookup or edge lookup works
it basically works in the on the same
lines but here instead of
vertically searching through the columns
the range is more of horizontally
defined so we search
in rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee id you have
your employee name you have employee
email address
you basically have the job title of
different employees
and then basically you have the salary
so this is the data which has been given
to you
and you are asked to search or you are
interested in finding out say the salary
based on employee name or job title
based on employee id so what we need to
do is we need to define the range here
now range can depend on what you are
searching for so for example when i am
searching employee name and salary so i
am interested in these four rows when i
am saying employee id and job title then
might be this is the range and i don't
need salary so i can create a named
range if we are interested in so that we
can easily search for it or we can
straight away give
the the first cell value which is
basically a one here
and then the last
value here which is g and then you can
give five so you can do that or you can
create a named range whichever way you
would want to do it so for example we
would want to create a named range for
our first question which is
find the salary of edin connell using h
lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now like we did earlier we can
just define a name might be we can call
it
our search three
and we can just give okay so that's the
named range which we have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name so here we can insert our function
so let's look up
and let's search for look
and just click on go so here you have h
lookup and basically that's the function
i'm interested in say okay so this says
what is the lookup value which you are
interested in so we are interested in
finding out the value based on the
employee name
so for example let's select this cell
that gives us more dynamism and you can
add in any name and you can search for
the salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is d
2 so we can give eden conal from here
so let's select this now table array so
we need to give our range so let's say
our search 3
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name to salary so let's give
the row index number which is four and
the range lookup will say zero which is
basically exact match and that completes
our formula so click on ok and that
basically gives me the salary for edin
corner
now that's basically because we have fed
in the value here
and that is basically giving me this
so i can again
do if error if i would be interested in
to basically take care of error message
if the value is not found for that you
can look into the previous example which
is vlookup now similarly we are
interested in finding out the job title
for employee id 1 0 5 how do we do that
so we need to use hlookup well we could
have done with vlookup but here the data
is more arranged in the form of rows
so how do we do that so we can again use
hlookup but and we can give a range
or named range or let's for this time
let's basically
key in our range manually so we can do
that so let's go for h lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value
then we need to give a range now as i
said if you would want to give a range
manually so for example i'll say a
and then i'll say a
1
colon
and then i'm interested in
g and then the row will be 4 so salary
row is not what we are we are not
interested in so let's say g
and then we can give 4 so that basically
gives me the range
right instead of having a named range so
we can do that and then we need to give
the row index number so we are
interested in finding out the job title
which is basically in our range the
fourth row and then give 0 for true or
false
so if you see here it tells if it is 1
it is approximate match
false is an exact match and we can close
this bracket that completes our formula
it takes the value which is given in
employee id and then it will try to
search for the job title so that
basically shows wherever the employee id
is 105 the job title is fabricator again
you can use if error
wherein
your if error can then be working on h
lookup and can take care of error so
that if an employee id is keyed in
for which there is no matching value
then
it will
not show you
a not applicable error in
instead of that it will replace with the
word whatever you have specified so in
this way you can easily use hlookup to
search
from the range of data which is
horizontally arranged and in the
previous example we were seeing how you
use
vlookup when the data is arranged
vertically
so we have looked at
vlookup and hlookup and what we have
seen is vlookup has a limitation in one
way that
we need to basically give a range where
the leftmost column is the one which is
used now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for
so for example we have this question
find the salary of hank saunders
now that's the employee name which we
have here and we would want to find out
the salary so what are the columns we
are interested in so one is your
employee name and one is your salary and
these are the only two columns which we
are interested in so instead of using
vlookup now like i've shown earlier you
can create a named range for these two
columns and you can use that or we can
manually give the range here so let's go
for lookup function here and lookup
function will basically help us in
searching what we are interested in so
we are interested in finding out the
employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup i can
first give the value which is here
employee name
now
whatever
employee name is keyed in here we will
be searching for salary of that employee
now lookup function needs a lookup value
so
we are searching
based on employee name then it says look
up vector so we will basically then say
what is going to be our lookup vector so
here we need to give a range so what are
we interested in we are interested in
finding out the salary based on employee
name so first goes our range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example
select this one so that's our range b1
to b21
so that will basically have the employee
name in which we will be searching for
and then we are interested in searching
out the
the result vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this
and that completes our lookup function
so now if you hit on enter it shows
that for this employee where the name is
hunk saunders the salary is 5400 now you
can test it by
basically giving some other name so for
example if i replace this with say
fred stone
and that basically shows me the value
for fred stone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is hank
saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
left most column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee id
of
this particular email id so we need to
again use our lookup function so we'll
say lookup now what are we interested in
we will search based on this email
address so i will select this
then i need to give
that based on email address we are
searching the employee id so email
address is in this column so let's
select this range and then we are
interested in employee id so then goes
our result vector so select this column
and that basically completes your
formula so close this bracket and hit on
enter so that basically shows me the
employee id for an employee with this
email address so this is how you use
lookup now as i have explained earlier
you can be using the if error and you
can basically see how
your index match can be used now here is
an example of if error
so basically this shows how if error
helps so say for example as i showed in
your sheet 1 so check for employee james
bond if the value is not present display
not found and what are we doing we are
basically nesting our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value
given in the cell h
is not found then basically
it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is b1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for multiple functions
we are searching for 2 that is the
column number 2 here that is employee
name so check for employee james bond if
the value is not present or no so we are
basically just searching for employee
name
here and then give your 0 or 1. so
that's basically usage of your if error
which i have shown earlier and the same
thing can be applied for your edge
lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example
you know instead of using your vlookup
or hlookup or look up examples what we
have seen
say for example you are asked to find
the salary of peter daniels now we
already know how to find that using
vlookup right so for example we want to
find out the salary for this employee
name which is peter daniels i can use a
vlookup however sometimes we may also
want to use a index match an index match
is also one useful function to do that
so we can basically search based on that
so we have to define the range
of data we have to then say what do we
want to match so that's basically an
employee name
and then we are interested in finding
out
say for example
based on the range
of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here i can use a
function which is called index and if
you see here it says returns a value or
reference of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so i can say a1
all the way to e21 so that basically is
my range
now i would want to find the salary of
this employee name which is peter
daniels so i can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically
give it correctly so we need to say
match
now how does this match function work so
we need to basically
match for a value so for example we'll
select whatever employee name is given
here so that's peter daniels now that's
basically what we would want to match
now where do we want to match this so we
want to match in the column b which has
employee
names so we can give a range which is b1
to be
21 so that's basically
within the employee names we are looking
for a match
which is given here that's in h6
and
we want to do a match so we want to do a
exact match so let's do a comma 0 and
then
we are interested in finding out the
salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically
completes your function and just hit on
enter so that shows me
the salary of peter daniels right so
this is an easy way when you can use the
index function remember first you give
the range
and then you need to give your matching
condition so when you say match i would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell
i will search in the range of values
which is employee names
i will find an exact match and what i'm
interested in is finding the salary for
peter daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee id with salary ten
thousand so you want to find out the
employee id
wherever the salary is ten thousand so
we are obviously looking for an exact
match now how do we do that so we can
start with our index function and within
index function we need to give a range
so for example i am interested in
finding out
say for example
our range which is a 1
2
e 21 so that's what i'm interested in
or you are actually interested in
searching
based on
say your
salary so you are interested in
searching the employee id so maybe if i
just do a 821 let's see what happens
here
now then i can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here h
13
so i will do a match for this one now i
need to give a range
so let's
basically give a range which will be we
are interested in
searching employee id based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
i will say e1 to e 21 that's what i'm
interested in searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine i mean we are interested in
finding out the employee id
based on the match which is within this
range
and
then what we would want to do is we
would want to
basically find the employee id employee
id is in my
column a so what i can do is i can
additionally give a match here
and then i can say i'm interested in the
finding out the value for employee id
and that basically needs a range so the
range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give a1
all the way to e 1
so that's the range in which we would
want to search and we would want to find
a match for employee id we want an exact
match so let's close this one and that
basically closes my match and we need to
close our index function so now that
shows me employee id where the salary is
10 000.
so this is how you can do your index
matches where you can give a range
then you can say what you need to match
within which particular column
whether it is an exact match or
approximate match and then the column
from where you are interested in finding
out the value so same thing we did here
we basically gave a complete range and
if you closely see
we were only interested in finding out
the employee id so here i gave a range
a1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out
match basically will give your lookup
value so that's h13
then we gave a range which is salary
that's what we are interested in and
then we said when we are doing a match
we are only interested in finding out
the employee id
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match
so this is how you can use index match
instead of lookup which can also give
you
some exceptions and searching for
specific columns or specific rows
now if error we have already discussed
where you nest your vlookup or h lookup
inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions hlookup
vlookup lookup or index match to search
for data
some function like this which shows up
xln dot x lookup
and then you're trying to search for
something so don't be
uh
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using
you have excel 2013 and say your friend
has a new version of excel say office
365 or excel 2016
and basically he uses your new cool
function and sends the file to you so
that's where
you will have this excellent prefix as
i'm showing up here so for example what
is the job title of xavier power is what
you would want to search and here the
function which shows up excel and x
lookup and then you are searching so
this is basically
something which is the function now if i
just select what it has selected here
and if i hit on enter it shows that this
does not work in my excel here and
that's because of the version but what i
can do is i can fix this by removing
this
details here
and that basically shows lookup we are
searching for
job title based on employee name which
is in this field h6
and then we need to give a range so we
need to give a range of names employee
name
and then basically
the
job title
range which is basically the job title
so now if i just hit on enter it gives
me the value so it's as simple as that
similarly here what is the employee id
of the person with this email we have
already looked at the lookup function so
if it shows your xlnx lookup all you
need to do is remove this and then keep
the lookup function searching for the
value
based on the range of values and then
searching for a value within a range of
values so just hit on enter and that
gives you the value and same thing goes
for this job title so what is the job
title and salary of employee name
so we have this function now what i can
do is
here i'm interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do i fix this
i can basically select this
and then just do a lookup
based on the values and it basically
says you can't change part of an array
so we can fix this
now what we need to do is we need to
basically search based on
this particular value so we will
basically say i want to do a lookup
now lookup should be based on employee
name whatever name is given here
then you need to find the job title in
salary so for job title i want to find
based on employee name so i will give a
range
and then basically i will say i'm
interested in finding out the job title
so i will give a different range
and then basically close this so
that basically shows
now this is basically because of the
function which we have here so basically
to fix this what we will have to do is
we will have to delete all the columns
here which were selected such as
employee name job title and salary
because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array now what we want to do is we want
to find the job title and salary based
on the employee name so we can do that
using lookup as we have done earlier so
we will use a lookup function now what
we are interested in finding out is the
job title based on employee name
so we can select this cell which does
not have any value
then we need to basically say
from which range or based on what you
want to search so we want to search
based on employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then
we will be interested in finding out the
job title so let's select the job title
range and that basically completes our
lookup so let's close this and hit on
enter now it says obviously error
because this does not have any value
we will fix that by giving in a value
here
same thing we can do for salary so for
example i can just drag and drop it here
and in this one
instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give so
the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name as the range
and then
we are interested in finding out
the salary so we will select this
particular range and what we are
interested in finding out is basically
employee name
or we are interested in finding out
based on employee name so let's select
this particular column and then hit or
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix
your
excel fn
error so same thing goes here so it
shows you xln is what you would want to
search might be if you don't find
something you would want to
push in name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my excel and then i have
lookup i'm searching based on h24
which is basically employee id you are
giving a range which is a2 to 821
because we would want to find
name not found
for a particular employee id so i'm
giving a range which is a2 to 821
i'm trying to search for the name which
is from b2 to b21 and then i'm giving
name not found
so
say for example we can do this lookup
but then
with lookup you don't have this direct
option what we can do is we can use if
error
if error and then basically try to
search so that gives you a lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here we are
searching for a particular range
and then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what i did was
i just use a vlookup so we know that
employee id 121 does not exist so i'm
just using if error i'm doing a vlookup
where i'm searching for the value given
in h 19
and then
i'm saying
that i would want to search from a range
which is basically b1 to c21 that is in
employee name and say
email address for example
and we would want to basically search
for
name not found so we can
instead of giving b21 or b1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just b1 to b21
we are searching in column two we are
searching for exact value and if it does
not find then it says name not found and
that's how we do it so we can always
replace and fix this excel fn
errors
if you
are
using
some spreadsheet which was or excel
which was sent by
um
someone else who is using a different
version so in this way we can use your
different lookup functions
take care of your errors use index match
welcome to this video tutorial on
vlookup in excel
vlookup is one of the most widely used
functions in microsoft excel to perform
analysis of data calculation and data
manipulation so in this video you will
learn vlookup in detail let's straight
jump into learning what is excel vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet
it allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters
now
let's look at the syntax to write a
vlookup function so vlookup takes four
parameters or arguments you can see it
here there are four arguments
in the wilker function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value the lookup value represents
the value that you are searching for
next is the table array the table array
represents two or more columns of
information the third argument is called
the column index number
now this represents the column number in
the table from which the value must be
returned the first column is 1 the
second column is 2 and so on and then
we have the fourth parameter which is
called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or zero
meanwhile if you want an approximate
match you need to enter true or one if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set
we'll understand how vlookup performs an
exact and approximate match we'll see
how vlookup is case insensitive
then we'll perform a wildcard character
search
we'll understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlookup works
so we want to find the units sold by
morgan using the data set on the left so
here you can see i have the data set it
has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date
region there's a representative column
item units there's unit cost and total
and from this table i want to find the
units that were sold by morgan if you
look at the table
at the bottom you can see the
representative name morgan and morgan
has sold
30 units
now i want to find this value using the
vlookup function so here on the right
you can see i have my lookup value which
is morgan and this is my vlookup formula
and using this formula i am getting the
result as 30. now let's go to our excel
workbook and perform all the demos one
by one so this is my excel workbook that
we are going to use for our demo
and here is the data set we'll be using
now this is the same data set that you
saw
a while ago
so this data set has
seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item there's units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
now we are going to use a chunk of this
data set and perform our vlookup
analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab all
right
so here
i'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from row 2
till row 12
is going to be our data set that we'll
use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
thomson
so here
thompson is my lookup value which means
looking at thomson i want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here
you can see we have the representatives
name
right here
and
from the table you can see thomson sold
pencil
and i want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function
so let's go ahead and write our vlookup
function
i'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item i'm going to write
my vlookup formula
to write the vlookup formula i'll write
first equal to
and
i'll write vlookup now if i hit tab it
will auto complete
all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
thomson so i'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma now it's asking to give the table
array so the table array is the table
from which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and
you can select the table array till the
end of the data set or till the column
which has the value you want to find
so here i'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till
the end of the item column
which is going to be my table array
then i'll select
the column index number so the column
index number is based on the table array
you have selected in this case my column
index number is going to be 2 because we
have selected just two columns and the
value which i am going to find is in the
second column so i'll give 2
comma
now the range lookup i'm going to give
is false because i want to find an exact
match so either you can hit tab or you
can write 0 which means false
if i close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that thomson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that thomson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time i'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that thomson has sold
so i'll write my formula equal to
vlookup i'll hit tab to autocomplete
i'll give my lookup value as thomson
comma
this time i'm choosing my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because
if you consider this table array the
item column is the second column in the
selected table array so i am going to
write it as 2 comma
the range lookup i want to give as false
because i want to find the exact match
if i close this and hit enter you can
see it has returned me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose
let's say this time i want to start my
table array from the region column which
is this column
so i want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider thomson as the lookup value
my table array should always start from
the representatives column so let's just
try this example
so i'll write vlookup
my lookup value i'm going to give it as
thomson comma
the table array as i mentioned earlier
i'm going to choose from the region
column
and let's say i'll select till the item
column give another comma and this time
my column index number is going to be 3
because
since
the table array has three columns and my
item column is the last column so i'm
going to give my column index number as
3
comma i want to get the exact match so
i'll give zero if i close the bracket
and hit enter you can see it has given
me
an error
okay
now let me just show you another method
to use vlookup in excel
so here
on the top you can see there's a
formulas tab
and under formulas tab under function
library you see
we have an option to select lookup and
reference if i click on this
and if i scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup
let's choose this
all right now here
you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here i want to select my lookup value
as
thomson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
i'll write 2
and range lookup
i'll write as false because i want the
exact match if i hit ok you can see
it has given us the exact same result so
this is one of the other ways to use
vlookup in excel now
let's move to the next sheet which is
regarding approximate match
okay
so sometimes you might have cases where
you don't have the lookup value present
in the table in those cases you can tell
vlookup to return an approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value column should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table
and my lookup value column which is
going to be the representatives column
is already sorted in ascending
order and let's see the question we have
here
so i want to find the item sold and the
unit cost for mat
so my lookup value is going to be mat
now if you see this table i don't have
the representative's name
matt anywhere in the table now using an
approximate match i want to find the
item and the unit cost so let's do it
so here under item i'll write my vlookup
formula
so i'll type vlookup i'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time my lookup value is going
to be matte so i'll select this cell
comma
my table array i'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because i want to find the
item value format
i'll give a comma
my column index number
as per the table array is going to be 2
comma
my range lookup this time i am going to
give is true or 1
so i will write 1
close the bracket
hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's say you were asked to insert
the name mat to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it
ideally you should place between qival
and morgan
since this column is already sorted mat
should appear before morgan and after
kibel so in an approximate match vlookup
will consider the previous highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before matte is ql
and hence
vlookup returned the corresponding item
purchased by kival which is binder now
similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost for
matt
again
vlookup will return
the unit cost of kibel which is 125.
let's just try it out so i'll write
vlookup
my lookup value is mat comma
my table array for this time is going to
be from representatives column
till the unit cost column i'll consider
i'll give a comma
now the column index number as per the
table array is going to be 4 i'll give
another comma and this time
i'll double click true because i want an
approximate match where close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
returned me 125 which is actually
keville's unit cost okay
we have another question
and this time i want to find the units
sold by rob
now rob is going to be
my
lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have rob
now let's see what vlookup is going to
return as the item for rob so i'll write
vlookup i'll give my lookup value as rob
comma
my table array is going to start from
the representatives column
i'll select till here i'll give a comma
my column index number is 2.
i'll give another comma
i'll double click on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why vlookup returned pen for
rob
now if you are asked to insert the
representative's name rob
into this column so ideally rob would
appear somewhere between morgan and
sorvino because
since this is
sorted in ascending order rob is
actually greater than morgan and is less
than sorvino so as you know
vlookup in an approximate match returns
the previous highest value which is
morgan here and the corresponding item
for morgan is pen and hence vlookup
returned pen for rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
your lookup value is on the left in this
case
it is the representative's value and i
have taken sorvino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
sorvino
now if you consider this table your
lookup value which is so we know is
actually this column the representatives
column and we are going to find out the
order date
so your representative's name is on the
right of the table
and the value we are going to find out
is on the left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if i use the vlookup function for
this example here i'll write vlookup
i'll give my lookup value as
sorbino
comma
my table array i'll consider from the
order date because i want the order date
till
the representatives column
i'll give a comma and this time
my column index number is actually the
first column if i consider my table
array as the first three columns
selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if i close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now
if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representatives name you can do that
easily because your lookup value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this i'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
sorvino's order date so i'll select it
from the table
i'll give a comma
my table array will start from the j
column
let's say i'll select the entire table
comma
and my column index number will be 3 if
you consider these
as my table array
comma my range lookup is 0. if i close
this hit enter you can see we have got
so we know corresponding to the order
date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says
vlookup returns only the first match so
we have a question at hand the question
is
find the units sold by jardine
if you see this table
we have the representative's name jardin
twice you see here
and if you look down we have jardin here
as well
but the items sold by jardin at the
first instance is pencil and at the
second instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by jardine
you will see
vlookup will return
36 instead of 3.
let's just try it out
i'll write the vlookup function
my lookup value is jardine
comma
my table array
i'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
i'll give a comma
my column index number based on the
table array is three i'll give another
comma now i want the exact match so i'll
select zero
close the bracket and hit enter
as you can see it returns me the first
match of jardine which is
36 so vlookup did not consider the
second
match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have jones repeated thrice so you
have jones here
we have zones
here for the second time and also we
have zones for the third time
and let's say
you want to find the unit cost for jones
so if i write the vlookup function
i'll consider my
lookup value as jones comma
my table array
i'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
i'll give a comma
based on the table array my unit cost
column is at the fourth index so i'll
write four
comma the range lookup is zero
if i click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for jones is 1.99
because vlookup only returns the first
match
okay moving ahead to the next example we
have here is vlookup is case insensitive
if you consider this table
i've added another
row in green
so if you see here i have a
representative name called gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case
here i have added
gil's name in
capital letters or all in uppercase
so i want to find the total revenue
generated by gil the total revenue is
basically the total column
let's do it i'll write vlookup
my lookup value is gil which is actually
in upper case
i'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on this selection my column index
number is 5
comma the range lookup is false so i'll
just double click on false
if i close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider gil
which was present at the bottom of the
table in uppercase
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example
the vlookup function supports wildcards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value
for instance you can use vlookup to
retrieve values from a table after
typing only part of a lookup value to
use wildcards with vlookup you must
specify the exact match by giving false
or 0 for the last argument that is range
lookup
now we have a question here i want to
know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with ki
make
now here sales represents the
total column actually
so i want to find out the person whose
name starts with ki
so if you consider the representative
column i have one representative whose
name starts with ki that is kival
so
using ki as my lookup value i want to
find the total so let me show you
how to use wildcard characters and find
the value using vlookup
so write my function vlookup
okay
now in lookup value i'll give ki
after that
i'm going to write amber sent
followed by
double inverted commas
then i'm going to write a star
and close the inverted comma
this means
the value starts with k i
am percent actually represents
concatenation and star represents
anything followed by k i
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
i'll give a comma
next
i'll select my table array starting from
the representatives column till the end
of total column because i want to find
the sales
i'll give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5
comma
the range lookup is 0 because i want to
find an exact match
close the bracket hit enter you can see
it here
vlookup has returned me
999.5 which is actually kevl's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of
selecting the cell in which we have the
lookup value i can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so i'll write the vlookup function
something like this
so my lookup value
i'll pass
ki within double inverted commas because
ki is a character value
so within double inverted commas i'm
writing ki
followed by amber sent which is for
concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my lookup values
this in total means anything that
appears after ki will be considered as
the lookup value
again the table array i'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is 0.
if i close the bracket hit enter you see
we have the same value so this is
another method or another way of using
vlookups
okay
now moving ahead let's explore another
feature of vlookup so if the vlookup
function cannot find a match it returns
a hash and a error now if you want you
can use the if any function to replace
the hash n a error with a friendly
message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of may 2018.
now if the order date is not found i
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column
we don't have any value for 10th of may
2015. you can see these values we don't
have any value corresponding to this
date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value i'll return invalid date so
let me show you
how to write this
i'll type my vlookup function
i'll give my order date as 10th of may
2015
as my lookup value
and then
i'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
i'll give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma i
want an exact match
so i'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has written me an error
now i want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date
so let me show you how to do it i'll do
it here so to return a valid message
i'll use the if any function
and within ifinay function i'll give my
vlookup
function
so let me type if n a
i'll hit tab
now for the value parameter i'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be
the order date
comma
my table array i'll select from the
order date column till the end of region
column comma my column index number is
going to be 2
comma
my range lookup is 0
i'll close the bracket give another
comma
now if this expression results in an
error i want to display a message that
is invalid date
so i'll put invalid date within double
quotes
since it is
a text
message i close the bracket
hit enter
you can see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two-way lookup
now in the vlookup function
the column index parameter is normally
hard coded as a static number however
you can also create a dynamic column
index by using the match function to
locate the right column and this
technique allows you to create a dynamic
two-way lookup matching on both rows and
columns
now let me first show you how a
match function works so suppose
i want to find
the index where unit cost column is
present
so here i'll use the match function
i'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma
suppose
i'll choose my lookup array starting
from representatives column till
the unit cost column comma
i'll give my match type as 0 for exact
match
if i close the bracket hit enter
it returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array
unit cost is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem i want to
find
the cost of each item sold by morgan
so let's
write our vlookup formula
write vlookup
my lookup value is
j5 which has the
representatives name as morgan comma
my table array
i'll select from
c2
till
f12
i'll give a comma and this time
i know that my column index number is at
4 but i'll be using the match function
to find the same
so i'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array
is from
c1 till
f1
comma my match type is 0
i close this bracket
give another comma
and i'll give my range lookup as zero
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right
now
we have another question here
i want to find
how much sales did andrews make in the
central region so here i have
two lookup values one is central one is
andrews now looking at these two values
i want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create another table
i'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right
now i'll create another column where
i'll merge the values of region and
representatives so here
let me create
another column okay i'll just name this
column as
region
rep
all right
now this column
i'll use the concatenation operator
so i'll select east
use ampersand and then select jones i'll
hit enter
now the same thing i'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so i have my
new column created now using this table
i can easily solve the problem
now to find the total
i'll write my vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of
j11
ampersand
k11
comma
my table array will start from the
region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5. and my range lookup
is 0 but close the bracket hit enter you
can see
for central region which is this one
and for andrew's
representative the total is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlookup performs an exact
match
we also saw how using the formulas tab
and lookup
and reference you can write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlookup
performs an approximate match so we had
mat and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only returns the first match
following which we saw
that vlookup is case insensitive so here
we had added a new row where gil was
present in upper case but still vlookup
found the total revenue for gil which
was in sentence case of proper case next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to
use vlookups
and here we saw how to use
an if-funny function
along with vlookup
and finally we saw how to use two
vlookups
we will be learning about excel budget
template how to create an excel budget
template
for that let's get back to practical
mode where we have to start our
microsoft excel and see how to implement
excel budget template
so on my screen you can see an example
excel budget template theme
so on my screen you can see a column
where you have the debit amount
so in the i column we have all the
amount what we are spending for a month
and on the right column will be the
balance amount or the running balance of
that for example you can see that there
is a row number five where the debit
amount is eight thousand for a change
levis and it is done through upi payment
now if i change this value of eight
thousand to four thousand something
then you can see that these running
balance will automatically change you
can see that currently the running
balance is 73 000 and if i change this
value from 8000 to 4000 then all the
running balances will change
let's do that so for that let's press
enter
there you go you can see that the number
has been changed successfully and all
the values from the running balance are
also changed until the last date which
is the march 30th
now how is this working and not just
that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in january and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance
after one lakh has been debited into the
account in the month of february as
february income
now the current available balance is one
lakh thirteen thousand two hundred and
the total expense in february is one
lakh four thousand five hundred right
how am i doing all this looks so much
interesting right now let's do this
practically
so for that i have already created a new
sheet and i have included all the data
that we have used previously
the income of that particular month and
all the expenses of that particular
month
now without further ado let's begin to
implement the excel budget template now
our first step happens to be converting
all the data into a natural table so you
know that in excel all the data values
are stored in the form of a database by
default so it happens to be our duty to
convert the database type table into the
pure table type table so for that select
all your data and press ctrl t and there
you go you have an option to convert
this data into a table and remember to
check this particular check box
and tell your excel that your table has
headers
so we do have headers here so now press
ok and your table will be converted into
a natural table
now let's type in the formulas
so now let's select the cell j2
and type in the formula
so what are we doing here is we are
trying to
add the sum of j2 plus h3
so which is this particular cell
and removing i3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance
let's press enter and there you go so it
means that you received
one lakh rupees in the month of january
and out of that one lakh you spend
15 000 rupees for something maybe your
educational or something and then the
remaining running balance out of 1 lakh
rupees is 85 000 rupees now let's copy
the same formula to all these cells
and there you go
now the running balance has been
calculated for all the cells here
now remember the monthly income
available balance and debit for january
and final balance
now let's try to calculate that for all
the three months so here we have three
months that is january february and
march
now let's do a simple calculation to
find out the available balance of that
month and the total debit made by that
person in that particular month
the formula is really simple all you
have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these values
and done
right
there you go so the total expense of the
month january is 93 800 rupees
now let's calculate the total debit of
february month same formula that is
calculating the sum of
all the expenses made in the month of
february
okay
now let's also calculate the sum of all
the expenses in the month of march
done
so we have the final values of all the
total expenses made in those particular
months now
let's calculate the final balance
now i think i forgot one important thing
so before we calculate the final balance
we need to find out the available
balance
that is the available balance
after
one lakh rupees is created into our
account and along with the savings that
you have from your previous month right
so that we have a simple formula
now which all we are doing is just
adding the
income
cell with the balance cell that's all
so there you go now after crediting one
lakh rupees and adding up the uh
balance of
that particular month that is we have 13
200 remaining from the month of january
and the month of february we have income
of one lakh so the total amount is
three hundred and
no no no it is
one lakh thirteen thousand two hundred
yeah
now we have the final balance that is
the difference between the available
balance and
the debit made in that particular month
so in the month of february we had a
total balance of one lakh thirteen
thousand two hundred and the total debit
of one lakh four thousand five hundred
so the final remaining values as eight
thousand seven hundred
similarly the same formula has been
applied for the month of march and the
final balance we have is 37 300
so that's how you implement budget
template in excel all simple formulas
and you have all the numbers at your
fingertips
we will learn about user form in excel
now without further ado let's get
started with our one point agenda that
is user form in excel
so what exactly is a user form so user
form is a graphical user interface that
helps you have an live interaction with
your worksheet which enables you to
enter or eliminate data from your excel
worksheet through the graphical user
interface
now let's get into the practical mode
and start the excel workbook now we have
launched our microsoft excel
so let us create a blank workbook for
now
now we have the blank workbook or
worksheet now before we get started with
the user forms in excel the fundamental
step is to enable the developer menu on
the toolbar here you can find the
developer menu so basically it will not
be enabled as default
to enable that you need to get into file
menu and inside the file menu you can
see the last menu that is the options
menu select that
and you will have a dialog box on your
screen and inside that you need to go
into the customized ribbon option
and inside the customize ribbon option
you have the main tabs
scroll through the main tabs and here
you can find an option called developer
by default it will not be enabled it
will look something like this but to
enable that you need to select the check
option in this and click on that and
select ok now the developer option will
be enabled on your tool menu
so now you have your developer option on
your toolbar
so to get started with user forms in
excel click on the developer option and
here you can see visual basic
so click on that visual basic and now
you have your new window opened right on
your screen
so this is the visual basics for
applications
so here is where you create your user
forms
now to create a user form just select on
insert menu and you have the option
called user form
now a new user form will be created for
you
and that is userform1
so this is the userform which you can
design and enable to interact with your
worksheet and help you insert data or
eliminate data
for now let's try to create a simple
user form for employees
now here you can see the controls option
where you can find the various options
to provide an object into your user form
so it might be a label it might be a
text box it might be a multi-page it
might be a command button it might be a
frame or a toggle switch many more for
now let's make it simple let's create a
label
so this is our first label we have just
dragged and dropped it
and let us name it as
okay so let us select it
and rename it as employee id
now let's insert another label
drag and drop
as simple as it looks
select that
and rename it as employee
name
now another one you can also copy that
and paste it
and this should be our
employee phone number
now we have our three labels on the
screen
let's try to insert the text
box now this is our first text box
for employee id
now let's copy and paste it
so another text box for
employee name copy and paste again and
the last text box for
employee phone
now let us try to insert the button
so the first command button let us
rename it as insert
now let us relocate it to a little bit
left now let us try to insert another
button
and
here it is
the second button would be
refresh sheet
the refresh button will play the role of
clearing the
text boxes in case if there is some data
already entered if you want to clear
that you can just press on refresh and
it will be cleared
now we have our user form so let us try
to rename our user form so here you can
see that we have the properties tab and
inside the properties tab we can always
rename it and to rename it let us go
into caption and rename it as employee
data
and that's done
so our basic user form is ready now
let's get back to excel sheet so
remember that we have created three
labels employee id employee name and
employee form we need to create the
exact same columns here
so employee
id
let us expand the column a little bit
now
employ
name
let us also increase
the width
and finally we have employee phone
there you go
yeah we have our three columns
let us select all the three columns
and
align to metal
you can also format your
cells
let us select the green color
and text as white
and it is bold
yeah
pretty good
there you go so we have created our
sheet and it's ready now
now
the last part remaining is we need to
code this particular user form
so coding in the sense we have two
buttons over here right so those buttons
should be performing some kind of
operation so for insert button the
operation should be inserting the data
which we have entered into these text
boxes
so to program it just double click on
the insert button
and here
eliminate everything
and
paste this code so basically what we did
is we had this particular code segment
so this is the starting part of the code
segment and this is the ending part of
the code segment
so we are writing our code in between
these two lines
so what did we write here
so end of the row is sheets of sheet
name so this is the sheet name
right here we have our sheet name as
sheet1 so that is the sheet name where
we want to perform the operations and
range from a
to rowscount and xlr row that is we are
counting the number of rows here that
particular statement will count the rows
till the end of the sheet automatically
and after that it will shift to text box
value that is once the row number is
counted that is from 1 to n it will
start entering data from the first
available row
that is a column
a column then
once the a column is finished it will
enter into b column and subsequently
into c
and once the text boxes are entered the
data that is let's come back to here so
once we have entered all the text that
is the employee id name and phone after
selecting the insert button
automatically these three text boxes
should go blank again you cannot have
the same data again in your
text box
so that is why we have included text box
value 1 null text box value 2 null text
box value 3 null so that was for command
operation insert
now we should program the command
operation for refresh double click on
that
and you have the
code option over here so this particular
code will be automatically loaded from
the click button one now for click
button too you need to add some more
data that is refreshing so whenever you
press the refresh button the text should
go blank for that we'll use the same
code from the previous click button or
the command button
paste it over here
and this should perform the clearing
operation
and it's done
now close this so select the employee
data
use the form and here you can see the
run option
so select that run option and the sheet
has the user form here now let us enter
the employee id as one two three four
five
and employee name as j-o-h-n
okay caps lock is on
j h and john
employee phone as some
1800
two three one
and select the insert option and the
data got inserted now let us try to
insert another data one two three four
six
employee name quick
and
employee phone number
180345
yeah by now you might have guessed i'm a
fan of john rick yes
and yeah there you go we have entered
the second data over here now let me
show you another trick
where you can place all this user form
as a macro and replace this by just one
single button so whenever you press that
button this data form or user form will
pop up and you can directly start
entering data
so for that let's get back to the visual
basic
and stop this particular execution and
you got your user form back
now you need to insert a model get into
insert option and select the module or
model yeah it is module not model
so inside this module you need to write
the command for macro
so
here it is
so
what we are basically doing is
a-n-p-l-o-y-e-e
data
dot show
or we can use an underscore and get back
to user form and
rename this as
date
cool
so what we are doing is entering the
subject as enter employee details this
will be the macro name and when this
macro is called the employee data user
form should be shown and once it is
shown the code should be ended
that is end subject
now we have designed our module
now let's get back to the sheet
and here
go to the developer option go to the
insert menu and select button
and draw the button somewhere
and now you can select the enter
employee details macro and press ok and
now you have a button here
now you can edit this
edit it as press to enter
enter employee details
and there you go
done
so now whenever you press this
particular button the user form will
activate
okay
and you need to play this
okay the error was related to the
employee data sheet name we had to
rename the employee data from user form
to employee data initially it was just
user form we have renamed that to
employee data and now the code is fine
so let's get back to the sheet now if
you press this button
the user form will automatically start
now let us try to enter the data again 1
2 3 4 5 7 this time
and
some name
let's enter as
jennifer
and her phone number would be one eight
double zero three four five
zero nine eight some random number and
select insert and the data has been
inserted here
so this is how you work on userforms in
excel
why exactly
do we need to do time series analysis
typically we would like to predict
something in the future and
it could be stock prices it could be the
sales or
anything that needs to be predicted into
the future that is when we
use time series analysis
so it is
as the name suggests it is forecasting
and typically when we say predict it
need not be into the future in machine
learning and data analysis when we talk
about predicting we are not necessarily
talking about the future but in time
series analysis we typically predict the
future so we have some past data and we
want to predict the future that is when
we perform time series analysis so what
are some of the examples it could be
daily stock price the shares as we talk
about or it could be the interest rates
weekly interest rates or sales figures
of a company so these are some of the
examples where we use time series data
we have historical data which is
dependent on time and then based on that
we create a model to predict the future
so what exactly is uh time series so
time series data has time as one of the
components as the name suggests so in
this example let's say this is the stock
price data and
one of the components so there are two
columns here column b is
price and column a is basically the time
information in this case the time is a
day so that primarily the closing price
of a particular stock has been recorded
on a daily basis so this is a time
series data and the time interval is
obviously a day time series or time
intervals can be daily weekly hourly or
even sometimes there is something like a
sensor data it could be every few
milliseconds or microseconds as well so
the size of the time intervals can vary
but they are fixed so if i'm saying that
it is daily data then the interval is
fixed as daily if i'm saying this data
is an hourly data then it is the data is
captured every r and so on so the time
intervals are fixed the interval itself
you can decide based on what kind of
data we are capturing so this is a
graphical representation the previous
one here we saw the table representation
and this is how to plot the data so on
the y y-axis is let's say the price or
the the stock price and x-axis is the
time so against time if you plot it this
is how a time series graph would look so
as the name suggests what is time series
data time series data is basically a
sequence of data that is recorded over a
specific intervals of time and based on
the past values so if we want to do an
analysis of time series fast data we try
to forecast a future and
again as the name suggests it is time
series data which means that it is time
dependent so time is one of the
components of this data time series data
consists of primarily four components
one is the trend then we have the
seasonality then cyclicity and then last
but not least irregularity or the random
component sometimes is also referred to
as a random component so let's see what
each of these components are so what is
trend trend is overall
change or the pattern of the data which
means that the data may be let me just
pull up to pen and
show you so let's say you have a data
set somewhat like this a time series
data set somewhat like this all right
so what is the overall trend there is an
overall
trend which is upward trend as we call
it here right so it is not like it is
continuously increasing there are times
when it is dipping then there are times
when it is increasing then it is
decreasing and so on but overall over a
period of time from the time we start
recording to the time we end there is a
trend right there is an upward trend in
this case so the trend need not always
be upwards there could be a downward
trend as well so for example here there
is a downward trend right so this is
basically what is a trend overall
whether the data is increasing or
decreasing all right then we have the
next component which is seasonality what
is seasonality seasonality as the name
suggests once again changes
over a period of time and periodic
changes right so there is a certain
pattern um let's take the sales of warm
clothes for example so if we plot it
along the months so let's say january
february march april may july and then
let's say it goes up to december okay so
this is our
december a d i will just mark it as t
and then you again have jan feb march
and then you get another december okay
and just for simplicity let's mark these
as decembers as the end of the year and
then one more december
okay so what will happen when if you're
talking about warm clothes what happens
the sales of warm clothes will increase
probably around december when it is cold
and then they will come down and then
again
around december again they will increase
and then the sales will come down and
then there will be again an increase and
then they will come down and then again
an increase and then they will come now
let's see this is the sales pattern so
you see here there is a trend as well
there is an upward trend right the sales
are increasing over let's say these are
multiple years this is for year one this
is for year two this is for year three
and so on so for multiple years overall
the trend there is an upward trend the
sales are increasing but it is not a
continuous increase right so there is a
certain pattern so what is happening
what is the pattern every
december the sales are increasing or
they are peaking for that particular
year right then there is a new year
again when december approaches the sales
are increasing again when december
approaches the sales are increasing and
so on and so forth so this is known as
seasonality so there is a certain
fluctuation
which is uh which is periodic in nature
so this is known as seasonality then
cyclicity what is cyclicity now
cyclicity is somewhat similar to
seasonality but here the duration
between two cycles is much longer so
seasonality typically is referred to as
an annual kind of a sequence like for
example we saw here so it is pretty much
like every year in the month of december
the sales are increasing however
cyclicity what happens is first of all
the duration is pretty much not fixed
and the duration or the gap length of
time between two cycles can be much
longer so the recession is an example so
we had let's say recession in 2001 or
2002 perhaps and then we had one in 2008
and then we had probably in 2000 2012
and so on and so forth so it is not like
every year this happens probably so
there is usually when we say recession
there is a slump and then it recovers
and then there is a slump and then it
recovers and probably there is another
bigger slum and so on right so you see
here this is similar to seasonality but
first of all this length is much more
than a year
right that is number one and it is not
fixed as well it is not like every four
years or every six years that duration
is not fixed so the
duration can vary at the same time the
gap between two cycles is much longer
compared to
seasonality all right so then what is
irregularity irregularity is like the
random component of the time series data
so there is like you have part which is
the trend which tells whether the
overall it is increasing or decreasing
then you have cyclicity and seasonality
which is like kind of a specific pattern
right
then there is a cyclicity which is again
a pattern but at much longer intervals
plus there is a random component so
which is not really which cannot be
accounted for very easily right so there
will be a random component which can be
really random as the name suggests right
so that is the irregularity component so
these are the various components of time
series data yes there are conditions
where we cannot use time series analysis
right so is it can we do time series
analysis with any kind of data no not
really so what are the situations where
we are we cannot do time series analysis
so there will be some data which is
collected over a period of time but it's
really not changing so
it will not really not make sense to
perform any time series analysis over it
right for example like this one so if we
take x as the time and y is the value of
whatever the output we are talking about
and if the y value is constant there is
really no analysis that you can do
leave alone time series analysis right
so that is one another possibility is
yes there is a change but it is changing
as per a very fixed function like a sine
wave or a cos wave again time series
analysis will not make sense in this
kind of a situation because there is a
definite pattern here there is a
definite function that the data is
following so it will not make sense to
do a time series analysis now before
performing any time series analysis
the data has to be stationary and
typically time series data is not
stationary so in which case you need to
make the data stationary before we apply
any models like arima model or any of
these right so what exactly is
stationary data and what is meant by
stationary data let us take a look first
of all what is non-stationary data time
series data if you recall from one of my
earlier slides we said that time series
data has the following four components
the trend seasonality cyclicity and
random random component or irregularity
right so if these components are present
in time series data it is non-stationary
which means that typically these
components will be present therefore
most of the time a time series data that
is collected raw data is non-stationary
data so it has to be changed to
stationary data before we apply any of
these algorithms
all right so a non stationary time
series data would look like this which
means like for example here there is an
upward trend the seasonality component
is there and
also the random component and so on so
if the data is not stationary then the
time series forecasting will be affected
so you cannot really perform a time
series forecasting on a non-stationary
data so how do we differentiate between
a stationary and a non-stationary time
series data typically or technically one
is of course you can do it visually in
non-stationary data the the data will be
more flattish seasonality will of course
be there but the trend will not be there
so the data may if we plot that it may
appear somewhat like this right it's a
horizontal line along the horizontal
line you will see compared to the
original data which was there was an
upward trend so it was changing somewhat
like this right so this is
non-stationary data and this is our
stationary data would look visually what
does this mean technically this means
that stationarity of the data depends on
a few things what the mean the variance
and the covariance
so these are the three components on
which the stationarity of the data
depends so let's take a look at what
each of these are for stationary data
the mean should not be a function of
time which means that the mean should
pretty much remain constant over a
period of time right so there is there
shouldn't be any change
so this is how the stationary data would
look and this is how a non-stationary
data would look as shown in the previous
slide as well so here the mean is
increasing that means there is an upward
trend okay so that is one part of it and
then the variance of the series should
not be also a function of time so the
variance also should be pretty much
common or
should be constant rather so this is a
if we visually we take a look this is
how time series stationaries data would
look where the variance is not changing
here the variance is changing therefore
this is non-stationary and we cannot
apply type series forecasting on this
kind of data similarly the covariance
which is basically of the ith term and
the i plus m term should not be a
function of time as well so covariance
is nothing but not only the variance at
the i-th term but the relation between
the variance of the i-th term and the i
plus m or the i plus n-th term so as
again once again visually this is how it
would look if the covariance is also
changing with respect to time so these
are the three all three components
should be pretty much constant that is
when you have stationary data and in
order to perform time series analysis
the data should be stationary okay so
let's take a look at uh the concept of
moving average or the method of moving
average and let's see how it works we'll
do simple calculations so let's say this
is our sample data we have the data for
three months january february march the
sales in hundreds of in thousands rather
not hundreds thousands of dollars is
given here and now we want to find the
moving average so how do we find the
moving average we call it as moving
average three so moving average three is
nothing but you take three of the values
or the readings add them up and uh
divide by three basically the way we
take a mean or average of the three
values so that is as simple as that so
that's the average first of all so what
is moving average moving averages if you
now have a series of data you keep
taking the three values the next three
values and then you take the average of
that and then the next three values and
so on and so forth so that is how you
take the moving average so let's take a
little more detailed example of car
sales so this is how we have the car
sales data for the entire year let's say
so rather for four years so year one we
have for each quarter quarter one two
three four and then year two quarter one
to three four and so on and so forth so
this is how we have sales data of a
particular car let's say or a showroom
and
we want to forecast for year five so we
have the data for four years we now want
to focus for the fifth year let's see
how it works first of all if we plot the
data as it is uh taken the raw data this
is how it would look and uh what do you
think it is is it stationary no right
because there is a trend upward trend so
this is not a stationary data so we
we need to later we will see how to make
it stationary but to start with just an
example we will not worry about it for
now we will just go ahead and manually
do the forecasting using what is known
as moving average method okay so we are
not applying any algorithm or anything
like that in the next video we will see
how to apply an algorithm how to make it
stationary and so on all right so
um here we see that all the three or
four components that we talked about
are there there is a trend there is a
seasonality and then of course there is
some random component as well cyclicity
may not be it is possible that cyclicity
is not applicable in all the situations
for sales especially there may not be
unless you're taking a sales for maybe
20 30 years cyclicity may not come into
play so we will just consider uh
primarily the trend seasonality and
irregularity right so random it is also
known as random irregularity right so we
were calling the random or irregularity
component so these are the three main
components typically in this case we
will talk about so this is the trend
component and
we will see how to do these calculations
so let's take a look
re-draw the table
including the time code we will add
another column which is the time code
and uh
and we'll just number it like 1 2 3 4 up
to 16. the rest of the data remains the
same okay so we will do the calculations
now now let us do the moving average
calculations um or ma4 as we call it for
each year so we take all the four
quarters and we take an average of that
so if we add up these four values and
divide by four you get the moving
average of 3.4 so we start by putting
the value here so that will be for the
third quarter let's say one two three
the third quarter then we will go on to
the next one so we take the next four
values as you see here and take the
average of that which is the moving
average for the next quarter and so on
and so forth now if we just do the
moving average uh it is not centered so
what we do is we basically add one more
column and we calculate the centered
moving average as shown here so here
what we do is we take the average of two
values and then just adding these values
here so for example the first value for
the third quarter is actually the
average of the third and the fourth
quarter so we have 3.5 now it gets
centered so similarly the next value
would be 3.6 plus 3.9 divided by 2 so
which is 3.7 and so on and so forth okay
so that is the centered moving average
this is done primarily to smoothen the
data so that there are not too many
rough edges so that is what we do here
so
if we visualize this data now uh this is
how it looks right so if we take the
centered moving average as you can see
there is a gradual increase if this was
not the case if we had not centered it
the changes would have been much sharper
so that is the basically the smoothening
that we are talking about now
let's go and or do the forecast for the
fifth year so in order to do the
forecast what we will do is we will take
the centered moving average as our
baseline and then start doing a few more
calculations that are required in order
to come up with the prediction so what
we are going to do is we are going to
use this multiplicity or multiplicative
model in this case and this is how it it
looks so we take the product of
seasonality and
the trend and the irregularity
components and we just multiply that and
in order to get that this product of
these two we have basically the actual
value divided by cma yt value divided by
cma will give you the predicted value of
yt is equal to the product of all three
components therefore st into it is equal
to yt by cma so this is like this is
equal to y t right so therefore if we
want st into y t the product of
seasonality and irregularity is equal to
y t by c m a so that is how we will work
it out i also have an excel sheet of the
actual data so let me just pull that up
all right so this is how the data looks
in excel as you can see here year one
quarter one two three four year 2.01234
and so on and this is the sales data and
then this is the moving average as i
mentioned this is how we calculate and
this is the centered moving average so
this is the primary component that we
will start working with and then we will
calculate since we want the product of
sc into y t that is equal to yt by cma
so if you see this values are nothing
but the yt value divided by cma so in
this case it is 4 by 3.5 which is 1.14
similarly 4.5 by 3.7 1.2 and so on and
so forth so we take we have the product
s t into i t and then the next step is
to
calculate the average of
respective quarters so that is what we
are doing here average of respective
quarters and then we need to calculate
the deseasonalized values so in order to
get decisionalized value we need to
divide yt by st that was calculated so
for example here it is 2.8 by 0.9 so we
got the decisionalized value here and
then we get the trend and then we get
the predicted values so in order to get
the predicted value which is basically
we predict the values for known values
as well like for example here one
quarter one we know the value but now
that we have our model we predict
ourselves and see how close it is so we
predicted as 2.89 whereas the actual
value is 2.8 then we have 2.59 the
actual value is 2.1 and so on just to
see how our model works and then
continue that into the fifth year
because for fifth year we don't have a
reference value okay and if we plot this
we will come to know how well our
calculations are how well our manual
model in this case we did not really use
a model but we did on our own manually
so it will tell us the trend so for
example the predicted value is this gray
color here and you can see that it is
actually pretty much following the
actual value which is the blue color
right and the gray color is the
predicted value so the at wherever we
know the values up to year four we can
see that our predicted values are
following or pretty much very close to
the actual values and then from here
onwards when the year 5 starts the blue
color line is not there because we don't
have the actual values only the
predicted value so we can see that since
it was following the trend pretty much
for the last four years we can safely
assume that it has understood the
pattern and it is predicting correctly
for the next one year the next four
quarters right so that is what we are
doing here so these four quarters we did
not have actual data but we have the
predicted values so let's go back and
see how this is working in this using
the slides so this is we already saw
this part and
i think it was easier to see in the
excel sheet so we calculated the st i t
the product of st and i t using the
formula like here y by y t by c m a we
got that and then we got s t which is
basically yt so this is the average of
the first quarters for all the four
years and uh similarly this is the
average of the second quarter for all
the four years and so on so these values
are repeating they are calculated only
once they get repeated as you can see
here and
then we get the decisionalized
data and that is basically yt by st so
we calculated st here and we have yt so
yt by st will give you the
decisionalized data and
we have got rid of the seasonal and the
irregular components so far now what we
are left with is the trend and
before we start the time series
forecasting or time series analysis as i
mentioned earlier we need to completely
get rid of the
non-stationary components so we are
still left with the trend component so
now let us also remove the trend
component in order to do that we have to
find the or we have to calculate the
intercept and slope of the data because
that is required to calculate the trend
and
how are we going to do that we will
actually use um what is known as a
regression tool or analytics tool that
is available in excel so you remember we
have our data in excel so let me take
you to the excel and
here we need to calculate the intercept
and the slope in order to do that we
have to use the regression mechanism and
in order to use the regression mechanism
we have to use the analytics tool that
comes with excel so how do you
activate this tool so this is how you
would need to activate the tool from
excel you need to go to options
and
in options
there will be add-ins and in add-ins you
will have um
analysis tool back and you select this
and
you just say go to open up a box like
this you say analysis tool pack and you
say okay and now when you come back in
to the regular view of excel in the data
tab you will see data analysis activated
so you need to go to file
options
and add-ins
and then
analysis tool pack typically since i've
already added it it is coming at the top
but it would come under inactive
application add-ins so when you're doing
it for the first time so don't use vba
you just say analysis toolbar there are
two options one with vba like this one
and one without vba so just use the one
without vba and then instead of just
saying okay just take care that you
click on this go and not just okay so
you say go then it will give you these
options only then you select just the
analysis toolpak and then you say okay
all right so
and then when you come back to the main
view you click on data okay so this is
your normal home view perhaps so you
need to come to data and here is where
you will see data analysis available to
you and then if you click on that there
are a bunch of possibilities what kind
of data analysis you want to do if there
are options are given right now we just
want to do regression because we want to
find the slope and the intercept so
select regression and you say ok
and you will get these options for input
y range and input x range input y range
is the value yt so you just
select this and you can select up to
here and press enter and input x range
you can for now you start with
the baseline or you can also start with
the d seasoned values so you can just
click on these and say okay
i have already calculated it so these
are the intercept and the coefficients
that we are getting for these values and
we will actually use that to calculate
our trend here right so which is in the
j column so our trend is equal to
intercept plus slope into the time code
so the intercept is
out here as we can see in our slide as
well so if you see here this is our
intercept and the lower value is the
slope we have calculated here and it's
shown in the slides as well so intercept
so the formula is shown here so our
trend is equal to intercept plus slope
into time code time code is nothing but
this one t column a one two three four
okay so that's how you calculate the
trend and that's how you use the data
analysis tool from excel using these two
we calculate the predicted values and
using this formula which is basically
trend is equal to intercept plus slope
into time code and then we can go and
plot it see how it is
looking and therefore so we see here
that the predicted values are pretty
close to the actual values and
therefore we can safely assume that our
calculations which are like our manual
model is working and hence we we go
ahead and predict for the fifth year so
till four years we know the actual value
as well so we can compare our model is
performing and for the fifth year we
don't have reference values so we can
use our equations to calculate the
values or predict the values for the
fifth year and we can go ahead and
safely calculate those values and when
we plot for the fifth year as well the
predicted values we see that they are
pretty much they captured the pattern
and we can safely assume that the
predictions are fairly accurate as we
can also see from the graph in the excel
sheet that we have already seen okay so
let's go and plot it so this is how the
plot looks this is the cma or the
centered moving average the green color
and then the blue color is the actual
data red color is the predicted value
predicted by our hand crafted model okay
so remember we did not use any regular
forecasting model or any tool we have
done this manually and
the actual tool will be used in the next
video this is just to give you an idea
about how behind the scenes or under the
hood how forecasting works or time
series analysis how it is performed okay
so it looks like it has captured the
trend properly so up to here is the
known difference we have reference and
from here onwards is purely predicted
and
as i mentioned earlier we can safely
assume that the values are accurate and
predicted properly for the fifth year so
let's go ahead and implement a time
series forecast in r first of all we
will be using the arimo model to do the
forecast of
this time series data so let us try to
understand what is arima model so arima
is actually an acronym it stands for
autoregressive integrated moving average
so that is what is arima model and it is
specified by three parameters which is p
d and q p stands for auto regressive so
let me just mark this so there are three
components here auto regressive
integrated moving average okay so these
three parameters correspond to those
three components so the p stands for
autoregressive d for integrated and q
for moving average so let us see what
exactly this is so these three factors
are p is the number of autoregressive
terms or ar we will see that in a little
bit and d is how many uh levels of
differences that we need to do or
differentiation we need to do and q
is the number of lagged forecast errors
so we'll see what exactly each of these
are so ar is the number of
autoregressive terms and which is
basically denoted by the b
and then we have d which is for the
number of times it has to be
differentiated and then we have q which
is for the moving average so what
exactly
ar terms so in terms of the regression
model autoregressive components
refer to the prior values of the current
value what we mean by that is here when
we talk about time series data focus on
the fact that there is regression so
what exactly happens in regression we
try to do something like if it is simple
linear regression we do some equation
like y is equal to mx plus c where there
are actually there are two variables one
is the dependent variable and then there
is an independent variable let me just
complete this equation as well mx plus c
right so this is a normal regression
curve or a simple regression curve now
here we are talking about auto
regression or auto regressive so
autoregressive as the name suggests is
regression of itself so which means that
here you have only one variable which is
your maybe the cost of the flights or
whatever it is right and the other
variable is basically time dependent and
therefore the value at any given time
and that we will denote as
y t for example so there is no x here
there is only one variable and which is
y and we say y t which is basically the
predicted value at a time interval t for
example is dependent on the previous
value so for example there may be a 1
and then y t minus 1 and then there will
be like plus a 2 and right plus a2 and
yt minus 2 and
all right and then plus a3 into y t
minus 3. all right so basically here
what we're saying is there's only one
variable here but there is a regression
component so we are doing a regression
on itself so that's how the term auto
regression comes into play so only thing
is that it is dependent on the previous
time values so there is a lag let's say
this is the first lag second lag third
lag and so on so the current value which
is yt is dependent on the previous time
lag values so that is what is not a
regression component so this is what is
shown here for example in this case
instead of y we are calling it as x so
that's the same and this is represented
by some equation of that sort depending
on how many lags we take so that is the
ar component and the term p is basically
determines how many lags we are
considering so that's the b4 now what is
d d is the degree of differencing so
here differencing is like two for the
non-seasonal differences right so for
example if you take the values like this
which are given for 5 4 6 and so on and
so forth if you take the differencing of
one after another like for example 5
minus 4 or 4 minus 5 the next value with
the previous value so 4 minus 5 so this
is known as the first order differencing
so the result is minus 1 similarly 6
minus 4 is 2. 7 minus 6 is 1. so this is
first order differencing and
here we call it as d is equal to one
okay and same way we can have second
order third order and so on then the
last one is q q is the actually right we
call it moving average but in reality it
is actually the error of the model so we
also sometimes represent as et all right
so now arima model works on the
assumption that the data is stationary
which means that the trend and
seasonality of the data has been removed
that is correct okay so this we have
discussed in the first part how what
exactly is stationary data and how do we
remove the non-stationary part of it now
in order to test whether the data is
stationary or not there are two
important components that are considered
one is the autocorrelation function and
the other is the partial autocorrelation
function so this is referred to as acf
and tsef right so what is
autocorrelation and what is the
definition or correlation is basically
the similarity between values of a same
variable across observations as the name
suggests now how do we actually find the
autocorrelation function the value right
so this is basically done by plotting
and autocorrelation function also tells
you how correlated points are with each
other based on how many time steps they
are separated by and so on that is
basically the time lag that we were
talking about and it is also used to
determine how past and future data
points are related and the value of the
autocorrelation function can vary from
-1 to 1. so if we plot this is how it
would look autocorrelation function
would look somewhat like this and there
is actually a readily available function
in r so we will see that and you can use
that to plot your autocorrelation
function okay so that is acf and we will
see that in our r studio in a little bit
and similarly you have partial
autocorrelation function so partial
autocorrelation function is the degree
of association between two variables
while adjusting the effect of one or
more additional variables so this again
can be measured and it can also be
plotted and its value once again can go
from minus one to 1 and it gives the
partial correlation of time series with
its own lagged values so lag again we
have discussed in the previous couple of
slides this is how a psef plot would
look in our studio we will see that as
well and once we get into the r studio
and with that let's get into our studio
and take a look at our use case before
we go into the code let's just quickly
understand what exactly is the objective
of this use case so we are going to
predict some values or forecast some
values and we have the data of the
airline ticket sales of the previous
years and now we will try to find the or
predict or forecast the values for the
future years all right so
we will basically
identify the time series components like
trend seasonality and
random behavior we will actually
visualize this in our studio and then we
will actually forecast the values based
on the past values or history data
historical data so these are the steps
that we follow we will see in our studio
in a little bit just quickly let's go
through what are the steps we load the
data and it is a time series data we try
to find out what class it belongs to the
data is actually air passengers data
that is already comes pre-loaded with
rstudio so we will be using that and we
can take a look at the data and then
what is the starting point what is the
end point so these are all functions
that are really available we'll be using
and then what is the frequency there's
basically frequency is 12 which is like
yearly data right so every month the
data has been collected so for each year
it is 12 and then we can check for many
missing values if there are any and then
we can take a look at the summary of the
data this is what we do in exploratory
data analysis and then we can plot the
data visualize the data how it is
looking and we will see how the data has
some trend seasonality and so on and so
forth all right then we can take a look
at the cycle of the data using the cycle
function and we can see that it is every
month that's the cycle and of every 12
months
a new cycle begins so each month of the
year as
the data is available then we can do box
plots to see for each month how the data
is varying over the various 10 or 12
years that we will be looking at this
data and
from exploratory data analysis we can
identify that there is a trend there is
a seasonality component and how the
seasonality component varies also we can
see from the box plots and we can
decompose the data we can use the
decomposed function rather to see the
various components like the seasonality
trend and the irregularity part okay so
we will see all of this in our studio
this is how they will look this is the
once you decompose and this is how you
will actually you can visualize the data
this is the actual data and this is the
trend as you can see it's going upwards
this is the seasonal component and this
is your random or irregularity right so
we call it irregularity or we can also
call it random as you can see here yes
so the data must have a constant
variance and mean which means that it is
stationary before we
start any analysis time series analysis
and we thought so basically if it is
stationary only then it is easy to model
the data perform time series analysis so
we can then go ahead and fit the model
as we discussed earlier we will be using
arima model there are some techniques to
find out what should be the parameter so
we will see that when we go into r
studio so
the auto arima function basically tells
us what should be the parameters right
so these parameters are the p d and q
that we talked about that's what is
being shown here so if we use auto arima
it will basically take all possible
values of this pdq these parameters and
it will find out what is the best value
and then it will recommend so that is
the advantage of using auto arima all
right so like in this case it will tell
us what if we use this parameter trace
we set the parameter trace is equal to
true then it will basically tell us what
is the value of this aic which has to be
minimum so the lower the value the
better so for each of these combinations
of b d and q it will give us the values
here and then it will recommend to us
which is the best model okay because
whichever has the lowest value of this
aic it will recommend that as your best
pdq values so once we have that we can
see that we will basically we can
potentially get a model or the equation
model is nothing but the equation and
based on the parameters that we get and
we can do some diagnostics we can do
some plotting to see how whether there
is a plot for the residuals so which
shows the stationarity and then we can
also take a look at the acf and pscf we
can plot the acm and psef and then we
can do some forecasting for the future
year so in this case we have up to 1960
and then we can see how we can forecast
for the next 10 years which is 1970 up
to 1917. and once we have done this can
we validate this model yes definitely we
can validate this model and
to validate the findings we use
a jump box test and this is how you just
call box dot test and then you pass
these parameters and you will get the
values that will be returned which will
tell us whether this how accurate this
model is how accurate the predictions
are so the values of p are quite
insignificant in this case we will see
that and that also indicates that our
model is free of autocorrelation and
that will basically be it so let's go
back and into our r studio and
go through these steps in real time so
we have to import this library forecast
package is not installed you have to go
here and install the forecast package
okay so that's the easy way to install
rather than so click on this install i
will not do it now because i have
already installed so the first time
that's only one time then after that you
just have to load it into memory and
then keep going so we will load this
data called air passengers so
by calling this data method and if you
see the the data passengers is loaded
here and if we check for the class it is
a time series data ts data so we can
check for the dates we can also view the
data in a little bit and start date is
1949 and january
and our end date is 1960 december
and the frequency is 12 which is
like collected monthly so
that is the frequency which is
12 here and then we
check if there are any
missing values there are no missing
values and then we take a look at the
summary of the data this is all
exploratory data analysis and then if
you just display the data this is how it
looks
and then we need to decompose this data
so we will kind of store this in an
object ts data and then use that to
decompose and store the new values let
me just clear this for now and
if we decompose basically as we have
seen in the slides decomposing is
breaking it into the trend seasonality
and irregular or random components then
you can go ahead and plot it so when you
plot it you can see here let me zoom
this this is our original plot or
observed value as it is known as then we
have decomposed the three parts which is
basically the trend as you can see there
is a fourth trend then the seasonal
component so this is a some regularly
occurring pattern and then there is a
random value which is basically you
cannot really give any equation or
function or anything like that so that's
what this plotting has done and then you
can actually plot them individually as
well so these are the individual plots
for the trend for the seasonal component
and the random component all right so
now let's take a look at the original
data and see how the trend is in a way
so if we do this linear regression line
it will show that it is going upwards
and we can also take a look at the cycle
that are there which is nothing but we
have a frequency of 12 right so the
cycles will display that it is january
february to december and then back to
january february and so on and so forth
and if we do box plots for the monthly
data you will see that for each of the
months right and over the 10 years that
the data that we have we will see that
there is a certain pattern right this is
also in a way to find the seasonality
component so
while january february sales are
relatively low around july august the
sales become so especially in july i
think the sales are the highest and this
seems to be happening pretty much every
year right so this is every year in july
there seems to be a peak in the sales
and then it goes down and slightly
higher in december and so on so that is
again part of our exploratory data
analysis and once again let's just plot
the data now as i said in order to fit
into an arima model we need the values
of pd and q now one way of doing it is
there are multiple ways actually of
doing it the earlier method of doing it
was you draw the autocorrelation
function plot and then partial
autocorrelation function plot and then
observe that and where does this change
and then identify what should be the
values of p and q and so on now r really
has a very beautiful
method which we can use to avoid all
that manual process that we used to do
earlier so what r will do is there is a
method called auto arima and if we just
call this auto arima method and it will
basically go and test the arima model
for all possible values of this
parameters pdq and then it will suggest
to you what should be the best model and
it will return that best model with the
right values of p d and q so you we as
data scientists don't have to do any
manual you know trial and error kind of
stuff okay so we got the model now and
this is the model it it has pdq values
are 2 1 1 the pdq and this is the
seasonal part of it so we can ignore it
for now and so if we want to actually
understand how this has returned these
values 2 1 1 as the best one there is
another functionality or feature where
we can use this trace function or trace
parameter so if you pass to auto arima
the trace parameter what it will do is
it will show you how it is doing this
calculation what is the value of the aic
basically asc is what you know defines
the accuracy of the model the lower the
better okay so for each combination of
pdq it will show us the value of aic so
let's run it before instead of me
talking so much let's run this if we run
auto arima with trace you see here there
is a red mark here that means it is
performing it's executing this and here
we see the display right so it starts
with certain values of pdq and then it
finds that value is too high so it
starts with again with some 0 1 1 0 and
so on and so forth and ultimately it
tells us okay this is our best model you
see here it says this is our best model
two one one let's go back and see did we
get the same one yes we got the same one
when we ran without trace as well right
now y is two 1 1 let us see where is 2 1
1 here is our 2 1 1 and if you compare
the values you see that 1 0 1 7 is
pretty much the lowest value and
therefore it is saying this is our best
model all other values are higher so
that's how you kind of
get your model and then now that you
have your model what you have to do you
need to predict the values right so
before that let us just do some tests of
these values so for that you install t
series again if you are doing it for the
first time you would rather use this
package and install and say t series and
install it and then you just use this
library function to load it into your
memory all right so now that we got our
model using auto arima let us go ahead
and forecast and also test the model and
also plot the acf and pscf remember we
talked about this but we did not really
use it we don't have to use that but at
least we will visualize it and for some
of the stuff we may need this t series
library so if you are doing this for the
first time you may have to install it
and my recommendation is don't use it in
the code you go here and install t
series
and i will not do it now because i have
already installed it but this is a
preferred method and once you install it
you just load it using this library's
function and then you can plot
your residuals
and this is how the residuals look and
you can plot your acf and psef okay so
this is how your psef looks and this is
how your acf looks for now there is
really nothing else we need to do with
acf and psef is just to visualize how
that how it looks but as i mentioned
earlier we were actually using these
visualizations or these graphs to
identify the values of p d and q and how
that was done it's uh out of scope of
this video so we will leave it at that
and
then we will forecast for the next 10
years how do we focus that so we call
forecast and we pass the model and we
pass what is the level of accuracy that
you need which is 95 percent and for how
many periods right so basically we want
for 10 years which is like 10 into 12
time periods so that's what we are doing
here and now we can plot the forecast
value so you see this is the original
value up to i think 62 or whatever and
then it goes up to 72 this blue color is
the predicted value let's go and zoom it
up so that we can see it better so from
here onwards your forecasting and you
can see that it looks like our model has
kind of learned the pattern and this
pattern looks very similar to what we
see in the actual data now how do we
test our model so we can do what is
known as a box test and we pass our
model here residuals basically with
different lags and from those values
here the p values here we find that they
are reasonably low p values which means
our model is fairly accurate
hello everyone now microsoft excel has a
lot of interesting features and one of
the exciting features in excel is to
send automated emails by writing sample
vba scripts
we will look at how you can automate an
outlook application and send several
emails with attachments from excel
marketing people in cc and bcc
so let's open the excel spreadsheet
ok so i'll click on this blank workbook
all right
now before we jump into the hands-on
part of this tutorial
let me tell you the purpose of using
excel to send emails
there could be multiple reasons for
which you might want to send an email
using excel
suppose you have a team that updates
spreadsheets or documents or let's say
reports monthly and you want to get an
alert message when those updates are
complete now this is a simple case where
you can use vba to send automated emails
another example could be let's say you
have a list of customer names in a
column in excel
suppose in excel you have a list of
customers like this
and you have the
file path
of a related file for each of the
customers in another column let's say in
column d
so your task is to send one email to
each customer and attach the correct
file
so this is another example of using vba
to trigger automated emails
so now let's start with our
demonstration
you can send emails directly from excel
with a few clicks without having to
write any codes now let me show you how
to do that
so here
in my excel workbook
if you look at the top left corner
there's a drop down here which says
customize quick access toolbar
if i click on this drop down you see
there are a list of options you have
automatically save new open
and here you can see something called as
email you have other things as well like
quick print spelling check undo redo and
others but we are interested with email
so if i click on this email it will add
this email
to our quick access toolbar which is
here on the top let me click on email
there you go you see here we have the
email icon
now if i click on this email icon
you have the interface where you can
send
emails directly from excel without
having to type any vba script or code so
here you can specify your to address you
can see i have a list of address names
available here
and you can also mark people in cc which
means carbon copy
now
you can also
write a subject you see here i have a
subject written test email using excel
and i have my current
workbook attached
now here on the top you can see you have
a lot of other options like file you
have the message where we are currently
in
then you have the option to insert you
can attach some other file you can add
your signature
you can draw something you can use these
options to change the theme colors fonts
and given
effects
you can also
change the
format of the text
here you have review as well as help
so this is
a very easy way to send email from excel
now
we will see how to send email in excel
using bba so let me close this
okay so i am on my excel workbook
you need to write a few sample scripts
to send email using vba
so let's understand the steps to send
emails through outlook
from
ms excel using bba
now
another thing that i've forgot to tell
you
if you want to use this feature of
directly sending emails to people
without having to type any code you need
to create
an outlook
account so i've already created my
outlook account
but if you don't have an outlook account
first you need to create an outlook
account all right
now let's see how you can write vba
scripts and send automated emails for
that we need to first go to the
developer tab here on the top
now in the developer tab we need to
select
the visual basic
option
or you can just
type alt f11
let me click on this visual basic
and this will open the
vb code editor
now to access outlook with vba you need
to activate the microsoft outlook object
library so for this
you need to go to tools here on the top
you have tools
i'll click on this and then
with tools you need to go to references
all right
now under references you need to select
the microsoft office 16.0
you can see here i have already selected
the microsoft office 16.0 object library
you also have to select the ole
automation
and then
you should also have microsoft office
16.0
object library
and this visual basic for applications
is already selected by default you don't
have to worry about that but the other
three you need to assure that these are
selected and then click on ok
ok
the next step
we need to navigate to the insert tab so
i have my insert tab here and click on
module so i have created a new module
here you can see here it says module one
and this is where we will type our vba
script to send emails
now to create a sub procedure in vba
i'll just
write
sub
i'll say send
email underscore
let's say demo
i'll give parenthesis and click enter
automatically it has given my end sub
where my
script will end or the sub procedure
will end
okay
now for those of you who are not very
acquainted with how
codes are written or you program in vba
we already have a video on
vbn macros so i would recommend you to
please check that video
cool
now next
so we had
given reference to outlook now we can
access the properties of outlook in vba
let's now declare an object variable
called outlook.application to refer to
the
outlook object
so what i'm going to do here is
i'll give a comment first
which says to
refer to
outlook application
now it is recommended to use comments in
your script or code
this makes your code very readable
so i'll start with dim
and then
i'll give my variable as let's say email
app
as
our
object variable which is
outlook dot application
okay
i'll come to the next line
okay
now to send an email we need to declare
another variable that will use microsoft
outlooks property to refer to a new
email
so in the next line i'll give another
comment which says
to
refer to
new
outlook email
here i'll write
dim
i'll create my
new variable which says new email
item as
i'll say
outlook
dot
mail item
all right
so this line of code
will use microsoft outlooks property to
refer to a new email
all right
now moving to the
next line
this time
if you want to
attach the current workbook in your mail
you must first declare a variable source
as a string
so i'll write dim
src which stands for source
then i'll say as
string
now the reason
source is a string is because we will
provide the file path where the
file is located
and
the name of the file is often a string
okay
next
now
we are going to create an instance of a
new object separately
so for that i'll give my comment to
launch
outlook application
okay i just did a smelly mistake here
i'll change this to launch okay
so to
create an instance of a new object
separately
we'll use the set keyword and then
followed by
this variable name
just close this which is email app so
i'll write email app
equal to i'll say
new
outlook dot application
okay
moving ahead
in the next step
we will create an instance for a new
email that will open the new email using
the set keyword
so for this we'll use the
application.createitem method that will
create and return a new microsoft
outlook item
so
i'll give another comment
which will
say to launch
new
outlook email
okay
go to the next line again i'm going to
use my set keyword
and now i'll write new
email
item
which we had passed
on the top you see here while we were
referring to the new
outlook email i'll just click on cancel
here
it should be outlook okay
so coming back to this line we'll say
new
email item
equal to
i'll say
email app dot
then we'll use the
create item method
and inside this
we are going to pass the date type which
is of
ol mail item
close this
moving ahead
okay so here on the top there should be
a space between new outlook i have made
a spelling mistake
okay
now
we'll use the
to property and assign the email address
to whom we want to send the email
so i'll write
new
email
item
dot i'll use the to property
give equal to
and
within double quotes you need to pass in
the
email id to whom you want to send the
email so here i'm going to use my
official email id
now one thing to
note here is once the video goes live we
are going to blur the email ids that i'm
using in this video
okay
so
in two i have passed in my email id
next
if you like to cc anyone in the email
you can use the cc property as well so
i'll write new
email
item
dot cc
i'll give an equal to sign and again
within double quotes
i'll pass in the email id of the person
okay
now moving ahead similarly you can also
use the bcc property if you want to mark
someone in bcc you can pass in their
email ids as well
so i'll write new email
item dot
this time i'll use the bcc property and
within double quotes i'll pass in the
email address
okay
then the next step
you can give the subject of the email so
for that we will use the dot subject
property
so i'll pass in my
variable name which is new email item
this is also called as an object
so i'll write new email item dot
i'll use the subject property
equal to
so let's give a subject to our email
let's say test
email
demo you can give
whichever subject line you want
now you can write the body of the email
by using the html body type
so let me show you how to do that i'll
pass in my object which is new email
item
dot
i'll use the
html
body type
given equal to
and here
we are going to write whatever we want
to put in the body of the email
i'll use
a new
object which is called vbnewline
now this bb new line is to insert a new
line
in the body of the email so let's start
with the body of the email let's see
i'll write
within double quotes i'll say hi
i'm given
amber sent and write
vb
newline
and give another amber send and again
give another new line by writing bb new
line
and i'll give
amber sent again
and then
i'll write let's say
this
is
a
test
email
from
excel
all right
i'll give
my double quotes
given amber sent again
and
then i'll
give an underscore and come to the next
line
and here
i'll again say
vb
newline
given ampersand i'll give another new
line
so i'll write vb
newline
given ampersand
and an underscore
and then
i'll close my mail by writing let's say
regards
give a comma
then i'll again give amber send vb
newline
given amber send
and underscore and go to the next line
and i'll
give my signature
let's say
jimmy
okay
so
what we did was we created our body of
the email by writing new email item dot
and we used the html body type
and my body has high
with two new lines and in the third line
we have the
body which sees this is a test email
from excel and then i have my closing
statement which is the signature that is
regards jimmy
now after the
mail body
you can assign this workbook dot full
name to source variable
so this is
going to attach the
workbook that we are working on to your
email so i'll write src which we created
here on the top
given equal to and say
this
workbook dot i'll use full name
if i hit tab it will auto complete
now here this workbook refers to the
current workbook and
dot full name refers to the full name of
the worksheet
now you can send the attachment using
the attachments property
so the way to do is
i'll write
new
email
item
dot
i'll use the
attachments property
and
i'll write add src
now if you want to send any other
attachment you have to pass in the files
location on your computer along with the
extension of the file
now
if i go to
my folder i have a folder in my
d drive which says email in
excel files so there are two files here
one is an image this is a jpeg image
and this is a text file which has
employees data you can see here i have
opened it on a notepad and it has some
insert into students values so basically
we are inserting some values to a
student's table it has some information
regarding that
suppose you want to
attach
these two files in your email you can do
that so let's see how to do it
so coming to the
next few lines i'll write
email
item
dot
i'll say
attachments dot
add
and here
i'll pass in
my file location
within double quotes
so
i'm going to copy this location
and i'll paste it here
and i'll give another
backslash
and
followed by the backslash we are going
to
give the
file name
along with the extension of the file
if you see here my file name is employee
data so i'll write
employee
space data
dot txt
and i'll close this
copy this
and i'll paste it here
and the next file we are going to attach
is
my logo let me just rename this i'll
just write
logo
okay
and you can check the
data type by going to the properties you
see here it is of type jpg
and we'll use the same extension for
this i'm going to delete this and make
it as logo
dot
jpg
okay
now if you want to display the email to
edit the email body manually or ensure
everything looks correct you can use the
dot display method
so what i'm going to do is
i'll write
new
email
item
dot i'll use the display property and
i'll say
displays true
then finally
you want to
send the email to the mentioned email
addresses
you need to use the dot send method
so even dot displays a method and not a
property
okay so i'll write now
new
email
item
dot
send
okay
so we have our code ready here let me go
to the top
and tell you what we did so first i
created my
sub procedure which is send email
underscore demo
then we created our variables email app
which is
to refer to outlook application then we
had
new email item which was to refer to new
outlook email
then we passed in our source string
then to launch our outlook application
we used
new outlook dot application
now to
launch
new outlook email we use the email app
dot create item method
and then we saw how to use the dot 2
property ccbcc we wrote our subject then
we passed in our
email body
and then we saw how to attach the
current workbook using the attachments
property or the method
then we passed in our
two files which was employee data and
the logo file
by giving the
file location and using the attachments
dot add method finally we are displaying
and sending the email
before i run it
this should be
new email item
again this should also be new email item
okay
now you can see here i have saved it as
email underscore demo dot xlsm which
means this workbook is now
macros enabled
all right
so now it's time for us to go ahead and
run our script so here on the top you
can see we have the run option
let's go ahead and run it
it says there is some compilation error
let's debug it
okay
so in the references we actually
missed adding
one of the other references
let's do it now so i'm actually looking
for
microsoft
outlook 16.0 let's search and add it
i'll show you which one
okay so this object library which says
microsoft outlook 16.0 object library we
missed adding
initially so let's add this as well
all right so now let's go ahead and run
our script
you see here
on the top you can see the subject test
email demo and we have the message box
you see here we have attached
three files the one is the
email underscore demo dot xlsm which is
the current workbook we are working on
then we have the employee data file and
we have the
logo png file as well and these are my
email ids that i had put in my script
and below you can see the body of the
mail if you want you can edit it here
you can bring this to the next line
all right now if you just click on send
the email will be triggered now this
happened because
in the script we have used the dot
display method
now the display
method ensure that you can edit your
email body and make sure everything
looks correct before sending the email
i'll go ahead and close this
i'll say no
and what i'm going to do here is
i'm going to comment this line which
says new email item dot display true
so every time we run this vba script
our
display
box that we just saw won't appear it
will directly trigger the mail by
sending it
now let's run it again
okay now we are going to check our
mailbox now
okay so this is how our
email looks like on the top you have the
subject of the email which is test email
demo and then below you can see the body
of the mail which says hi this is a test
email from excel regards jimmy
and at the bottom you can see we have
the three attachments the first is the
simply loan logo then we have the
employee data which is present in a doc
file and third we have the excel file
that we were working on
we will be learning about mail merge in
excel but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simplyland now first up what
exactly is mail merge
mail much in excel is a simple yet
spectacular method to write similar
emails to hundreds and thousands of
recipients without a hassle or even a
single error
let us imagine that you are supposed to
write an interview call letter to
multiple recipients
so
what if you had like five recipes you
could do five different emails and you
could send them but what if you had 50
or even 500
right that would seem a little
troublesome and you might even feel that
you might want a whole team to do that
right
but what if i say that you can do the
same with one single mail within a
matter of minutes you send all the
emails to all the 50 or 500 recipients
sounds interesting right so now in this
particular tutorial we are going to do
the same
now without further ado let's directly
get onto the practical mode and start
our excel and try to do some mail merge
in excel
now we are on practical mode and we have
started our microsoft excel
so
regarding the example we discussed
earlier that is sending an interview
call letter to multiple people that's
what exactly this excel sheet does so
here we have about 25 members or 25
candidates with their first name last
name and email and their address written
over
now where is our call letter now this
happens to be our call letter so the
call letter has been sent from an
imaginary company that is smart
solutions private limited india
and followed by that we are having one
recipient here who happens to be mia
and the subject and everything all the
text related to the interview call
now we are trying to send this one
single interview call letter to all the
25 people
now the only change that is going to
happen is the recipient's name and
address is going to change and the
addressing
for example here you can see dear mia so
instead of dear mia we're going to
greet the recipient with their
particular name so that's what we're
going to try to do now so to do that you
have to go into the toolbar and select
mailings option
in the mailings option
you can see
the start mail merge select recipients
edit recipient and all other options so
here you might want to select the second
group and inside the second group you
have an option called select recipients
click on that
and now it will show you some options
the first one is type a new list so if
you are having some list then you can
type in or if you already have an
existing list like what we did creating
an excel sheet and storing all the email
and address and all the recipients
complete details you can use that as
well
so here we're going to use the existing
list so click on that
now it will show you
a new dialog box using which you have to
navigate to the existing list
so our existing list is named as mail
merge so click on that and select open
now press ok
now the next part is
to address all the details
so here
you can see that
two address and after that you can see
the addressing of the recipient now we
have to encode this mail in such a way
that
to all the recipients automatically
excel will replace the addresses names
and the greetings
right now let's try that
[Music]
now let's try to encode the address part
so highlight the address part and in the
same mail links option
you can find
the
address block in write and insert fields
ribbon
so let's select that
and now you can see the address of
everyone
right
so this is the preview of the
recipient's address now you can see that
the recipient's full name and state is
only available here not the street and
house number etc now you can fix that by
selecting the match fields option
and here you can include the address
so
which might be the housing apartment and
the second one would be street
and
postal code you can match it with pin
code
and that's all yeah remaining we have
everything else let's look at the
preview and this is how it looks like
perfect
now let's select okay
that's fine
and
similarly we will also try to
match the
just a moment yeah similarly we'll try
to encode the recipient's name
now for that let's go into the greetings
line
here you can see you can select the
option dear sir or dear ma'am or to
whomever mates may concern
and here you have another option
two or just dear so we'll go with deer
and this is how the preview looks like
and if you're happy with that
it's okay and if you want to parallely
check for other things i mean other
recipients you can also do that
for example the next recipient is santo
shastri and followed by him we have
prabhakar reddy rajesh sahoo right you
can also check everything and here you
can also see the address changing on the
mail
so we can check for jagadi's charity his
address and his name
right so it looks like it's working
perfectly now select ok and that's done
now we are in the final stage and in the
mailings option you can see the last two
options that is the preview results and
finish so before merging and finishing
the mail merge we shall go through a
quick preview to check if everything is
fine or not
so here you can see we have the address
block this is how the encoding looks
like
and if you
replace the encoding with the actual
address and name this is how the
actual address and name look like and
you can check all the letters you can
just click on the arrow key here and you
can check all the recipients address and
their
names
right so if you can find any errors you
can replace them and if not if
everything is fine then you can just
quickly press on the finish and merge
option when you finish merge option or
finish and merge option you get three
different
options that is edit individual
documents print documents and send all
these to the recipients
now if you had any queries or if you had
any doubts about or if you find any
errors on the emails then you can go to
that particular individual document and
edit it with the first option and in the
second option you can print all the
documents like if you want to send a
hard copy then you can print it
so you can see here all and select okay
and then you can
you know kind of save it as a pdf or you
can
send the location of your printer and
then just press ok
right you can just save them in the form
of pdf
or you can directly send the emails
right now i'm not connected to any
printer so i'm not going to print any
documents now let us try the last one
this should be interesting
now
when you select the mail option
then it automatically selects the email
column
from your excel sheet remember we had an
email column from excel sheet right
this particular column word
automatically selects that column from
excel and you can just select ok and all
the mails will be sent to all these
imaginary mailing addresses
so that's how it's done
let's look at one more interesting
feature of excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen
conditional formatting has different
rules which can be applied on your data
and that allows you to basically
differentiate
or easily identify data values which
are
based on certain criterias or rules so
when you talk about conditional
formatting you have different options
such as you can highlight cell rules you
can get top and bottom values
you can
apply different rules apply different
color scales and you you can easily
manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data and easily perform
some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition
you can perform conditional formatting
to identify cells you can highlight a
few significant cells and you can easily
perform conditional formatting
as shown
on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look
so say for example we have our excel
sheet and if you see here
i am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
revenue greater than 10 000.
so
we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color
and how do we get here so for example
let's select
this data
and what i could do is
i could go into conditional formatting
now i could basically highlight cell
rules and we could just say greater than
that's an easier way i could also go
ahead and create a new rule but then i
can use one of this option i can say
greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at any
value greater than twelve thousand so
let's choose twelve
thousand
and here
it says what color would you want to
select so for example
i would say
something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay
so right now what i'm doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10 000
but then i have also selected all the
sales
people who have made
or who have generated revenue greater
than 12 000.
so i can just wait ctrl z to see the
previous result now here
i had the values which were greater than
ten thousand
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale
so if you look at the values here i have
a three color scale mainly in green
yellow and red
and how do you do this so for example i
can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here
you can create different rules so
we can set up a two color scale so we
can say format
only values that are above and below
average i can format only cells that
contain something
i can get the top and bottom values so
these are different ways in which
i can
have a three color based scale now what
i will do is i will select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example
i can go into manage rules and if you
see here there are certain rules which
have been specified now what does that
mean so you would want to specify a
three grade scale
so for example if i would want to look
at my first rule
it tells me that i am choosing three
color scale i can choose lowest value
percentile and highest value and that
basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example
i have all these rules
but you should always carefully remember
that the rules will be applied in the
order shown so for example if i just
delete these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now
it does not have any highlighting now i
can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting
i could go for color scales or i could
basically go into
new rule
so i would want
the
cells to be using three color scale so
let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50
and then the highest value is green and
if that looks good let's say okay and
now if you see the lowest values have
been highlighted as red
you have mid values and then you have
the positive value so this is the three
color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can
basically color the cells based on their
value so what we are seeing here is if
the revenue generated
is greater than average then that shows
in green
and if the revenue generated is lesser
than average that's shows in orange
now how do we do that so we can
basically again manage some rules so i
can basically create a new rule
now here i can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option i would want to select now i can
select this and it says format values
that are above average so
in our case we had it in green so for
example i'll say above average and then
here i can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size
so
let's go and look into
the formatting
so for example let's choose yellow
say okay now i'm saying
wherever
the cell values are above average it
would be yellow instead of green and
let's go in here
let's go and look into manage rules so
this is
basically the rule which we are applying
now we can also add a new rule
and
i need to select the values so for
example i will say
here so we had gone for above now we
will go for below
we will go for format we will choose red
we'll say okay we'll say
now
these are
basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if i select this and then
i could basically
choose my area just hit on enter
and similarly you can go in here
and then select
your area
hit on enter and say apply say okay and
now if you see
i have really chosen bright colors but
then i have said wherever my revenue
generated is
above average
it should be in yellow and
below average should be in red so we
wanted above
average to be in green
and below average to be in orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also find the top 10
and bottom 10 values and that's pretty
easy so you can just select this
and then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10
now you can choose the color and for
example i'll go for
blue
and
i'll say okay
so now if you see my top 10 values are
blue now similarly i can add one more
rule so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay
say okay and that's it so now you have
your values which are top or bottom 10
values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also
have the values which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing
so what
we can do is we can select our
columns
either you could apply this to all the
columns now here i have applied this
only to jan and april now i could apply
this for june so let's say june so you
can go for gradient fill you can go for
solid fill
you can obviously just select the color
and that takes care of the things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill
which is color you have no border this
is basically color is black now i can go
for something like gradient fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply and okay
so this basically is like your first
column so you can use conditional
formatting for various use cases and you
can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be
here the revenue is getting generated or
was getting generated but did not grow
beyond a particular value
and so on
now similarly you can also go in for
different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased
or say for example if the revenue was
going up for this particular sales
person so here we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was
kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can obviously work
on this
wherein we can grade our cell values so
what we can do is we can
go in for
highlighting the cell values now
you can go for color scales you can go
for icon sets and this is where you can
choose your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
i would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional
i could go
using this three arrows i can go in for
this color i can choose directional
and then
my values are
automatically
using directional now what we can also
do is we can then go into manage rules
and that basically tells me what rules
have been applied
so for example the latest one is the
icon set which i have chosen it shows
the selected columns i can obviously do
a edit rule and then i can choose so i'm
saying the format style is
icon sets
i'm not using a data bar i'm not using
color scale
now here
i have chosen the style of icons
and then here
you can basically give some values so
you have icon which is green
when the value is greater than or equal
to 67 percentage
when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily
highlight your cell values based on this
icon set so i can apply this and that's
how i use conditional formatting so
conditional formatting can be very
useful if you would want to use icon set
if you want to use your data bars
if you would want to
highlight particular values
if you would want to color code based on
some calculation
if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts
or people who are working business
intelligence teams or people who would
want to use excel to easily identify the
data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out
less significant or more significant
cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations
or analysis
so let's continue learning on using
excel for various things now we have
learnt on conditional formatting and
seen how that can be very helpful
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation now this can be very useful
when you would want to work on
validating the data which is being fed
in the cells so you could limit it to
basically a number between a particular
value you could also add some messages
to it
if you would want
or you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed now
that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that so you
can basically select the cells
or
you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later drag
the property to other fields now here
once the cell is selected so for example
let's try this out and let's see if that
works so for example i will say peter
johnson
okay
and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
junior
and if i do this it says
input length is greater than 15 do you
want to continue if i say yes
right so basically it is allowing me to
add the value here but then it has
basically violated the rule
now this is giving a message to the user
that the username should be entered less
than 15 characters now how do we do that
so for this
we can basically
select the column and then we can search
for data tab
and get into data validation
so this is where you can create or
select different kind of rules so for
example i can go into data validation
i can go into settings and i can say the
text length
and that should be less than 15. now
this is the maximum i'm giving and it
says apply these changes to all other
cells within the same settings
so i can do this or i can just drag and
drop so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column
and that will allow only 15 characters
it will pop up a message
if the user really wants to go beyond
the particular limit
now you also have similarly date of
birth so the restriction is date of
birth should be between 10 jan 1990 to
30 december 1998.
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here i have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range
that is 10 jan date
1990 12 30 1998 so that's the start and
the end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up which says
enter a valid date now i can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so i can say stop
i can say invalid entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this
and that says invalidate entered i can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until
i do not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well i
would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c2 to c14
so let's get into data validation let's
look in settings and here
we are choosing custom
now within custom i am choosing
what is the formula so i am saying is
number
and then i am saying find
at the rate for
the rows c2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here is the value
should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email
should contain
at the rate
so if i do this and if i say okay now
you can test it so you can say abcd
and that says email should contain at
the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values so now you
have the field called salary it says
salary should be greater than 50 000 now
we can limit the values by
choosing
a whole number so for example for salary
i can go into data validation
i can go into settings so here i can say
something like
decimal or i can go for whole number so
both of the things are fine it depends
on what kind of values get into this
particular field so if i say whole
number and if i say it has to be greater
than 50 000
so i'm saying the minimum is 50 000
or i could have given a decimal and then
i can say greater than less than equal
or anything or even between so i can
select greater than and then i can just
say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will
generally not be decimal so this would
be whole number salary
is
can be a whole number or it could be
decimals so we have chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation i have chosen whole number
i have set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends i can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand
how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be
based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city so if i would want
to
implement a data validation based on
this so for example if you see here city
and that basically shows me only the
four values which can be entered and if
i go to place then it tells me for
maharashtra i can only enter pune mumbai
nasik now how do i do this so say for
example you take an empty field and you
want to restrict the values of city
names so i could
select data validation i could basically
select list
and then it tells me you need to enter
the list values that is the source so
you click here and then i can just
select these fields now if i do this and
if i say ok
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into this
it will show me
the same thing but then it shows me some
empty cells
which did not have any value so this is
fine but it would be better if we do it
in a different way so i can select this
and i've already given my city names
here so i can just do a data validation
and here in the source
let me get rid of this
now i can just
have my cursor here
i can select these values
and then if i say ok so now if you see
my city names have been restricted to
these values and that's how you can
implement
your data validation so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one by just doing a ctrl z
now i'll come here and say for example i
would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in
doing this for all my four cities now if
you see here i have
data validation i could choose bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done so i could select this or
for example i can go in here i can
select data validation i can select list
and then here in the source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be these
and then
if i basically say ok
now
if we see these are the values which are
fed into bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect
f2 so basically i'm giving in a formula
which relates to the value which is in
for the city maharashtra so we could do
this or in a simpler way we could do
this and then just drag and drop here so
we could check for maharashtra what are
the values
let's choose a different city so for
example kolkata and here i will choose
now since we did a drag and drop it has
basically taken the values of bank load
so that's not right so we select this we
go into data validation and here i can
either
feed in the values
that is such as bangalore i could
basically say something like this
kolkata
and i could say okay
so now if you see it shows me the places
in kolkata
now here
we have let's choose a different city so
for example let's go for delhi
and here i can go to data validation and
i can just say delhi
so this is an easier way of doing it or
if you remember the formula
then what you can do is
you can just give in
indirect
and then basically
give the value of the cell
for which you would want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a cell which
should be
belonging to a particular list
so this is how you do a simple data
validation by restricting the
data in the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is one more very useful
feature of excel and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis
now pivot table is a summary of your
data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set
and it allows you to group your data in
several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of
items here it also tells me the sum of
sales
and basically it gives me per item what
is the total sum of sales which were
made now how do i get this here so for
example if i would want to delete this
and i would be interested in getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the
row end if i just do a control and right
arrow it tells me what's my right last
column
and if i just do a control and down
arrow it tells me there are
9994 rows
now i can use this
and what i can do is i can basically
work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since i have chosen my first
row and first column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
i'll say existing worksheet and i can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field
and that should be good enough
so
for example if i close this or if i say
okay
so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table
will be created now what are the fields
we are interested in so as per the
problem we need to find out what the
total sales for each category so let's
go in here and let's select the field
category now as soon as you do that it
shows that
the rows
which are
being selected are for this column
category and now we are interested in
getting the sales so we would want the
sales per category so let's select this
so you see some of sales is selected now
close this and that's it that's that's
your data so it shows you row labels
it tells you what are the different
categories
and it also gives you
sum of sales which is per category now
this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have
another data set so
again you can just check how many rows
we have and it is basically the same
9994
and if i look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and
here
we would want to find out
which category
so for example let me get rid this with
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so
we have some categories here which says
furniture and it shows some sub
categories
and then it shows me office supplies and
then some sub categories and same thing
with technology now we know how we got
this data but this is different than
what we were seeing here so here we were
just getting the categories but but we
did not have any breakdown
of sub categories within this particular
category and here you see there is a
breakdown and then basically you can
also apply a filter which basically says
what is the data you want and if you are
interested in finding out a particular
value now how do we do this so for
example let me get rid of this now we
know how we can find out the category of
items but we would want to find out
which sub category of items sold the
maximum under each category so here we
are not looking at sales but we are
looking at the quantity
okay
so what we can do is we can go to the
first row and first column
click on insert click on pivot table
data is already selected let's choose
existing worksheet let's choose a
location in our worksheet where we would
want to have this so might be i can
select this particular field and then
just close this
so it says
this is the existing worksheet say okay
and now you need to select your
columns
so for example
if
i would want the data for categories so
i can select this now i know
that within category these are the
options which we have and then there is
a sub category so let's select that and
if you see here
now we have the data which will be
filtered so based on your category and
sub category and then we will choose
quantity so it automatically understands
that this is something on which
summation can be done so let's select
this and close on this now if you see
here we have got our items
where we can see
the sub categories within a particular
category now i can basically close this
and that just shows me
high level categories here so here
i can again
select a particular
row and column i can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected
existing worksheet is what i want so now
i will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier so we will select
category subcategory and quantity so the
data is already coming
just select this and now you already
have all your data but this is not what
we want we want to basically apply a
filter
to this now how do we do that so we can
go for
slicer so i can go for insert slicer and
then it tells
what are
the subcategories which you are
interested in so for example
if i go for something like
subcategory and say okay so this tells
me
what are the categories you are
interested in so for example we know
that furniture has furnishings with the
highest value
so i can select say furnishings
and then i was interested in office
supplies
so within office supply i can basically
search for
here
binder so i can just do a control and
select binder
and then i can also know for technology
i can select phones so i'll say control
and select phones
and now if you see the filter has been
applied and we have these sub categories
which are selected so we have our data
here now we don't need really this so i
can just delete this and i have my data
which shows me
furniture being the main category and
that has only furnishings office supply
having binders and technology having
phones and that basically
is a filter applied on the result of
your pivot so this is how we are seeing
which subcategory of items
were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis let
us look at some more examples
now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region
that made the highest average profit now
how do we calculate that
so for example this is the data we have
and as i have instructed earlier you can
select the first row and first column
you can click on insert go into pivot
table
and that basically selects all your data
we will choose the result should be in
this existing worksheet so select this
click here
and then basically
let's select
this cell
and
i will say okay so now my pivot table
will be here so we are interested in
finding out top three states within each
region which have made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select
region so when we select region it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state so
within every region you have multiple
states so that's what we are selecting
and then we are interested in looking at
the profit so let's select profit and
that automatically shows up here
so we can now say close this
so basically we have all the data but we
are looking at the sum of profit but
that's not what we want
we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit
now how do we change that so here we
have sum of profit so i can do a right
click
and basically i can say summarize values
by average so now i'm getting the
average here and that basically tells
per region
i have the average profit
but first is let's sort this data so
let's go into sort more options and here
i have average of profit
or for example as i said you can select
region say okay
and now it is
basically having the
regions
and then you have your state value so
again we can do a
sorting here and i can say
let's go for more sort options i'll say
descending the state values should be
based on average profit so let's say
okay and now if you see
in particular region we have
the data which has been
sorted
wherein you have the highest average
profit on the top
now what we can also do is we can
basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but i'm not interested in top 10 so i
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region
you have
the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average and then you are also looking at
the subtotal so which basically says
average profit for your west now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort z
to a
if that's what you would want to do or
you can go for sorting
more sort options and
you want to
sort the region which is as of now
based on descending z2a let's make it
ascending say okay
and now you see the data has been
filtered so it says per region
now you can always select this and you
can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit
now
we are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted
within the region and what is the
average
now we have one more question what is
the percentage contribution of each
sub-category of products under each
category to the total sales so we know
there are different products
there are different categories and
all the categories contribute to the
total sales so we would want to find out
what is the percentage contribution of
each sub category
of products
under each category so we not only want
the
category percentage but we would also
want what is the contribution of each
sub category
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
and first column
click on your insert click on your pivot
table and now the data is already
selected existing worksheet
place your cursor here
and then let's select this
cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category
and then within a category we will have
sub categories and we are interested in
the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales but we would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sum now we can click here value
field settings and it says if you would
want to summarize this it says show
value as
and
what are the values you would want so
you can straight away go ahead here and
say percentage of grand total so we
could do that because we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now i could basically say
in the percentage of grand total say
okay
and then
just close this so once you have closed
this you see
already the data is in
percentage so now we have our data with
subcategories but we also want the data
to be sorted might be in a descending
order which tells
which subcategory is contributing more
than others we can select how many
subcategories we are interested in so we
can basically select
one of the sub category cells
right click now you have option filter
and you have sorting so we can say more
sort options
now here i will say descending and
you want the
descending to be sum of sales which is
already showing us percentage
click on ok and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales
it shows the sub categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total sales
so technically speaking if you look at
all these values which are sub
categories and if you would total them
that would be your total grand total so
this is how we can solve a simple
problem like this what is the percentage
contribution of each sub category of
products under
each category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for
home office segment
we are looking for customer which made
the lowest profit
we are also looking for the state
as the main
criteria so
in each state
we would look for home office segment
and within that we would look for
customer which has made the lowest
profit that means
the lowest value
of the profit so how do we do this
so let's say let's get into
selecting our row and column we will go
into insert i'll say pivot table
i'll say existing worksheet
and let me get my result here so let's
say okay now that gives me the pivot
table so the first thing is we are
looking at
per
state
and
i would be interested in
[Music]
home office segment or i could first
start with segment
now here we have segment
and in segment i can basically select
home office so i can just do a uncheck
and select home office only
and now i can select
state
so that will be my
sub category within segment and then
within state
we would want to find out the customer
so let's get the customer name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit
and here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this
and now you have your data
which basically shows me
the names of customers which made the
profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this
and we have state entries also so that's
fine so what i can do is here
i can basically say sorting go to more
sort options i can say i want to do it
descending or i want to do an ascending
and ascending based on
sum of profit so let's do that now you
see
the topmost value is the lowest value
per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state
so how do we do that so we can just
go for filtering go for top 10 values
i'm interested in bottom value and in
that also
i'm looking for only the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per state
customer who has made the lowest profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table
now say for example we have a question
which says find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order year as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice and then we would want to
create a pivot chart also so for example
how do we do that
so for example i will get rid of this
i will get rid of
this my pivot chart which we can
recreate
so find the sales made in each quarter
of 2016 for all the regions
so this is what we want
now how do we do this
so for example let's select this
we will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet
and then i can select this particular
cell i'll say okay
and now
i'm interested in data quarterly so
first let's select
our field here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if i say order date
now
you see we have quarters and ears which
are selected
now we could be selecting these fields
which says
quarters ears
and if i would want data to be filtered
based on years i could do that or i
could get rid of here so i have quarters
i have order date
so
that's being already selected now
what else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region
and we can also add region as a column
here so that will basically give me all
the regions
as different columns and then finally we
want the sales so let's select this
and now
let's look what we have
so if you see here
we have our data
which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels
so let's click on this so we have date
filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016
and the value has to be one
and then let's select this
and let's change this to 2016.
and
this is 12th month
and then we can say 31.
so we are saying the date has to be 2016
and it basically says
not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this
and let's make it date
and say okay
and now we have our data which is
for
2016
so for example i could basically select
this
and here i could be
looking at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from order data
so we have applied the filter on order
date
and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date
16 oh this is wrong so this one has to
be changed to 2016.
so select this and now we have our data
for
2016. so we have found the sales made in
each quarter of 2016 for all the regions
the grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value
or for individual months in a particular
quarter
and we have sliced the data now we could
have also
introduced a slicer by
selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if i would select a
particular field and then i could click
on slicer i could choose i would want to
slice the date based on order date and
then could have done it or we have just
given the
date for 2016. now we just need to
plot a graph for this and that's very
easy so you just need to select
the complete pivot data and here you
have the chart options so let's go for
line chart
and that basically shows me the line
chart
so we can select this we can just drag
and drop it here
and then
we can basically check if that is
showing us the data so if you see here
this is line chart where it has divided
the regions in different colors so we
have all the regions we could filter out
in pivot chart a particular region
we have
the quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is 2016.
in quarters it tells me it is 16. so we
have our data we have created a pivot
chart
and basically we have sliced the data
for
2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year
for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram
for the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what i can do is
i can basically
select my
row id here and now i'll do a pivot
table
so the data is already selected i'll
choose existing worksheet let's select
this particular cell say okay now what
are we interested in now if you look at
the fields we don't see any
years or quarters and so on so for
example here i can just choose order
date
and then basically
i can choose say for example
years or quarters
the data which is coming out from my
order date so here i will just select
years
now
then i have my order date
so
we are interested in the years
orders and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select
profit so that basically says sum of
profit
but then
i'm on also interested in
for all the categories of products so
what i can do is here
i have my field which is category and
that i'll add to the columns so that
shows me what are the different
categories
and this looks fine now i'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is i'll click on region
and here it says select all i'm only
interested in east and west so let's
select this
take this put it here
let's say okay and now
we have the data which has been filtered
based on the region so here we have
region so you can always look at the
filter it is east and west and we have
our year data
per year we have
different categories you can always look
at what are these column labels so this
is my different categories
and this is the profit per category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this
so we have our data for all these years
different categories the profits made
per year
and if i would want i could go into an
year and i could look into different
months
so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so i can just
place my cursor here i can select this
and then i can go into insert and here i
have different options so we can go for
bar chart
we can go for insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional
let's select this and here you see you
can obviously select different regions
you have your years
which shows up
you have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data and
understand it in a better way let's look
at an example of
one more useful function
in excel and that is vlookup now vlookup
is used to see if a value exists in a
range of values and we can create a
range of values which is nothing but
a block of cells which has a name
and can be referenced so
mainly to use vlookup we need to create
a named range
and that can be referenced anywhere in
the workbook or the other option is you
can always drag and select
uh the range of data in which you would
want to search something now there is
also
uh other functions such as hlookup which
pretty much does the same thing however
it does it horizontally that is left to
right instead of vertically there are
other functions like lookup and x lookup
and so on so when we talk about vlookup
let's see how we do that so for example
this is the range of or this is the data
which has been given to you and here is
the question find the employee name with
employee id 107. now assume that you
might have huge amount of data and you
may want to search something so how do
we do it now here i have created some
column and then some basic formatting i
have given it as an employee id i've
given employee name now what i can do is
i can create a range of data now how do
i do that or a named range so what you
can do is you can select the data and
then you can do a right click now here
you have something like get data from
table range so you can do that you can
define a name so you can click on this
and here
you can give a
name to the range what you would want to
call it so for example let's say our
search
now that's the named range i'm creating
and just say okay so the scope is
workbook and i've created a named range
which you can see here so it shows for
search our search so you have created a
named range now how do we do a vlookup
here so for that we can use a formula so
for example i would want to search for
employee name where employee id is
whatever you would want to search for
so employee id we can give here 107. now
that's what we would want to search the
employee name for
and employee name is what we are
interested now what we can do is we can
use the function option here i can do a
insert function and that shows me
different functions which are here now
vlookup is showing up because i have
recently searched for it or
you can
basically just type in here look
and you can do a go so that shows you
all the look of options what you have
like lookup hlookup match vlookup and so
on so we would be interested in vlookup
so let's select that and click on ok
now that basically opens up this
function arguments and it shows what
does this function do so it says looks
for a value in the left most column of a
table
and then returns a value in the same row
from a column you specify
by default the table must be sorted in
an ascending order now you can
basically say this is what you would
want to search for what is the lookup
value if you place your cursor here it
says what is the table array that is
nothing but the range which we can use
our named range here we have the column
index number which basically tells me
what is the column number in the range
which we want so what is the value we
want from which column and then
basically you have range lookup which
basically is the fourth option
and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to
give a particular value which is nothing
but
we would be interested in say employee
name
so i can
basically search for a value based on
the lookup value now how do we do it so
we are saying we would want to search
for employee id which is 107. so what i
can do is i can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee id for which i would want to
search the employee name i could
actually select the cell here which is h
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so might
be we can select this one which is h6
and whatever value we key in here we
will be searching for employee name for
that employee id
now table array is we would want to give
a range so what we can do is we can give
our range so for example we had selected
something like our search
and if you see here that already selects
or shows me employee id employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now
column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so i can just
say 2
and that basically is the column number
and then you have to give a range lookup
which is a logical value so either you
give an exact match or
you can basically give a
closest match so we can say for example
do a 0 which basically means false or
you can say 1 which is true so let's go
for 0 now that's our formula so it says
vlookup you will search for the value as
per h6
in the range
and then you are looking for employee
name which is column number two and then
true or false so let's click on ok
and that basically gives me the value
which is parallel up
birch
so here i'm searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this
for other columns and you can do that so
if it finds
employee
id here now say for example if we had an
employee id somebody enters an employee
id which is not in the range for example
let's try
121 and then you see this is basically
an error right because
it does not have any employee id with
121. now how do i take care of this so
there is a formula which is called if
error and that can be used to take care
of this
so if the value is not found then it
will
show whatever i would want to
show here so what i can do is i can
still select this
and what i can do is i can search in
function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do is
we can test it here so for example if i
look in function and if i search for
error and say oh
go
so there are lots of
functions here and this is the function
we are interested in if error so if i
say okay now this takes the value and
what is the value if error so for value
what i can do is basically
i can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula
and value if error so for example i will
basically say for example not found
so we can try this and we can say okay
now here it says not found so whenever
it is n a it is not found
now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of h7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if i would say
107
like earlier and then hit on enter so it
says panel of cruise and it shows us the
value
right and if we enter something else
then basically
here it shows any and it shows not found
but what we want to do is we want to
merge these two so what i can do is i
can get rid of
or i can basically take this one
now
what i would want is i want this formula
to
be here
so what i can do is i can say if error
and then
basically
given your vlookup
option or function here and then say for
example not found here
not found now that basically will take
care of any kind of error if the value
is not found so when we say 121 it
basically says not found but if i say
107 which is found then it shows me the
value so we are using vlookup but then
we are also using if error which will
take care of our error message or
basically the not applicable
pound not applicable replaced with
whatever value we key in
similarly we can do the same thing here
so we have to find the job title so we
are interested in finding out the job
title once the employee name is given
now employee name can basically have a
value from the cell or whatever value
you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with our v
lookup so that's the
function we are interested in
so you can just do a double click now
you are interested in finding out the
value whichever is given here
so that's the lookup value
and then you are interested in
finding out the job title from the range
so i will still give our range which
basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range
and now i'm interested in finding out
the job title so that's column number
four
and then i can just give zero which is
for false so now we have given our
vlookup but that shows not applicable
because we have not given any employee
name so we can key in the value here
which says fred stone and now
if we are basically giving the value so
fred stone now
we will have to search if there is any
job title which is fred stone so here is
the value so that should be showing up
let's check what has gone wrong so we
are giving our range
we are interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was
that when we want to search for a value
say for example let's take this vlookup
and let's replace this value of h2l with
the
value here so fredstone
and then basically we will give our
range we will save which is the column
we are interested in and then give true
or false
so
we can also basically take care of this
error message so for example let's take
this complete formula from here
and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for h6 which was employee id
now that's not what we are interested in
we are interested in finding out the
value
so let's take this one and replace this
with the value given here
and then i give my range i say which is
the column i'm interested in so i'm
interested in looking for job title
and then let's search so it basically
tells me
not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example i go for function
and then i select vlookup and say for
example i say ok
now just look at the description here
looks for a value in the leftmost column
of a table now earlier the range which
we had selected had the left most column
as employee id and that's why it was
giving an error so how do we fix that so
for example let's
basically
remove this function from here
now what we want to do is we would want
to search for the stock broker now if
you see here
i have given a range which is b
1 to d 21
so we would want
the value for what we would want to
search say employee name that should be
the left most column so
so that's how we have our function so
let's do that so say for example the
name is given here so we want a range so
either we can create a range like
earlier by selecting say for example
this data
now am i interested in salary no i'm
interested in job title right so i can
basically just three columns
and then i can define a name so i can
say our
search
to
and let's give a named range and that's
only because we would want to easily
reference or use that named
search or named range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say
v
lookup
and then
you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes
so basically this is my function we will
say if the value is not found then we
will give this so you can create an
external structure
and then within your vlookup we will say
the leftmost column which we are
interested in
so
that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either i can directly select the value
here in the column b or i will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name
then i need to give a range so let's
select our range so that's your hour
search too
and then you need to select the column
number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give it
zero
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name now
let's
try to find the job title of fred stone
so i can just select or i can say equal
and then i can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup
we have also used if error which
basically takes care of error message if
the value is not found so for example we
can test this
here we have fred stone so for example
if i
just empty this and i point it to
something which does not exist so that
shows me not found or if you just select
this and then key in a value it shows
you this might be we can just type in so
if i say fred
then basically it says not found because
we are looking for exact match now if we
had changed this to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this
so there are different ways of doing it
so what we can do is we can always go
for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example i would be interested
in finding out
this one
and let's give this so you can search in
this way so you can also have statements
which can be searching one related to
other
now here the question was to find the
job title of fred stone so let's type in
fred stone and that basically shows me
the job title which we are interested in
so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interesting to see how
horizontal lookup or edge lookup works
it basically works in the on the same
lines but here
instead of
vertically searching through the columns
the range is more of horizontally
defined so we search
in rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee id you have
your employee name
you have employee email address
you basically have the job title of
different employees
and then basically you have the salary
so this is the data which has been given
to you and you are asked to search or
you are interested in finding out say
the salary based on employee name or job
title based on employee id so what we
need to do is we need to define the
range here
now range can depend on what you are
searching for so for example when i am
searching employee name and salary
so i am interested in these four rows
when i'm saying employee id and job
title then might be this is the range
and i don't need salary so i can create
a named range if we are interested in so
that we can easily search for it or we
can straight away give the
the first cell value which is basically
a 1 here
and then the last
value here which is g and then you can
give 5 so you can do that or you can
create a named range whichever way you
would want to do it so for example we
would want to create a named range for
our first question which is
find the salary of eden connell using h
lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now
like we did earlier we can just define a
name
might be we can call it our
search three
and we can just give okay so that's the
named range which we have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name
so here we can insert our function so
let's look up
and let's search for look
and just click on co so here you have
hlookup and basically that's the
function i'm interested in say okay
so this says what is the lookup value
which you are interested in so we are
interested in finding out the value
based on the employee name
so for example let's select this cell
that gives us more dynamism and you can
add in any name and you can search for
the salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is d
two so we can give eden conal from here
so let's select this now table array so
we need to give our range so let's say
our search three
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name to salary so let's give
the row index number which is four and
the range lookup will say zero which is
basically exact match and that completes
our formula so click on ok and that
basically gives me the salary for edin
connell
now that's basically because we have fed
in the value here and that is basically
giving me this so i can again
do if error if i would be interested in
to basically take care of error message
if the value is not found for that you
can look into the previous example which
is vlookup now similarly we are
interested in finding out the job title
for employee id 1 0 5 how do we do that
so we need to use hlookup
well we could have done with vlookup but
here the data is more arranged in the
form of rows
so how do we do that so we can again use
hlookup but and we can give a range
or named range or let's for this time
let's basically
key in our range manually so we can do
that so let's go for h lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value
then we need to give a range
now as i said if you would want to give
a range manually so for example i'll say
a
and then i'll say a
1
colon and then i'm interested in
g
and then the row will be four so salary
row is not what we are we are not
interested in so let's say g
and then we can give four so that
basically gives me the range
right instead of having a named range so
we can do that and then we need to give
the row index number so we are
interested in finding out the job title
which is basically in our range the
fourth row and then give 0 for true or
false so if you see here it tells if it
is 1 it is approximate match
false is an exact match and we can close
this bracket that completes our formula
it takes the value which is given in
employee id and then it will try to
search for the job title so that
basically shows wherever the employee id
is 105 the job title is fabricated again
you can use if error
wherein
your if error can then be working on
hlookup and can take care of error so
that if an employee id is keyed in
for which there is no matching value
then
it will
not show you
a not applicable error in
instead of that it will replace with the
word whatever you have specified so in
this way you can easily use hlookup to
search
from the range of data which is
horizontally arranged and in the
previous example we were seeing how you
use
vlookup when the data is arranged
vertically so we have looked at
vlookup and h lookup and what we have
seen is vlookup has a limitation in one
way that
we need to basically give a range where
the leftmost column is the one which is
used now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for so for example we have this
question find the salary of hank
saunders
now that's the employee name which we
have here and we would want to find out
the salary so what are the columns we
are interested in so one is your
employee name and one is your salary and
these are the only two columns which we
are interested in so instead of using
vlookup now like i've shown earlier you
can create a named range for these two
columns and you can use that
or we can manually give the range here
so let's go for lookup function here and
lookup function will basically help us
in searching what we are interested in
so we are interested in finding out the
employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup i can
first give the value which is here
employee name now
whatever employee name is keyed in here
we will be searching for salary of that
employee now lookup function needs a
lookup value
so
we are searching
based on employee name then it says
lookup vector so we will basically then
say
what is going to be our lookup vector so
here we need to give a range so what are
we interested in we are interested in
finding out the salary based on employee
name so first goes our range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example select this one so that's our
range b1 to b21
so that will basically have the employee
name in which we will be searching for
and then we are interested in searching
out the
the result vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this
and that completes our lookup function
so now if you hit on enter it shows
that for this employee where the name is
hunk saunders the salary is 5400
now you can test it by
basically giving some other name so for
example if i replace this with
say
fred stone
and that basically shows me the value
for fredstone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is hank
saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
left most column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee id
of
this particular email id so we need to
again use our lookup function so we'll
say lookup now what are we interested in
we will search based on this email
address so i will select this
then i need to give
that based on email address we are
searching the employee id so email
address is in this column so let's
select this range
and then we are interested in employee
id so then goes
our result vector so select this column
and that basically completes your
formula so close this bracket and hit on
enter so that basically shows me the
employee id for an employee with this
email address so this is how you use
lookup now as i've explained earlier you
can be using the if error and you can
basically see how
your
index match can be used now here is an
example of if error
so basically this shows how if error
helps so say for example as i showed in
your employee james bond if the value is
not present display not found and what
are we doing we are basically nesting
our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value
given in the cell h
is not found then
basically it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is b1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for multiple functions
we are searching for 2 that is the
column number 2 here that is employee
name so check for employee james bond if
the value is not present or no so we are
basically just searching for employee
name
here and then give your 0 or 1. so
that's basically usage of your if error
which i have shown earlier and the same
thing can be applied for your edge
lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example
you know instead of using your vlookup
or edge lookup or lookup examples what
we have seen
say for example you are asked to find
the salary of peter daniels now we
already know how to find that using
vlookup right so for example we want to
find out the salary for this employee
name which is peter daniels i can use a
vlookup however sometimes we may also
want to use a index match an index match
is also one useful function to do that
so we can basically search based on that
so we have to define the range of data
we have to then say what do we want to
match so that's basically an employee
name
and then we are interested in finding
out
say for example
based on the range
of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here i can use a
function which is called index
and if you see here it says returns a
value or reference of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so i can say a1
all the way to e21 so that basically is
my range
now i would want to find the salary of
this employee name which is peter
daniels so i can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically
give it correctly so we need to say
match
now how does this match function work so
we need to basically match for a value
so for example we will select whatever
employee name is given here so that's
peter daniels now that's basically what
we would want to match
now where do we want to match this so we
want to match in the column b which has
employee
names so we can give a range which is b1
to be
21 so that's basically
within the employee names we are looking
for a match
which is given here that's in h6
and we want to do a match so we want to
do a exact match so let's do a comma 0
and then
we are interested in finding out the
salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically
completes your function and just hit on
enter so that shows me
the salary of peter daniels right so
this is an easy way when you can use the
index function remember first you give
the range
and then you need to give your matching
condition so when you say match i would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell
i will search in the range of values
which is employee names
i will find an exact match and what i'm
interested in is finding the salary for
peter daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee id with salary ten
thousand so you want to find out the
employee id
wherever the salary is ten thousand so
we are obviously looking for an exact
match now how do we do that so we can
start with our index function and with
an index function we need to give a
range
so for example i am interested in
finding out
say for example
our range which is a 1
2
e 21 so that's what i'm interested in
or you are actually interested in
searching
based on
say your
salary so you are interested in
searching the employee id so maybe if i
just do a 821 let's see what happens
here
now then i can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here h
13
so i will do a match for this one now i
need to give a range
so let's
basically give a range which will be we
are interested in
searching employee id based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
i will say e1 to e21 that's what i'm
interested in searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine i mean we are interested in
finding out the employee id
based on the match which is within this
range
and
then what we would want to do is we
would want to
basically find the employee id employee
id is in my
column a so what i can do is i can
additionally give a match here
and then i can say i'm interested in the
finding out the value for employee id
and that basically needs a range
so the range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give a1
all the way to e1 so that's the range in
which we would want to search and we
would want to find a match for employee
id we want an exact match so let's close
this one and that basically closes my
match and we need to close our index
function so now that shows me employee
id where the salary is 10 000.
so this is how you can do your index
matches where you can give a range
then you can say what you need to match
within which particular column
whether it is an exact match or
approximate match and then the column
from where you are interested in finding
out the value so same thing we did here
we basically gave a complete range and
if you closely see
we were only interested in finding out
the employee id so here i give a range
a1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out
match basically will give your lookup
value so that's h13
then we gave a range which is salary
that's what we are interested in and
then we said when we are doing a match
we are only interested in finding out
the employee id
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match so this is how
you can use index match instead of
lookup which can also give you
some exceptions and searching for
specific columns or specific rows
now if error we have already discussed
where you nest your vlookup or h lookup
inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions hlookup
vlookup lookup or index match to search
for data
some function like this which shows up
xln dot x lookup
and then you're trying to search for
something so don't be
uh
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using
you have excel 2013 and say your friend
has a new version of excel say office
365 or excel 2016
and basically he uses your new cool
function and sends the file to you so
that's where you will have this
excellent prefix as i'm showing up here
so for example what is the job title of
xavier power is what you would want to
search and here the function which shows
up excel and x lookup
and then you are searching so this is
basically
something which is the function now if i
just select what it has selected here
and if i hit on enter it shows that this
does not work in my excel here and
that's because of the version but what i
can do is i can fix this by removing
this
details here
and that basically shows lookup we are
searching for
job title based on employee name which
is in this field h6
and then we need to give a range so we
need to give a range of names employee
name
and then basically
the
job title range which is basically the
job title so now if i just hit on enter
it gives me the value so it's as simple
as that similarly here what is the
employee id of the person with this
email we have already looked at the
lookup function so if it shows your xlnx
lookup all you need to do is remove this
and then keep the lookup function
searching for the value
based on the range of values and then
searching for a value within a range of
values so just hit on enter and that
gives you the value and same thing goes
for this job title so what is the job
title and salary of employee name
so we have this function now what i can
do is
here i am interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do i fix this i can basically select
this
and then just do a lookup
based on the values and
it basically says you can't change part
of an array so we can fix this
now what we need to do is we need to
basically search based on
this particular value so we will
basically say i want to do a lookup
now lookup should be based on employee
name whatever name is given here
then you need to find the job title in
salary so for job title i want to find
based on employee name so i will give a
range
and then basically i will say i'm
interested in finding out the job title
so i will give a different range and
then basically close this so
that basically shows
now this is basically because of the
function which we have here so basically
to fix this what we will have to do is
we will have to delete all the columns
here which were selected such as
employee name job title and salary
because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array now what we want to do is we want
to find the job title and salary based
on the employee name so we can do that
using lookup as we have done earlier so
we will use a lookup function now what
we are interested in finding out is the
job title based on employee name so we
can select this cell which does not have
any value
then we need to basically say
from which range or based on what you
want to search so we want to search
based on employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then
we will be interested in finding out the
job title
so let's select the job title range and
that basically completes our lookup so
let's close this and hit on enter now it
says obviously error because this does
not have any value
we will fix that by giving in a value
here
same thing we can do for salary so for
example i can just drag and drop it here
and in this one instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give
so the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name as the range
and then
we are interested in finding out
the salary so we will select this
particular range
and what we are interested in finding
out is basically
employee name
or we are interested in finding out
based on employee name so let's select
this particular column and then hit on
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix
your
excel fn
error so same thing goes here so it
shows you xln is what you would want to
search might be if you don't find
something you would want to
push in name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my excel and then i have
lookup i'm searching based on h24
which is basically employee id you are
giving a range which is a2 to 821
because we would want to find
name not found
for a particular employee id so i'm
giving a range which is a2 to 821
i'm trying to search for the name which
is from b2 to b21 and then i'm giving
name not found so
say for example we can do this lookup
but then
with lookup you don't have this direct
option what we can do is we can use if
error
if error and then basically try to
search so that gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here we are
searching for a particular range
and then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what i did was
i just use a vlookup so we know that
employee id 121 does not exist so i am
just using if error i am doing a vlookup
where i am searching for the value given
in h 19
and then
i am saying that i would want to search
from a range which is basically b1 to
c21 that is in employee name and say
email address for example
and we would want to basically search
for
name not found so we can
instead of giving b21 or b1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just b1 to b21
we are searching in column two we are
searching for exact value and if it does
not find then it says name not found and
that's how we do it so we can always
replace and fix this excel fn
errors
if you
are
using
uh some spreadsheet which was or excel
which was sent by
someone else who is using a different
version let's quickly see
some more examples of doing data
analysis using excel and for that we can
use
some inbuilt add-ins which can be added
to our excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive
analytics or descriptive analysis on
your data say for example getting your
descriptive statistics such as your mean
median mode and so on so we can do that
and we can use excel for it so for
example you can if you are given some
data say i have temperature price of ice
cream units sold and i would want to
have descriptive statistics on this what
i can do is i can click on file
and here in file you can click on
options and within options click on
add-ins
now within add-ins you have excel
add-ins which is selected here so click
on say go for example and that shows
what add-ins are available and you can
choose which ones are you interested in
so for example i have chosen analysis
tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your excel so if you click on data so
here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis and here it says what are you
interested in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histograms so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok
now this one basically asks your input
range so while your cursor is blinking
here
also it is said
grouped by so let's give it a range so
for example i will say say temperature
now if i do this and i have selected the
heading just look at that
and now you need an output range so
let's just select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking here
let's
select save fields here and this is
where i would want the output now it
also said what options do you want so it
has output range we can then select
summary statistics confidence level so i
will say summary statistics is what i'm
interested in say okay and this says
input input range contains non-numeric
data now why is that because we chose
temperature the heading also so click on
ok and here we will alter the range
so this one
is our range should be
only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics and now you can
click on ok
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here
i could basically
given a value for this so i can say
temperature
and that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature might be i can just do some
formatting
and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here
now similarly we can do it for price of
ice cream
so what we need is
we need to basically
go for data
data analysis
descriptive statistics say okay
now you need to give a range so here i
will
change my range to these values output
range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on ok
and this says output range will
overwrite existing data press ok to
overwrite data in range
i will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new range
so let's select our new range which is
here
and now click on ok
so now we get the values which is for
your price of ice cream so again we can
basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier i can select this i can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this
now i can go into data and i can go into
data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this b2 to
8
and this one which is h6 to h19 we would
want to shift it
might be 2 columns up so might be i can
just say h5
and i can manually change it to at 17.
and let's say okay
and
we will basically get this and i can get
rid of this
so i can have it in the same range
so similarly so this one will have to be
renamed and i can basically say price of
ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for
my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics so
we need to give the range correctly so
this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if
we were selecting the heading so let's
do it in this way so in my range
in my range
let me empty this
i can basically select this which we
know
has non-numeric data in the first row
say for example i'll say labels in first
row i'm interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from h
to basically something like
j
so let's say j
and let's select these values so that
should take care of things and now you
see you have your units sold you did not
have to manually rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis
using data analysis here
you can basically get your descriptive
statistics for your columns and then you
can do whatever needed formatting you
need
to basically make your data look
in a
good way
now let's look at one more example of
data analysis
where we may want to look at the
frequency of values or frequency of
values occurring in a range of values so
for example if you have been given
temperatures you have been given some
pins where you would want to identify
how many values fall into the range of 0
to 20
20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50 and the
easiest way to do that would be creating
histogram now histogram is usually used
for data analysis where you would want
to look at different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature might be there might be one
more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see
if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be sale of ice
cream is a is a response
based on temperature so it depends so
sometimes you may want to find the
relationship between two variables
whether they are positively or
negatively related or you would want to
do different kind of analysis and in
certain cases we may want to
first do analysis on one single variable
look at the frequency of values might be
also look at the defects and for which
we can use something like pareto chart
so we can go for histogram and that
basically gives us the frequency of
values now how do we do that so we have
already added the
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay
now i have already selected input range
so if you see here my input range is
temperature which is also with the
headings
and i have bin range which is basically
the range of values so for example i can
select this and that's my pin range i am
selecting
are the option labels because i'm using
the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and pins now we need to give
it output range so for example let's say
i would want my data here and that
becomes my output range so you can have
a sorted histogram or basically a pareto
chart
so if that's what you're interested in
looking at the frequencies for your
different ranges and here i am also
selecting chart output because i would
want to have a visual histogram which
gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on ok
and now you get your pins
so it basically tells you frequency of
values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the value is 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20
so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we can
basically say there is 120 here
with the 20 being the maximum value and
then there is one more 20 so that's your
0 to 20 then you have 20 to 30 which
shows three values so might be in that
case i can say 26
is one thing then i can say 30
that's the second one
and then basically i can look at 22
so
basically this one does not select 20 as
the lower range but it basically selects
30 as the higher range so i do see 20 to
30 there are three entries similarly we
can see values for 40 and 50
and since we have selected pareto or
sorted histogram that shows in a
descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range
so that shows me highest frequency is
five and then you have three and three
and then two so this is how we can
create a histogram and we can perform
analysis on a single variable
now as discussed earlier as i said
sometimes we may
be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables
are they linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on and for that we can use the
correlation
of your data analysis add-in so for
example you want to find out correlation
of temperature and units sold and what
we can do is
we can find out that using a formula so
for example if i search for something
like
co
relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select
the range of values for temperature
and then i am interested in finding out
the correlation of temperature in units
sold so let's select this
and that basically gives me a range of
values it gives me the correlation value
which is 0.2859
say ok and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of value so here we are interested
in temperature and price of ice cream so
let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that
let's close our bracket and here we have
the correlation value of temperature
and the price of ice cream similarly you
may be interested in finding out
temperature and units sold like what we
have done earlier
so we can do the same thing based on
function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so i can get rid of this one now how do
i do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into data we need to go click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this
now that basically needs an input range
so we need the range now i might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
i've selected all the columns here
we will say group by columns obviously
we need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading
now output range you can just give one
simple cell and that's where your data
will start from or you can give a new
workbook so click on ok
and that basically gives you
that basically gives your
correlation of your different variables
and what are the values and we can check
these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically
temperature
and price of ice cream
and that basically shows me 0.96149
have temperature in units sold so you
have 0.2859
now you can also look at units sold
and say for example price of ice cream
you can look at these particular values
so if i would be interested in finding
out
what is the relationship between these
variables i can easily find using
correlation so i could be
basically writing in a formula here and
selecting what are the cells so here we
were selecting a2
and c
here we were selecting a and b now might
be i'm interested in price of ice cream
and units sold and if that's what i'm
interested in then i will give a range
of b2 to b8 c2 to c8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values
so it's very simple in excel and you can
use either the data analysis tab
and
get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means
might be i'm interested in range of
values i'm interested in seeing a sample
of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if i go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which i see here might be i want
to see
say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or i
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly i would want to pick
up say three temperature values now how
do i do it so for example here i have
seven values now if i go
for periodic sampling
the sample
or periodic sample value which i need to
give has to be lesser than the total
input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here
and let's go for data analysis so we can
go for sampling here click on ok
and that needs a range of values so we
will select a2 to a8 now i could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case i can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row
now here we can go for
number of samples which we are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
i have seven values so what if i select
five
so for example if i say five
that means
i could just get one value so basically
when i'm saying 5 out of 7 so that's
just giving me out of 5 i want one value
so i can then just give an output range
so here i can basically select this cell
i'll say okay and now you see
it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is i've
said five it has given me the fifth
value that's your periodic sampling so
for example
we want more values so let's reduce this
period
to might be 2 which basically gives me
every second value so i can basically
say for example 2 and say ok
and then
say ok so that shows me
26
then you have 35
then you have 40 and then well this one
does not have any more values so that's
your periodic sampling now if you go for
random sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis go for sampling i'll
go for number of samples how many you
want so for example out of seven values
randomly i want three values
and i can just give this say okay
and then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range
so let's select this and say okay and
that gives me random three values from
this
values of temperature so we can use
excel to do a simple sampling and we can
choose whether we would want to go for
periodic sampling or
random sampling now we have seen
sampling histogram correlation
descriptive stats and now also let's
look at regression now what is
regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between
two or more variables and basically we
would want to look at
two or more variables
and
basically a relationship of those
variables with the response or the
target right so for example if we look
at our data here we have temperature we
have price of ice cream and then we have
units sold and we can
go ahead and make
predictions so for example when you look
at regression here you see something
like this which is regression statistics
you have anova
you have different plots which we have
here which is x variable
x variable 2 and then you have normal
probability plot now we have already
seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are
independent variables which one of these
are dependent variables right so when
you talk about your x
that's your independent variable or we
can say predictor or explanatory so when
you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors
or explanatory variables
these are the factors that
might influence the dependent variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or target
that's the main factor you're trying to
understand or predict
so we can plot a scatter plot to see
relationship between variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on we can also
get values such as r square which is
coefficient of determination
regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so
here is one of the links of one of my
edits other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold
and then get these plots so what we can
do is for example i can get rid of this
and might be i can just say
no borders
and
when it comes to these plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal
using your data analysis
add-in tool
so we have been given variables here now
as i said when we talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have
multiple variables right so you might
have heard of univariate analysis
bivariate analysis and so on well
here we are focusing more on using excel
to do our regression analysis so i will
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things
as basics should be known that when we
talk about regression analysis
what does it do it helps you understand
how the dependent variable changes
when one or more independent variables
vary
and it basically allows us to
mathematically determine
which of those variables really has an
impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so
mainly the goal of the model is to get
the smallest possible sum of squares and
draw a line that comes closest to the
data so that's what we mean by our
regression line or basically looking at
the points and seeing if the points fall
on a regression line
if there are residuals that is points
which do not fall on the regression line
and in terms of statistics
when we talk about
statistics
we differentiate between a simple and
multiple linear regression so you have
something called a simple linear
regression
models
which basically gives you the
relationship between dependent variable
and one independent variable using a
linear function and if you use two or
more variables that is explanatory
variables to predict the dependent
variable we are actually dealing with
multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function
because the data relationships do not
follow a straight line
we have to use non-linear regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this
might be based on temperature price of
ice cream we would want to find out how
many units were sold now what we can do
is we can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert
you can then choose the kind of plots
which you want and here you have
insert scatter plot so we can choose
this and you can choose the first option
so that gives you a blank layout and
what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want x values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about y
that's your dependent variable or your
response or target so that is in our
case units sold and x values are one
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here i can click on this
series x values and then i can
select this
now in y values what i can do is i can
select these
and then i can just say okay
so that shows me that it would be giving
me a
regression scatter plot
now let's say okay
and we have some points plotted here now
if you would want to see the impact of
one individual variable such as
temperature or price of ice cream you
could as well do that now what you can
also do is you can add more meaning to
this
by giving in a title or you can also go
into quick layout and you have various
options here so you see it gives you
what is the access title what is the
series and i would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your r square and that gives you
your y and x that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change
the chart title to something else a
scatter plot
of
dependent
uh wes independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning
and
we can get rid of this one so we have
series and we can say
what are these points if you would want
to add in legend if you would want to do
that or i can just get rid of this
and
i will keep these values here which we
will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always
compare these values so here i have
created a simple scatter plot
and then i can look at dependent wise
independent variables
or i could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis
so basically you can here
say for example just say y
and might be here i will say
x and we can rename that later
now
how do we perform data analysis or get
into regression
right now what we would want to do is
we would want to get
or we would want to do the regression
analysis to demonstrate the relationship
between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically y
when you say y
equals
you can say
plus a
plus c
and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression when
x
is your independent variable y
is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected
mean value of y
when all x variables are equal to zero
so basically on a regression graph
that's the point where line crosses the
y axis and that's your intercept
when you talk about b that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as x changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically
the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise
right now what we can do is we can also
reduce this
equation to
y is b x
plus a
and that's the equation of a line we can
look into this and the linear equation
can be understood mathematically in this
way now how do we do it in excel so
what we can simply do is
here let me
[Music]
yeah
so
we need to get into data and then here
we have our data analysis add in you can
click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as i
said you will have to select the
dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your x and y
so y being your target
that's basically your units sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to x either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so i
will select temperature price of ice
cream
and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels
right
now we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that
so you can say whether you want it in a
new worksheet or you can just say output
range and i will probably
just click here and select one of the
cell here
now we can also choose the other options
which we would want to see as a part of
this regression analysis
so basically we have selected input y
range which is your dependent variable
you have selected x range which is your
independent variable and if we are
building a multi-regression model then
we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals
so that basically gives you
your residuals now we can also get your
line fit plots which you were seeing
earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots and then basically
just say okay
and
let's say okay
and that basically gives you
your regression analysis output
so we
basically have your summary output
we also have anova
we have our serial output that's from
the previous one
and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
i can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these
so we have our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this
and then what we can do is
since we had some existing data it has
overwritten so let me get rid of this
and i'll repeat this step again
and
let's say water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis
so we go get into data we get into data
analysis we choose regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c
x range is multiple variables we have
gone for labels
output range which we would want to
select a particular cell
so let me select this
i am going for residuals line fit plots
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot now to interpret this
or to understand what we have here where
we look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at
multiple r value here
and we can
let's also fine tune this one yeah
we have our values here and if you see
we have our r square now we can then
basically look at
our multiple r so what is your multiple
r that's your correlation coefficient
which basically measures the strength of
linear relationship
between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient
it can be any value between -1 and 1 and
its absolute value indicates the
relationship strength
so
the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and 0 means no relationship
at all
now when you are looking at r square
that is the coefficient of determination
which is used as an indicator of the
goodness of the fit
so it basically shows how many points
fall on the regression line so your r
square value is basically calculated
from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now
when we talk about
looking at the value of your r square
so it is basically we can be
seeing
that this is
0.450788
that's the value which i'm talking about
so it basically means 45 of our values
fit the regression analysis model
so in other words
45
of dependent variables that is your y
values are explained by the independent
variables that is your x values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit
and here we have considered multiple
variables
now when you talk about your adjusted r
square it is the r square adjusted for
the number of independent variables in
the model
so
you would want to use this value instead
of r square for
multiple regression analysis
such as in our case
now you also have standard error so
that's basically
goodness of fit measure that basically
shows the precision of your regression
analysis so the smaller the value the
more certain you can be about your
regression equation
so
when when we talk about your r square
that represents the percentage of
dependent variables variance that is
explained by the model and standard
error is basically an absolute measure
that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into
regression statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that
then you already know what i'm talking
about we are just seeing how excel
easily helps us in doing these things
now
we can also look at observations here
which is basically the number of
observations in our model which is seven
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your anova values here
so we basically see df you have ss
ms f and significance f
now to understand these
so basically what we are doing is or
what excel is doing is it splits the sum
of squares into individual components
that give information about the levels
of variability within your regression
model so when you talk about your df
that's basically the number of degrees
of freedom associated with the source of
variance you have sum of squares that is
your ss
so smaller the residual ss compared with
the total ss
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about ms that's
your mean square you have f is basically
the f statistic
or you can say
f test for the null hypothesis
basically it is used to
test the overall significance of the
model and then you finally have your
significance f
which is the p value of f so
when we when we usually talk about
seeing simple linear regression the in
anova part is
not
really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance f value that gives an idea
of how reliably
or statistically significant our results
are so if significance f is less than
0.05
that's five percent our model is okay if
it is greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept temperature price
of ice cream so we know we are looking
at our variables and then we are also
looking looking at our
intercept which basically gives you
more details on your coefficients
so the the main
important thing when we talk about
regression analysis
is basically your coefficients it
basically enables you to build a linear
regression equation
uh in the form of y equals bx plus a
which i explained earlier
and then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals
so we can compare the estimated and
actual number of sold umbrellas based on
the observation
so we have 11.209
here and if you compare that's basically
12
the second one is 15 and here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these
and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right
so
obviously there will be or there would
be some difference because independent
variables are never
perfect predictors of your dependent
variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values
so that's what we see here in the
residual section
so for example when we look at this one
which is 11.209
and the actual is 12 we see what is the
residual and how far
is the predicted value from the actual
value
so
similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables
we are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically
uh add in more details to this
particular plot and you also have normal
probability plot which is basically
getting
your values from your probability output
here so this is how you can perform a
simple regression analysis and now what
you can do is you can as i said
you can basically be looking at your
scatter plot you can be looking at your
y and x and your r square values right
but remember what are the variables
which you are selecting
and then you can compare these with
basically the values what you see here
so remember here i've chosen
my both set of variables
and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so
it's pretty simple here you can
add more details to your scatter plot or
the plots what we have created
or
some people prefer to do it using
formulas
so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as
you have
linus you have slope you have intercept
you have correlation and so on so
basically
you can use these particular functions
and what you will have to do is
you will have to
basically go in for a function if that's
what you would want to do and then you
can search for functions
and say for example i'll just say nest
and say go and here i have my function
so if i would want to really use this
one i can do that what i will have to do
is then select the variable so if you
just say okay and that basically says
your known y's known x your constants
your stats and basically you can use the
formula also but we are not covering
that here might be in the later videos
we can do that so just try out and
perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of performing regression
analysis
using your data analysis add-in in excel
well hello everyone this is ifan syed
from team simply learn in this tutorial
we will be talking about macros used in
excel and also the visual basic
application programming for macros
so what is excel macro you do certain
daily tasks and daily reports or monthly
reports that you generate and you use
data from your excel and you scrub data
and
you basically have the same things
performed or done on the excel sheets
every time and every
day or monthly or bi-weekly or any
number of times that you open your excel
you
remove certain columns you add certain
things and you
change certain values and
these are the things that you do
an
n number of times on an excel
and this can all be done
by simple automated
wave which is macros so what it
does is it is a set of tasks that you
can execute as many number of times as
you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it and
extract certain data and remove certain
columns
that you do every time that you open
that sheet for instance you remove that
column i which has the obsolete values
offer of your accounts or the sheets
that you have and you remove that column
and you edit some names you add such
things every time that you open that
report and then you format it in a
proper way and send it to your
management so this can all be done
in a simple
running script called macros so what you
do is you record those
mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically
a set of code or a task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
a number of times
so
it makes your life easy
now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your excel
it's a simple uh tab that you need to
add
in the ribbon section which i'll be
showing you across
and this will enable the macros on your
excel so you go to
files good options
and then you need to customize ribbon
click customize ribbon
and then there is a developer tab which
you see here it should be activated so
you just need to select that
click on the
tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it over
on your excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon
customize ribbon and you can
add or remove
your macros from here so this is two
ways that you need to that you can
activate your macros so how you record a
macro is the next thing
so here i have a work orders sheet that
i receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do
and
you know this report has so many things
that are obsolete which you do not need
which has to be put across to your
management or your
for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start recording a macro as soon
as you click on this record macro button
it will start
recording your keystrokes on the mouse
mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do
so
this is the sheet that i have
and
we'll try to run macros on this and see
what it does
so here i have and
this actually works this way uh i need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro
so when i click a record macro it
starts uh recording my
mouse clicks and keystrokes so in this
sheet i have to
you know remove some columns and
the columns that are obsolete and the
data that looks
weird here should be removed and all
what i need is the work order number the
district and the tactician name and the
kind of service that we provide and
the
requested workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what i want
and i do it every day when i receive the
sheet and i have to
make these changes and
send it across to the accounts team
so what i do is i simply
automate this by running a macro
so
i go to
let's see how it records the macro
i click record macro i save it as work
order
accounts
and i'll add a little description like
[Music]
work order
for
account
cost
click ok
in
see what i do is basically i
add the borders first
so that the data looks proper
and then i do not want this column i
delete it i do not want the number of
technicians that are there
i do not want all these and i also want
the labor hours the account and what
kind of payment this is very crucial for
the fm scheme i do not want any of these
obsolete data
so i just delete this
okay
and then
i just want to have some cosmetic
changes done so
i make sure this
doesn't have any border
and
that's it this is the task that i
perform
every day i still don't need this
and i go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now i have the macro
save and when i have it i have
you know automated these all these steps
in one simple click
and how i execute it in another sheet so
i will show it across to you
the next thing so here i have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and send it across so i simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab
and
go to the macro and i have this macro
save which we ran the just now and i
simple with a single click i will be
able to do these daily tasks
and execute in a flash so i just click
run and it does the rest for me i have
my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running
a simple macro continuing our
work on macro we can simply do this by a
single click of a button
by adding a button so
what you have to do is go to the
developer tab and in the control section
you will see the insert option
when you click on the insert drop down
you will see a form controls and you can
say select a button
and here i select a button
and the mouse
changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro
and when i just
assign that macro to this button i can
edit the text by
making it as
work order
accounts just to make it simple
okay
and now if you see if i just click this
button it will run the macro
and format our sheet
so this is how we run the macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your mac
so when i click view macros it will show
you what are the macros that i have and
that i can run
and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab
if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to
edit the macro how do you edit your
macro you have
to use a simple application in excel
which is bba visual basic application to
edit your macro you go to the developer
tab
and then click on visual basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on
and you can edit the
macro here
so as we see
if you go back to the excel
we see that
our sheet we have been working on
the sheet and it has the column still k
and the actual sheet is this
so if i go to the visual basic editor
and
i'll make sure they know i remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m
and i just delete that
and i click
run
i go back to my sheet
and you see
these changes are not there
okay
this is your old
macro and this is our new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority
of my orders
so these are the things that we can edit
with the vba
in this tutorial we will be talking
about the visual basic application
programming for macros so here we are
what is vba visual basic application it
is basically a visual basic application
language uh that is used for macros in
excel so what it basically does visual
basic for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate task by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks
by running a simple macro
now to help us
you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our
abilities to
ease our work and automate our task we
use vba
so
why vba there are many advantages of
using vba and why we prefer vba in
macros for excel
so
basically it is a very simple language
it saves time in pro performing tedious
tasks you have number of tasks that you
do every day as we have seen in the
previous section
how we uh you can simplify your daily
task by just running a simple macro and
this vba helps us in performing those
steps
in a very simple manner
another thing is it supports
english like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic english language
statements
and this can help us or it is very easy
to program or
code or edit these commands you can
select a range you can it is like a
if an else statement
and things like that we will look into
those in details in the next sections
now one more thing is it improves the
functionality of excel by allowing you
to make excel behave the way you want
there are multiple functions that you
perform in excel like selecting a number
of rows or columns or selecting a set of
cells
in particular you do it on a daily basis
so these things can easily be performed
and easily be edited and executed by
using vba
we will look into those in detail now
what is the vba editor interface this is
particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail bar section of the vba editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important uh menu
bar option
and when you can insert different
modules and buttons and all we look into
those in details run is one more
important thing all these things fall
under menu bar
the next thing is the vba code window
maybe a code window as it says is the
code window where your actual code
resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the codes and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
vba code window
where you
edit your or write your codes
the next thing is the project explorer
project explorer is simply like a
windows explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your
vba
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the
the excel sheets or the worksheets that
you're working on or the modules that
you have saved and so on basically it is
an explorer for your vba like a windows
explorer which is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet 2
and it shows the properties what are the
kind of
[Music]
worksheet that we have the page breaks
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that
the next thing is the immediate window
and the
watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool
or a window wherein you can run and
execute simple
lines of codes individual excel code
that you can run it will allow you to
test individual lines which is very
useful and handy when you are writing
and debugging codes
the output if the
lines that you execute can be seen here
in the immediate window whereas watch
window watch window is similar to it but
it displays the value of the watched
expression in its current current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the vba code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the use the
advantages of having a watch window in
your
vba interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
visual basic per application
for macros and
uh i'm going to show you how to
you know run some codes and
macros and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the vba for macros
so
there are two ways to
open the visual basic application
and the first thing is you can run alt
f11
click on the sheet and then just press
and it will open the
visual basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the visual basic and it will open the
sheet folder i mean the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project explorer
this is the immediate window
and we can run some
testing course immediately it will show
you the output so here we see the
project explorer window where we see the
modules
for our visual basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see
how the code develops okay so i just go
here and click
record macro
and i save it as
a format
and
columns
okay
just read book and i just save it click
okay
and it has started recording so now what
i'll do is
make it simple and i just delete some
columns here
okay
i do not need this
i delete this derivate i want this i
want the amount of payment
parts cost labor hours i do not want
this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and i go for the left and see what all
do i need i need i don't need this
i delete all these and
i just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then i want to change the format i
mean the hot
so
i select this
[Music]
and i change it to time stream
click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see
the
[Music]
macro here
so we see the macro here and
we can see
in detail what it looks like so
we see the code what it's doing and what
the macro
run has generated the code with so we
see we have basically the name of the
macro is format columns
and what it is doing we're just
selecting the columns and
deleting some we're checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the e
column that we have selected
and then again so on
and
the next thing is the font selection
that is mentioned
we are changing it to times new roman
size is 11 so
it is basically
a basic vba code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or format of the vba code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
vba and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation i have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and
i'll try to explain some basic uh
functions and
the commands and the codes that we use
to
accomplish the
task that we with vba
so as we see this is a blank sheet and i
have selected a new module for it
so here i uh start the code and as it
says it starts with sub and i am
specifying the
module name as
number so i'll just try to make it quite
simple and
you know so we as soon as we enter the
sub it sends with the ends up and so
this is the
start of the code and this is the end of
the code and whatever is there should be
here and this is the name of the
code or the macro now
i'll explain it further about the temp
statement why is it used and what does
it use for
so dim is basically a keyword which is
the
short form of dimension and it is used
to declare variables in the
vba so here i am trying to specify
uh a variable called x and how i'm going
to do it i
will
have it as a number or an integer or
anything so here in this example i'll
put it as an integer or a number okay
and as i put as it populates the prompt
so i select integer
and for example i select the number to
be
500
okay
and here i'm trying to assign a
variable integer
a cell a value of
500 with a
keyword
so where exactly i want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay
range
i am selecting
it should be under course where i'm
going to put the
value of x as and i close the bracket
and
what should be the value
we will
value should be x
so now as i click
run sub
or you can do it with the
by running the alt
f5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the excel sheet
it executes the value
of the cell b5 to be 500 so this is one
simple function that you can do
with the uh dimension keyboard or dim
keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain
more examples some more examples and how
we assign the string value as a as a
text or
something else okay
now i'm going to show you what dim can
be executed
used as set variable string can be used
as
double
when double is basically a longer form
of single variable it usually takes more
space but uses uh needs more larger
numbers okay and then you can set
double and i just don't specify it and
we can use date
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again string so what string
does if you use string it stores the
text it can contain numbers it will have
some text as calculations or anything
can be performed so these are the basic
thing that i will cover
and
you can also use different
values for it so i will discuss this in
the next example
okay
[Music]
so in the next example i'll try to start
or
use a string value for it and
i put it as a string
substring
[Music]
value
[Music]
this is my name
so as soon as i hit enter it ends with
the answer prompt and now i can give my
code
so
i put it a book as
string
okay
now
i'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value
of a country to one of the
cells so
let's see
how it goes and i select country
and in country i select
mark
okay
now what is the value or the cell that
basically takes the or we will put the
name of the country at so i have to
specify a range and as soon as i hit
it goes and i have to specify the
the cell
here so here i put it as g
and uh
okay
so i close it
and i put evaluated what value i am
going to assign it is a
country okay
now
i'll try to run this code by simply
and see
g4
the name
populates as a country here so
this is a dim keyword you being used as
a string in our vba code
so
uh we can also use
vba to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be
executed using uh
the
code here which i'm going to
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
[Music]
i'm going to name it as double value and
again the name keyword i'm going to use
the
keyword as double
okay y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable takes it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now i'm going to pop up a message in
this which says value of a is so and so
so i'm going to give value of a as
250
okay
and how i it pops up a message okay
so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value i mean uh it will
prompt you to enter the value what kind
of uh button you want and
you you can enter the text and you can
enter so here i'm going to
write a code which
you know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is so and so
the value of
a i'm going to put it in percent
code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay
now that's it
and let's try to run this and you will
see a message for popping message box
popping up
okay so the value of
the message box
pops up saying the value of a is 250
so
in the next example i am going to
write a code wherein you know you can
give a value or a string you can assign
it to a selected cell and this basically
used when you have some
you know when you have a
task of you know giving a value to a
particular cell or you have to assign a
text
or say something about a report okay
so
this let's see how it goes and we use
the
i will say
it as
fun with some procedures
[Music]
this is the name and
again
so here i am going to i'm going to give
a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give anywhere i mean
any string or any statement what my user
input will be i will define it here
[Music]
because
this
is the
report
for
vbq
let's make it simple
okay
and where i'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell
that i
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
[Music]
i have defined user input as this is a
report for vba so this cell turns into
you this is a report for vba
i run this
and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and
you know it makes life quite simple when
you use vba
as we have seen before we have used
message box now i'm going to use the
same message box
to
display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes
i'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your
name
and i'm going to put it under course
that my name is
[Music]
and we'll try to
run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name is ref so
this is a message box that you can
display and i can do anything with this
this is
[Music]
okay i run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an excel sheet or try to run a
workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or
you know define a report or kind of uh
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
and now i have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so
here it is
i put this up
okay
number
and
it will again
populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
the entered
[Music]
value
is
and it should tell me
which or i specify
which cell it is
that we are going to find the value of
okay
so i give a range
[Music]
of
i have to leave it in codes
i'm going to
code completed
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
a1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use excel to
determine our show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
i can change it to
a
4
as well
and try to run it
and it will give me the number so
this is simple way of you know
populating a message box which will tell
us the
value of it
let me show you one more simple example
where in a message box pops up or a
welcome message that can be pop set when
you open the
excel or worksheet so
so let's
name it as auto
open
[Music]
and then
again message box i want it to populate
and
what does it say
i put it in quotes welcome
to
our
worksheet
of workshop
[Music]
it's very simple you just run it and
see
it pops up a message saying welcome to a
workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or to simple
welcome message on
excel
next i'm going to show you a code
pairing you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curve
so
we name it as add value
now i specify the range i mean where
i am going to specify a cell
where
the value will be given to the
cell
now i'm going to
give it as v5
okay to put it as codes
close the parenthesis
what is the value that i'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0
okay so now with this code i mean i'm
going to assign a value of 250 to the
cell b5 let's see
run it see
again i do it to b10
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular
cell
now i can run uh the same thing and give
a range of cells i mean
let me make it very simple here
p
i give it as
b one
through
b
five
as
[Music]
four five zero so
let's see what it does
see here i'm going i'm specifying the
range to be
b1 through b5 so it is doing it for the
whole range
okay
and
then i can give a another set of range
here
like
let me specify it
range to be
[Music]
c
one
i have to give it a course
it will give me an error
single colon
c4
and i separate it with a comma and i can
specify another range so the next one
will be d1
to
d4
and then i close the codes close the
parenthesis
what is the value that i give is
let's say
2 3 0.
and i try to run it
so it gives the value
of c1 through c4 and d1 through d4 as
230 as we specified in the
code
so this is one of one more example where
you can assign values to the
uh
so range of cells or cells and with the
vba
one more thing i can uh
you know assign a value to a particular
cell by specifying these cells it's a
very simple
just specify the cells like
six
comma
okay
and
i close the parenthesis
i assign a value to it
value equals
10.
let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
row six
and column sub
okay
so this is one more example when you can
assign values to particular cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario where you need to select a
range of cells in your sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using vba
so i will show you how
this is our
let's say select a
range
okay and
and i am going to set a dim
variable as
example
okay let's say it has example and um
what i'm doing is i'm specific range
because i need to select a range of
cells
okay
now i'm going to set the variable as
set example where i'm going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a
1
to
t
[Music]
5
okay this will be the
selection
and what i'm going to
set the value okay i am going to set a
value
example
i'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here i'm selecting a
set of
cells a range of cells and i'm going to
assign a value
with this function
so this makes it quite simple and this
will be used in a regular daily task
when you know there is there will be a
scenario where you
have to select a set of cells and give a
give a value to it so you can do it with
a click of a button with the vpn
now i can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so
there's
i'll remove this
and instead of assigning a value i'll
just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then you see it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or cells with these
codes
now what if i want to do a selection of
the same
rows and columns in the next sheet
and i can do this with the
setup another set of commands so i will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing
and we specify the worksheets okay
worksheets
i want it in 2 okay so i just put it as
g2 and i activate it basically
activating it and now i am going to
specify the worksheet
2
and what is the range that i'm going to
select the same thing okay
the range will be
a1
to
d5
okay
what i'm going to do i'm going to select
it
okay
and see what happens here
okay okay
so here i am selecting the worksheet too
and i'm activating it and i'm going to
assign range and i'm going to select it
so i can just
copy the same or select the same set of
cells
in the next sheet
okay now when
there will be a as i said there will be
you know by requirement where you need
to copy some cell contents and paste it
to another location so how you do that
it's uh again a simple
code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a
copy
and paste i'm just making it simple
by giving something that we can
understand and relate
[Music]
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select this range
and i'm going to copy it and paste it
somewhere here okay
so let me just remove this
and
i'll show you
first we have to specify the range where
you want to copy
the cells okay so let's say it is again
a one
it should be in codes
five
of course
and i am going to select it okay
then
what i am going to do is
once you select this the selection that
you have
should what should be the function and i
am going to specify the selection
and the function should be copying it
okay so i just
said that
and where i'm going to paste it so i
have to now specify the range
where i have to paste this selection
and you can just mention the
column here let's say
g
10
okay
and close it
i'm going to select it
and then where i'm going to paste it i
can do it in this sheet okay
active sheet
and
paste it
so we are selecting a range of cells
selection
and that selection what we are doing is
we will copy it
and now we are going to specify the
range where you are going to
select it and then
paste it quite simple
let's see
okay
see
and
[Music]
you can just change it so it is visible
on this
g5
okay
so
this makes uh quite easy
and you can run it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to
get the count of the number of cells
like you have to have a selection and
you need to count the number of cells so
this can also be done and it's quite
easy
i am going to show it to you
let's say those are the
account
cells
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you're using it and
i'm going to set a
variable let's say
i'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to
that we need to count basically
so i'm going to set a variable as a
range and
then
what we're going to do is
and we would specify the range here
you can specify the range or your
selection where you count the where you
need the count of the number of cells
so even
[Music]
now how you want the output you want it
you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give you will give you
the count of the
variable that is the variable is here is
examples okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this
area
okay now
let's see it says
okay here i think i'm listed so i just
specify the number here
and let's see so it gives you the number
of
count in this 20 okay
now let's see i want to
[Music]
six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and then you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well i can further tweak this and to
determine the
or to count the number of rows or
columns so it's again very simple i just
need to do some changes here i have to
set the
column count
so if i want to
calculate the number of columns
just
[Music]
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message
the number of columns here
see
it gives there are five columns okay one
two
one two three four five okay
so it gives us the number of columns
here
if i change it to
it should give me
four
polynomial
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
just change it to rows
see
it says six rows are there
okay
should give me number
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of
count the number of
cells number of columns number of rows
with this
the next thing i'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the
most widely used statement and one
whoever is in programming i'm very much
familiar with this function so what it
does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the output output
should be such and such we can specify
the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there
and if it is
uh
space i mean if it is
achieved then you will have to specify
the output as well so this can be
achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understand the basic uh english
language so it's not very complicated
and i'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition
and if that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result
okay
so this is one thing and then you can
specify the
else or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
too
then
the result should be
this
so here you are going to
specify two conditions or multiple
conditions where
you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be
something else let's take an example
wherein you have to you have some scores
or marks
and you have to
select the result you can't do this
manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
i have it here
okay
let's show that
and
i specify as
a
statement
okay now i have to specify the
variables now i have two variables i
have a score and i have a
result and the score is an integer the
number and the result is a string path
of a so i specify this okay dim
score
i specify it as integer okay
and then
there's another variable that i have to
set the result
as
string
okay
now what the score will be the score i
have to specify the range
score i'm giving it as a range i mean
[Music]
it's in my
cell a1
okay
i specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
sorry
should be a dot
okay
and then i'm specifying a condition here
if
score
value the variable
is greater than or equal so as i said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
english
language functions
then
the
result result is another variable that i
have said result what it should be it
should be
in quotes
pass
okay
so
if this condition is met then the result
will be this okay
and now where i want to specify my
result i should give a range for that as
well so i give it in the next column or
any one
this is the basic uh
example
value should be
the result
okay let's see how it drops
see
says pass
change to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because i
have specified only one condition here
okay
change of 75 let's see how trunks
see
so this way it's very basic condition
that you are specifying you are
specifying two variables the score and
the result
and then you are giving a value for it
and your specifying the condition if the
score is greater than then the result
should be passed
now in the next uh section uh
we will simply tweak this and use an if
then else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition
and see so here again we'll use two
variables that is the score as integer
and the result as a string and let's uh
stick to the same values
now
i'm going to specify it and if the score
is greater than 60
then
the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before
and then
i'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
should be
okay
and now
i have to put it to the end if statement
i have to
specify the nsu and the result will be
again in the value i mean the range will
be v1 so
let's see if it is more than 60 then it
is passed otherwise it is fake
okay this pass let's see
40.
okay so we are specifying two variables
again we are giving at a range and we
are specifying one condition if this
condition is met the result is passed
otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
uh the next statement that we use uh or
we are going to discuss is the
loop statement that is the for loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations and
tasks that you need to execute and
you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first statement or the function
is executed and the next
is taken up so
and then the next and so on so
these loop statements allow us to
execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first
task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example
of the for loop statement
so let's see how it
works
and i'm going to set up a
[Music]
loop statement okay again the i'm going
to make it as loop one
so here it is i have to specify the
variable that is dim
and i'm going to specify x as an integer
okay i'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it exits
okay for x equals to one two
by four okay let's see
and
i'm going to specify the range
range as
so what i'm going to do is basically i'm
going to fill the
column a
from 1 to 24 with some value 1 from 1 to
24 with the values of 1
through 24 okay
so i'm setting up a range
and
how it ends is
it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
one i'll explain you how so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up our
integer variable x as integer and we are
setting the value of x to be 1 to 24 so
here for 1 it executes the first thing
is it it takes x as 1
and it fills in
a1
and then
the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to a2 and fills the value as
2. so just let's try to execute this and
you will see
the
row column a filled with 1 through 24
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as x
and the number of values is going to be
24
okay so this is one basic example of a
for loop statement
uh now let's do some more uh addition to
this uh
example by
you know executing another set of for
loop
and giving the output and we'll code the
output to be the color code advance in
the column b so how we do it it's a
basic simple example that i'm going to
take and again
what i'm going to do is i will have this
values here and i'm going to color code
the
b column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
in
what i'm going to do is i'm only going
to change the
b
and what action is going here we put up
a value now we're going to
select it
and with this selection
what i'm going to do is it should select
it
and
it should color the interior with what
is the color index
okay
and the value of x
and then i'm going to specify the
pattern what
pattern it will take for the
box to be colored and i'm going to put
it as a solid
it will kill the whole thing with the
solid
and then i just execute it see
it takes this
column b
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for loop statements
so there are numerous examples and
exercises that we can perform tasks we
can perform with the vba
and this can be found in detail
in our next courses advanced courses in
this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email ids
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding
let's jump into our demo
for creating our dashboards we'll be
using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random it was not validated though we
have applied certain transformations to
the data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly
if i go on top you can see
this data set has
17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have middle east and
north africa there's north america
asia
sub-saharan africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
etc
then we have the representatives name or
you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product then we have a
sales channel column so there are
basically two channels
whether the item was sold offline or
online
next we have the order priority column
now here c stands for critical then we
have h which is for high priority orders
then we have m for medium priority
orders and finally we have l which is
for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order id the ship date
next we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which
each product was sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally
we have created two more columns that is
order year and then we have
order month now these two columns were
actually generated using the power query
features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for revenue by order
year revenue by year and region revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate pivot tables and
po charts and format them to make them
look more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
i'll click on a cell in my data set and
then i'll go to the insert tab
here we have the option to select the
pivot table
i click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next i want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on ok
there you go
so we have a new sheet where i can place
my pivot table
so first
i need to find the total revenue
generated by each year
so what i'll do is
i'll drag my order year column
under rows
and then
i'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see i have my pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order year from 2010
to 2017
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so i'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts i
click on this
now actually i want a line chart so i'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go
so we have successfully created our
first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first
let me delete
these so i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the
buttons present on the chart
now
let me go ahead and
edit the chart title
so the title i want is total revenue
i'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if i click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines legend and others
okay
so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we'll label our x
axis and y axis
so here under x axis
i can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis i'll put
revenue
okay now you can move
a bit
all right
now
let me select this chart style option
and go to colors first
here
i'll select
yellow color
okay
and then let go back to style
let's select a new style from this
i want
this style
okay
now
you can also add
data labels so i'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if i click on this arrow
here i have more options
if i scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
i'll expand this
and under category i'll select custom
now here
we'll give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so i'll write if
my revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
99 000
let me make sure there are six
nines here so one two three four five
and six okay we are good to go
i'll close the bracket
i'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than
9 lakhs 99 000
i'll put it in the format of millions so
within double quotes i'll write m
i'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be
0 million let me click on add
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data
and you see here we have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and
adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up
i'll delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010
the total revenue generated was nearly
175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011
then the revenue constantly grew from
2011 till 2014
it reached 195 million
and after 2014
it again came down to
180 million
and the revenue dropped significantly
between 2016 and 2017.
in 2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet
so i'll write it as
revenue
by
year
alright
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
i'll click on any cell
go to insert and select pivot table
i'll just click ok so that my pivot
table is placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue
by each year and region
so first of all
let's drag
region to
columns then
let's drag the order year column under
rows
and then
i'll select total revenue on to values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly
if you see for 2013
this was the total revenue generated in
europe
and
we have four other years as well
now let's
create a line chart based on this pivot
table so i'll select any cell in the
pivot table i'll go to insert
and i'll click on recommended charts
from this list i'll select my line chart
and click on ok
there you go
so we have our next
pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the
sub-saharan african region
in 2012
sub-saharan africa made the
highest amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for north america has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see for
europe
this was the revenue trend between 2010
and 2017.
so if you see here in 2011 the sales
where at this level then it
significantly dropped in 2012
then in 2013
there was a huge spike and then and
again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these
line charts
now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the
field buttons present on the chart
and we'll also
delete the legend
all right now
let me just reduce the size of the chart
next
we'll
add a chart title
so
we'll
give the title as
revenue
by
year-end
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of millions
so i'll right click on this axis
and i'll select format axis
i'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category i'll select custom
and
we'll use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can
reduce the font size or increase the
font size let me just show you suppose
you want to increase the font size of
the chart title so you just select it
and from here you can either also move
it to left or right or you can place it
in the center as well for the time being
let me just keep it to the left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region
and we'll create a combo chart for this
so let me show you how to do it
i'll go to my data sheet
i have my cell selected
i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table
let me just click on ok
all right
so for this
i'll select
my region onto rows
and then
i'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column
all right so here we have the pivot
table ready now based on this pivot
table
let's create our pivot chart so i'll go
to recommended charts and if you see
below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the
preview preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on ok
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is
the bars represent the total revenue
which is this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next we'll add
data labels so i'll click on data labels
here
okay
so these are the
data labels for
the bars or
the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so i'll click on this arrow go
to more options i scroll down
i have number
from here i'll select custom and
i'll choose my type that is
in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our
data
next thing we'll add
a chart title
so here i'll write as
revenue
by
region
it's actually
revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well i'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet3 also i am going to rename it as
revenue
by
year
and region
so this
makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next
we are interested to get the revenue
generated by order priority
and for this we are going to create a
pie chart
so let's go to the data sheet
and create our pivot table first
i click on ok
now i'll select order priority under
rows
and under values i'll select
total revenue
so this is a
very simple pivot table so you have your
order priority so c is for critical h is
for high l is for low and m is for
medium
now based on this
let's create a pie chart
so i'll go to recommended charts and
here you have
pie chart
i want to select
this 3d type of pie chart
and i'll click on ok
all right so we have our pie chart ready
let me just resize it
and from here i'll remove the field
buttons
and i also don't need the legend so i'll
delete this as well
all right
now let's give a chat title so this is
going to be
revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
i'll
check this option
okay
now let's again format this in terms of
millions
so here
i'll click on the last option i'll go to
numbers
under category i'll select custom
and
my type is going to be in terms of
millions there you go
let me close this
i will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue
by i'll just put op which stands for
order priority
all right
now
let's create our horizontal bar chart
i'll go to insert
click on pivot table
and select ok
so i want my revenue based on different
countries so i'll select country
and put it under rows
and then
i'll choose total revenue and place it
under values
so here you have the different country
names we have afghanistan this albania
let me scroll down you have bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have czech
republic there's estonia france gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have india there's jamaica italy
and all the way to the bottom if we go
we have new zealand there's netherlands
philippines portugal
we also have
singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the uae united states of america
zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
so based on this pivot table let's
create our pivot chart
so i'll go to insert and select
recommended charts
from here
i'm going to select the column chart you
can see the preview here and let me
click on ok all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and
the revenue for each of the countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart
so first of all i'll delete
the field buttons okay
and let me also remove the legend
here i'll write
revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so i'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
i'll select
style 6
okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and rename this sheet so
i'll write
revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally
we'll create another report which is
going to be part of our revenue
dashboard and this is
revenue by items so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have
cosmetics vegetables cereal fruits
there's cloths snacks households and
other products as well
so let's check the revenue for each of
these items
so we'll continue the same drill i'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time i'm going to drag
item type under rows
and
we'll have the total revenue under
values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this total revenue
from largest to smallest so
you can see here office supplies made
the highest amount of revenue
followed by household then cosmetics
and fruits
made the lowest amount of revenue
i'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts
this time i'm going to create a bar
chart so this is how my bar chart is
going to look like
i'll select ok
all right
now let's format this chart a bit
i'll delete the field buttons
and i'll delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to
change the
color of the bars so i've selected all
the bars i'll go to my home tab
and here let's say i want to select
green color
all right
i've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
14
and i'll remove the
bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have
created to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
i'll create a new sheet
and first thing i'm going to do is
i'll click on the view tab and
uncheck grid lines so this will remove
the gridlines present in the worksheet
next
i am going to insert an image
so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is i'll go to the
insert tab and under illustrations
i have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so i'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
i'll go to desktop and here i have a
folder called
excel dashboard files
and i'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so i'll hit shift and i'll drag it
all right
so you can see i have successfully
added a background image if you want you
can still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so i'll click
on insert and here
i have the option to select
a text box
so
i'll click on a text box and
i'm going to place a text box in the
middle
and i'm going to name this text box as
excel
revenue dashboard
on
sales
i'll
centralize it
let's do some more formatting so i'll
select this text box on the top you can
see
shape format
here
i'm going to expand this
shape fill
and i'll select no fill
so
my text box is transparent now and i'll
also remove
the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and i'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to
britannica bold
and i'll increase the size to let's say
30
all right i'll just
drag the
text box
i'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so i'll go to
insert and i'll click on illustrations
again
and select
pictures
i am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing
so i'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and i'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so i'll hit
ctrl v to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see i have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts our
column charts the combo charts this pie
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and
format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered
so let's adjust the
labels let me bring this
down
similarly i'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right
this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the
white background from each of the charts
and make it transparent so let me show
you how to do it so i'll select this
chart
then i'll right click
and go to
format chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called no fill so if i select no
fill you can see the white background is
gone now
similarly let me also remove the grid
lines so i'll select the gridlines and
hit delete so you've also removed the
grid lines from here
now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so i'll select this chart
go to format
and here
i'll go to shape outline and i'll select
no outline
you see this
so we have our total revenue by year
which is a line chart and this is
completely transparent now now what i'm
going to do is
i'll place this chart over a box
so i'll go to insert and in insert we
have the option to create a shape
so i'll click on illustrations and here
i'll choose a shape
and let me select a rectangle
so i'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now what i'll do is
i'll select this and bring this to front
i'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and i'll place this
shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first i'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and
and let me increase the transparency so
i'll
right click and go to format shape
here i'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say
20
all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better
now we'll just
adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so i'll go to shape
outline and i'll select no outline
you see
we have now formatted our chart
let's just
pull this a little up
all right
now we'll add
this blue background to all the other
charts so we'll first add the background
make it transparent and then we'll
convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible
so
for the time being i'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard
so
i've added a few logos for
each of the
charts you can see the logos here so for
revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the
labels in terms of millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by revenue in terms of
millions
so the way to do is you can select this
graph
right click and go to format access
here if i scroll down
you have numbers
and
under category i'll select custom
then i'll select my type as
this format
which is in millions
and
you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to our
dashboard
now slicers are used to format your data
based on a particular column suppose if
you want to see revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add
date columns so if you want to see what
was the amount of sales or revenue
generated on a particular year or a
particular month you can do that using a
timeline
so
i'll select one of the charts
and then
either you can go to the insert tab and
here you can see under filters we have
slices and timeline or
if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option
so i'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
fields present in the
data set
so i'll select
country
region and let's say
we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers i'll click on ok
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have asia
this europe north america and others
similarly we have the different country
names for country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slices to a dashboard so what
i'll do is
i'll right click
on this option
and i'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables
so let me check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on ok
alright
now that we have connected
one of our slicers we'll now connect the
other
remaining slicers
so i'll right click on this go to report
connections
and i'll check all the pivot tables
present in this worksheet
click on ok
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
i'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have
the item type so i'll right click
go to report connections and then i'll
select
all my pivot tables
and let's hit ok
alright now let me just
organize this a bit so i'll
place my pivot tables
to the right
i'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
i'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
i'll add my final slicer that is sales
channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard i'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now i have arranged all my slicers
so let's say you want to find the
revenue that was generated for
an item type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for
beverages item type
if i scroll down
now this chart represents the revenue
that was generated in each of the
countries only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
india
so i have selected india here
and now you can see
my graph has changed only for country
india
you can see here it is showing only for
india now
now similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to
know the revenue generated
based on sales channel so we have two
sales channel that is offline and online
suppose you want to know the revenue
generated offline so i'll just
select offline you can see
the values have changed so these were
the revenues generated for each of the
items only for
this is
our entire
excel revenue dashboard on sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added
different icons then we formatted the
labels also
next we added
slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this
sheet as
revenue dashboard i'll write rev
dashboard
okay
now
we move to our data sheet and
start creating our pivot tables and
pivot charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table
so
i'll create
a new worksheet
this time i am going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so i will drag my
total profit column
to values
and
my order year to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to
get an idea
as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since i've
sorted this data in
descending order so 2014
had the maximum amount of profit
and 2017 had the least amount of profit
i'll just do control z to undo it all
right now based on this pivot table let
me go ahead and create my po chart so
i'll go to recommended charts and click
on a line chart so this is the preview
of the chart
i'll click on ok
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first i'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart
and i'll
rename the chart title as
total
profit
by year
next i'm going to remove the legend so
i'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
i'll go to style
and
this time
i'm going to select
my style type
okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have
this yellow color
next let me add the
data labels
so again if you see here this is not
formatted properly
so let's go ahead and format the
data labels
so i'll click on number
and i'll select custom here
and the type i'm going to select is in
millions
and i'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next
we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this i am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table
so i'll go to insert and i'll click on
pivot table
let me click on ok
since i want the country name so i'll
select country under rows and then i
have
my total profit under values the next
thing i'm going to do is i'll just
rename the row labels as
countries
and then
i'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so i
am going to select this pivot table
go to the design tab
here we have subtotals and grand totals
i'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again i'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right
now
we want to create a
map out of this the way to do is
i'm going to
select my data
copy it
i'll go on top
and i'll paste it here
using this data i can create my field
map now so i'll go to insert
here we have the option to create a
field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
i can expand this
now as you can see
our map has a color scale which comes
from light gray color to dark blue color
so the countries that are in gray or you
can say light blue
have the lowest amount of profit
while the regions or the countries that
have been shaded in
dark color
a dark blue color have highest amount of
profit
i will go ahead and delete this
scale
okay
next
we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
i'll do is
i'll right click on this map and i'll go
to select data
here instead of the previous range i'll
give my
new range now so
my new range
will be my original pivot table that i
had created
i'll go on top and click on ok
so we have our
map ready now
now if you want you can change the
color of the shade so i'll just go to
colors
and let's say we'll keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made least amount
of profit
okay
now moving on
next
we want to create
a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel
so for this we are going to create
another line chart
so i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so i'll select
new worksheet
here
since i want to know the profit by year
first of all i'll drag my order year
column to rows
and then
i'll choose my total profit column under
values
next i'm going to select my sales
channel under columns
there you go so we have our pivot table
here
now based on this pivot table let me
create my pivot chart so i'll go to
recommended charts
and i'm going to create a line chart
i close this
you see here
based on this
chart you can tell
the profit generated with
online
sales were actually
lower than that of offline so here the
blue line represents offline profit and
the orange line represents online profit
if you mark clearly
in year 2012 the online profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so
let me go ahead and
edit this chart a bit so we'll delete
the field buttons i'll also delete the
legend for now
let me go ahead and
add
a chart title so i'll write
profit
by
year
and
sales
channel okay
so this is my
second report
before moving ahead let me just
rename this sheet so i'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say sc for sales channel
okay
moving ahead
now i want to
create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
the profit by sales channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
i'll first
go to insert click on pivot table and
click on ok
so i'll drag my sales channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table
now let's create our pivot chart which
is going to be a pie chart
let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so i'm going to select a donut
chart here i'll click on ok
let's
edit this chart i'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
i'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
i'm going to
format this label
i'll select the category as custom
and my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
i'll write
profit
by
let's say c which stands for sales
channel
cool
finally
i'm going to create a report that will
show the revenue and profit by items
so i'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first this time i'll choose
my
total profit under values
and we'll also have
the revenue column
so i'll put my revenue at the top then
i am going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table
let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the orange line represents
the total profit
i'll click on ok
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title
i'll name it as
revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use
for our profit dashboard
next let's create a new sheet
and we'll get started with building a
dashboard
so i'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so
first of all let's go to
the view tab and remove the grid lines
now
we'll
insert a background image
like we did for our revenue dashboard so
i'll go to insert
under illustrations i'll click on
pictures and select this device
i'm going to have the same background
i'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization
let's just
drag this
a bit to the right
we'll adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see i have brought my
revenue dashboard
and i'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
i'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right
the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
excel
profit dashboard instead of revenue
now
we'll copy each of the charts that we
just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few
now we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
copy this as well
similarly i'll bring the other three
charts on to my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard i have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
i have also
made some formatting for example i have
reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so i'll
select
the first chart i'll right click and
i'll
click on format chart area
here under fill i'll select no fill
next i'm going to remove the grid lines
so i'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so i'll go to design
actually format and i'll remove the
outline
next i'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and i'm
going to paste it here
okay
and let me just select
the chart and i'll bring this to front
and i'll move this
to the back
next i'm going to change the font color
all to white
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
i'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here
i have my first
chart ready
the same i'm going to do for the rest of
the charts
okay so now you can see here
i have formatted all my charts i have
also added a blue background
you see here i have also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit
similarly here i have added the data
labels this is for revenue
some of the charts also have the data
legends so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
i've also formatted the
map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline
first let me show you how to add a
timeline
so i'll
select one of the charts and i'll go to
insert
under insert i have the option to create
a timeline
so i'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so excel has only
shown us two columns so i'm going to
create my timeline based on order date
so i'll select my order date column and
i'll click on ok
you can see here this is called a
timeline i can expand this
now this timeline is based on months now
and if i
scroll this timeline you can see here i
have
my
order year 2010 and i have all the 12
months similarly we have for 2011 then
we have for 2012
all the way till 2017.
now you can filter this in terms of
years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so i have
years from 2010 till 2017.
let me just squeeze this
and i'll place it somewhere here
on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slicers for my profit dashboard so i
have selected one of the charts
under insert i'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which
i want to create slicers
so i'll create a region
let me also select
country
let's say i want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and i'll click on ok so here i have
created three slicers
let me
first
resize it and
i'll place it
on the right
similarly i'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
i'll
resize this and i'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
i have to
connect all the slicers and the timeline
to
the pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so i'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here
i am going to select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here i have selected four and i need
one more which is
pivot table number 10 right click on ok
similarly let's create
or connect my region filter to all the
pivot tables so i right click
go to report connections
here i'll choose all my pivot tables
which are based on profit
i'll click on ok
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on ok
and similarly i'll connect my
timeline as well i'll go to report
connections
and i'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then i'll click on ok
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so i am
selecting one of the pivot charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
and i'll select
sales channel and hit ok
so i have my sales channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
are based on profit
click on ok
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing i want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 to 2017.
now suppose
we want to know the profit that was
generated in the year 2012. so i'll just
click on
this range and now you can see our
charts only so information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was
51 million profit in the year 2012.
similarly you can see here
the profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
2012.
if i scroll down you can see
the revenue and profit by items
now
if i select
another year let's say 2013
i can just drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the
map or the line chart for total profit
by year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it
went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
excel has prompted
all right so this is how you can use a
timeline
now as i said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
i'll
send it back to the place where it was
and i'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose
you want to check the profit made by
different representatives you can select
them one by one
let's say adam churchill
this is the
profit generated by
adam churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer
let me just bring this to the middle
and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart i'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly
okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit
in let's say united kingdom you can
select united kingdom so this is the map
of united kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
united kingdom
and
below you can see
the revenue and profit
for all the items that was sold in
united kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item made the highest
amount of profit in
united kingdom
now you can also select
multiple countries let's say
i want to know for france as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now i
have
united kingdom and france selected and
the other charts present
in my dashboard change accordingly
now i have my
country selected as india you can see
the map of india here
and these were the respective profit
values
now one thing to note here is this is
actually
not millions that should be in k that is
thousands so please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually k and not
million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
pivot charts based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing you can also
change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select
another theme let's say face it
you see
the colors have changed and it looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic
you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the
text also change a bit you can see the
slicers are in a different font
let me explore one more theme let's say
this time i am going to choose
depth
and
this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my revenue
dashboard and see how it looks
there you go
so since we changed our theme even our
revenue dashboard is also impacted
so this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and
play with different themes colors fonts
and effects
all right
so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts
and then we learnt how to add slicers
and connected to different pivot tables
and we filtered our data to see
revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales channel
we learned how to create a map
and lots more
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here i'll be discussing some
important questions that you will come
across
when you face interview for excel
and
we will start with the basics the
beginner level
and
most of them will be discussed here will
be the beginner level at the beginning
and then we'll discuss it at the further
left
okay so of the first question that you
might get asked is what is a cell
address in excel
so
a cell address is a combination of
column letter and a row number that
identifies a cell on a worksheet
basically each cell will have an
associated column number
column letter and a row number so you
have to keep in mind it will always be
a column letter and a row number each
excel sheet will have suppose for
instance if you take row 5
rows will be in numbers and the columns
will be in letters column a column b
column c
d and so on
and the numbers will be for the rows so
for instance
if you take this particular
cell the cell address is d5
column d and row five
so this is the cell address now
let's move on to the next one
now you will be asked what is the
relative cell referencing and absolute
cell referencing in
excel
so relative cell referencing is usually
the relative references change when a
formula is copied to another cell
depending on the destinations row and
column
okay
so this is called relative cell
referencing absolute cell referencing
irrespective of the cell you know you
don't have to depend on the value of the
cell destination there is no change when
a formula is copied
so this we i'll explain it in the next
slide
the basic difference is this type of
referencing is there by default in excel
relative cell referencing you just
insert the formula you don't need to put
a download sign in the formula whereas
absolute cell referencing if you don't
want to change in the formula when it's
copied across cell then absolute cell
referencing requires you to add a dollar
sign before and after the column
and
row address so
see for instance
this is relative referencing you know if
you see this this particular cell is
having we put the value as a3 into b3 so
what it will do is it will multiply a3
and b3 and it will give the product this
is relative cell reference whereas
absolute cell referencing is again the
same thing but you have to put a dollar
sign
before the column and the row number so
here you are specifying
this as a3 into
b2 okay
a3 into b2 and it will give you this
particular answer irrespective of that
it will give you it will calculate what
is there in this and it will give you
the answer
okay now you move on to the next point
is basic question when you
scroll across an excel sheet sometimes
you have a header on the first row and
if you scroll down you will not be able
to see the first row so there is a
process uh or the there is a
trick to freeze the paints in the excel
so you just need to
have the rows locked so how do you
freeze paint this is the question so
what you need to do is you need to
select the view tab go to the view tab
and go to freeze panes it's a basic
thing and you will see this if you see
here
select the third row and click freeze
panes so you just select this and click
please page
okay
so you're going here and you're going to
the third row and you are going to view
tab and you are selecting free span so
what happens is first two rows will be
locked
okay
these two rows will be
locked similarly for uh if you want to
freeze the columns okay it's the same
thing i am going to select this
particular column
and then click on view and then click
freeze pane
so what happens is the first two columns
unlock a and b will be locked and if i
scroll right you will always see the
customer name and category column so
these two we have logged and the next
will be scroll so this is the
function of freezing panes okay
now coming on to the next one
and you will be asked
and you have an excel sheet or a
spreadsheet
and you want to restrict you want to
protect the data
for from anyone or from someone cop from
copying the cell for your worksheet so
how do you do that you need to select
that particular data that you want to
protect
and then click ctrl shift f
and then you will see the
protection tab okay
you just need to go to the protection
tab and select lock
okay and you will be asked to put a
password wherein you will be getting the
review tab where you you need to select
the sheet put a password and just save
it so i will show you across in
one of the examples here so this is
particular uh data that you have and you
need to protect you select it
so here
as i said i selected it and then i just
press ctrl shift f so here you see the
protection click the protection tab and
then click select and then lock
then click ok and then you need to go to
the review tab and then click on the
protect sheet
and you are having the you need to
select this
protect worksheet and contents of locked
cells so you are selecting these and you
are protecting the content and you just
need to
put some password
okay
and then click ok
ok so this is how you protect the data
on a worksheet and you are selecting
this area ctrl shift f
and just put up a password and select
lock sheet so this is how you protect
the sheet from anyone to copy it
now the next question that you might be
asked is what is the difference between
a function and a formula in excel
so
you will be asked this question and you
need to remember this formula is like an
equation which is typed in by the user
you are typing it suppose a
one plus b two you are typing this
formula in one particular cell okay
whereas function functions are
predefined calculations it is like a
formula
which is already there in excel and you
can use it so as it says here it
consumes more time and it has to be
typed in manually you this is as per the
need basis and this is particularly it's
very quick and very efficient you have
inbuilt formulas in excel the sum and
multiplication product and
various other things that you will come
across so this is the basic difference
between a formula and a function in
excel okay
the now the next question that you might
be asked is uh or you need to know
basically is
the order of operations used in excel
while evaluating the formulas so what is
the order you need to remember this
acronym ped mass p e d m a s or in other
simple terms you can use this also
please excuse my dear and sally so these
are the acronyms p
e d
m a s now let's see what happens first
and you uh in math when you do some
calculations you have order of
operations okay board mass is the one of
the order of operations now in excel
similarly in excel when you put up a
formula you excel will calculate it
in a particular order and this is called
the order of operations and the order of
operations is first it will calculate
what is there in the parenthesis it will
perform this function and then it will
see if there are any exponents in it and
if it is there it will do that
calculation the next and after that it
will see if there is any multiplication
or division so p e d and then
it will see
if there is any addition
okay and then the last one will be the
subtraction so excel knows this and you
have to know this so that when you put
up a formula you will know what is going
to happen first and you will not mess up
with your formula okay this is the order
of operations it is one of the important
questions in the interview for a
beginner excel
level now the next one is uh
how will you write the formula for
following multiply
the value in a cell a1 by 10 and add the
result by 5
and divide it by 2. it is quite simple
okay so i'm just giving it an example in
the slide and you might be asked
something else so you will be given a
task to
calculate or put up a formula for this
so when you are asked multiply the
values in a cell by of a 1 by 10 so this
is particularly thing okay a1 is the
particular cell that is being given and
you are multiplying it okay you put it
in parenthesis
and then
add the result by five so it will
calculate the parenthesis first okay and
if it sees if there are any exponents
you have to think in that way if there
are any exponents in it or not and then
first it will see the parenthesis and
then exponent there are no exponents
here and then it will do the
multiplication and then the
addition
and the division okay so you will get
this particular answer and if you put it
simply in this way your answer is wrong
because
it will multiply it into 10 add
5 and divide by 2 so you have to check
which one is right and you have to make
sure that you are putting the right
parenthesis okay
so
this is the formula
okay
the next question is uh
that is different what is the difference
between count counter and count blank
these are three particular important
things that you need to these are
similar but they are quite different
when you actually see it okay so first
we will see what is count count is
basically it counts the number of cells
which have numeric values as the name
suggests it is count it will count the
number of cells which has numeric
volumes okay if you see per this column
and
at a 11 we are putting it as
count equals to a 10 to a 2 to 8 and so
you're taking this range and you're
finding out what are the number of cells
which have numeric value if you see this
one two
three four
five so five cells have numeric values
it counts the
cells which has numeric value and the
next thing is the counter
okay what counter does it counts the
number of cells which has any form of
content it can be anything it can be a
number it can be a
alphabet it can be anything it will see
what are the
number of cells which has any form of
content okay for example this is the
same example we here taken here and we
have put the function as counter a2
now see one two three four five six
seven
so it sees that there is no seven cells
have some content in it it is numbers
and
letters it can be anything but it has
some content so counter is the pension
for this now the next one is count blank
okay as the name suggests it will count
the number of blank cells only
so again the same examples count blank
a2 to a10 okay it will see what are the
number of blanks okay if you see this is
blank and this is black so two
cells are blank so it will count the
number of blank cells only okay
now the next one is uh what is the
shortcut to add a filter to a table
why do we use filter and it is one of
the basics
function in the excel where you need to
do some sorting and it can be done by
using a filter what is the shortcut key
it's very simple control shift and l
this is the key that is used to put up a
filter you just press this
ctrl shift l all together and you will
find the filter and you can
sort it now the next question that you
will come across is
how do you create a hyperlink in excel
so it's quite simple there is a simple
shortcut ctrl
k you press these two together and you
will get the option you will select the
it will select the cell where you have
to insert the hyperlink hyperlink
basically it redirects to
any other document it can be a web page
it can be a word document it can be
another excel sheet or so on okay so
these are the things
okay
now another important question uh that
is
how to merge multiple cells
text strings in a cell so how do we
merge the
text strings in multiple cells into one
cell
there is one particular simple function
that you can use which is called called
as concatenate concatenate function is
used to merge text strings present in
multiple cells okay and it's a very
simple thing you just need to put this
equals to concatenate
and then if you for example this is the
formula concatenate text one text to
text
or this is the concatenate a1 comma b1
comma c1 this is the data in our
three cells excel is fun in a1 b1 and c1
so now if you want to put them all in
one and you can merge it in one cell
using the concatenate function and it's
very simple concatenate
and parenthesis a1 comma p1 comma c1
okay and you will get it all merge in
one particular cell okay
so this is how you use the concatenate
function and you can also use the and
operator to combine cell values it is
the same thing you can use the and
operator instead of commas okay
and i will show it to you in the example
here
okay now we have this i'll just copy
this thing to
okay
and let's make it simple
and now i want to put this here equals
con
concatenate
and a one
comma b one
comma c
i just close it and i put enter so
you see this this all the the different
text is merged in one particular cell
and it will you can perform various
merge functions using the concatenate
function it's a very simple thing and it
is a frequently asked questions in the
interview okay
the next question uh it is very very
important one again
and very basic as well so how can you
split a column into two or more columns
you have some particular text or a
sentence written or data written in your
cell or a column and you want to put
them across in two or more or many
number of columns so how do you perform
this function it's very simple again you
need to select that particular cell so
for instance we have it here is india is
a democratic country india space is
space a space democratic space country
so the it's a different text here and
you want to split this particular
sentence into different columns okay you
need to select that cell and then go to
the data tab and then
choose text to columns there will be an
option and you need to select text to
columns okay and you will see this
screen okay
and you need to select the
choose the delimiter here and what we
are specifying here is uh first it is a
delimited and then we are selecting a
delimiter as space because we see that
it is space here which is very common
and we want to split it so you will see
a preview here which shows what your
output will be like india in one column
is a democratic country so the
denominator is space here
and
t you need to select this and then click
next okay
so you will see the options select the
columns data format and choose the
destination now you see the data view
and you need to select the destination
where you want to put this output as and
you select that and then click finish
and this one what it does it it's it
splits the text into multiple columns
okay so you see this you have selected
this as the output and it starts here
india is a democratic country so
you will come across some data which is
you know huge and there are spaces or
obliques or anything that is
differentiated it with and you need to
put them in different rows or different
columns so this is the
function r that you
need to use to split the text into
different or multiple columns okay
okay the next question can be very
simple one or most widely used in fact
and what is the use of vlookup and how
do we use it
so what is this particular
thing in excel vlookup function is used
for looking up a piece of information in
a table and extracting some
corresponding data or information so you
have some set of values in one
particular column
and
you want to retrieve or extract the data
corresponding to that particular
column or a cell in the whole sheet okay
so the syntax is something like this it
is you need to go to one particular uh
cell where you want the output as and
you type the function
we look up and you are selecting the
value of it is the
cell exactly where you want the output
to be and you are selecting the table
here
and the you are specifying the column
index
and range lookup so value this indicates
the value that you have to look for in
the
first column of a table okay
and then the table table basically this
refers to the table from which you have
to retrieve a value
we will show this in the example in the
next slide
and the column index column index it
provides the column in the table from
which we are
to retrieve a value okay you will
specify the column index which one you
are looking for
the next thing is range lookup which is
optional true with
if you put true it is approximate match
which is default and false if it is
exact match if you're looking for the
exact match so what is the use of
vlookup and how do we do it okay
so find the product related to a
customer name richard okay you have this
sheet and in this one you want to see
what richard has bought okay what is the
product that he has bought and you can
do this with the
vlookup function okay so you just go
here and you type in the function
vlookup you're naming it as richard
and
first thing is the value it is h4 okay
and then the next thing is the table
okay table is a2 because this is the
table okay and you're looking for
customer name richard
okay and then you're selecting this
the whole column index which is e15 that
means you're selecting this whole table
then 15 okay e 15 just selecting this
and then the next thing is optional
which is giving you the uh
range lookup okay what it does is it's
optional it is you're looking for an
exact value or an approximate by default
it is
approximate map so how it performs the
function okay
so it gives you the answer as camera it
goes and look up for
richard in this particular it will give
you the output here and the
a2 is the table that it will look for
the customer name
and it will search for richard
and then it will give you the output as
camera now the next thing will be we
look up different from lookup function
how different they are vlookup lets the
user look for a value in the left most
column of a table so as we've seen in
the example it
allows you to look for a data in the
left most column of the table and
returns the value in a left to right
okay it starts in left to right now
lookup function lets the user look for
data in a row column and it does the
value in the another row or column it
will give you the lookup function in the
next work okay not very easy to use as
compared to the lookup function okay as
we see uh it's a bit complicated when
you compare it to the
lookup function it's quite simple and
it is used to replace the v lookup
function okay
so this is the
different
lookup and vlookup function
now
excel is basically used for reporting
mainly used for reporting to management
you have to extract different kinds of
reports and what are the report formats
that are available in excel this is one
of the uh important questions again
for a beginner level and there are three
formats basically compact form
outline form tabular form okay these are
the three formats uh that are available
report formats that are available
in
excel okay
the next question is about a function
which is how does if function work in
excel okay the f function in excel it
actually performs a logical test
and you will give a condition it
performs the test and returns a value if
the test evaluates to true and another
value which you again will specify if
the test result is false okay for
instance
we have here a simple example which is
shown in the slide
and what we are doing here is written
record is valid if age is greater than
20 we have age here specified
and
salary is greater than 40
000 as return the record is invalid so
we are giving two conditions and it
actually checks and evaluates whether
these conditions are met and it will
give you the output that the record is
valid or invalid based on the two
conditions that are specified okay
and f2 to axis which is this these
column we are specifying it should be
greater than 20 and g2 to g6 which is
the salary column and we are specifying
the condition to be greater than 40 000
so based on this two things it will
check and perform if these conditions
are
met then it will give the desired result
okay so this is the function that is
used
in excel if function okay
the next thing is sum if function
okay again the sum function adds the
cell value specified by a given
condition or a
criteria so you are giving a condition
and you are actually doing another
function which is performing the
addition okay it will add the cell
values based on a condition again it is
shown here the total sum of salary where
salary is greater than 75 000
again for example the salary column is
g2 to g6 and we are doing a sum if
function what the result will be it will
perform the addition
of salaries which are greater than 75
000 so it will see which values are
greater than 75 000 and
then then the output will be it will be
adding these
salaries which are greater than 75
000 okay
now coming to the next
slide we will discuss another important
function counter and we'll find the data
um result based on the data that we have
and the context function so we have a
slide uh their data here and using the
curvy data find the number of days in
which the number of deaths in italy has
been greater than 200 okay it's not
shown here for some reason but i will
show you in the excel sheet okay so this
is the data that we have and we will try
to find the function so we'll use the
countdiff function and counter function
is again simple count if you are
specifying the
column that is the uh source that you
are looking for that is g2 the column g
and it is 2 it starts from 2 pro 2
g 2 till g 3 5 7 which is the end of the
column and what you're looking for is
italy you are specifying it in codes
italy and then the next column that it
will look for is the e column the number
of cases okay here we have the number of
cases e2 again we are specifying the
range and what we're looking for is
number of cases which are more than 20
so we'll perform this function and we'll
show you the
output okay i'll show you to you the
excel
so here is the sheet and i will
try to get the
answer here
and
the
so we are performing count
f okay
count f
and you are giving the
brackets parenthesis g2 which is the
countries column okay countries column
here who are specifying the whole range
three
five triple seven
there is basically uh a long a long list
of uh
data and you're specifying the page and
what you're looking for is particularly
uh any country you can pick up like uh
algeria
okay
algeria
and you specify it in codes okay
comma
then what is the next target that you
are looking for is the column e variable
it is mentioning the number of cases
okay so you specify the
column range for the number of cases
which is again e
and then
uh
the three
five triple seven i mean it's a
basically
long list of data that you're looking
for and then you are what is the
condition that you want to know and you
are have to specify the codes and what
you are looking for is number of cases
which are more than
and you hit enter
okay so it give you the output as 143.
so there are 143 days in which the
number of cases were more than 20. so
let's uh refine our search further let's
see 30
and it gives 140. so
another example that you can take is
let's pick afghanistan
afghanistan and hit so about 19 days
that
you will see the number of cases where
more than 30
and this can be done with the
count if punch
so the next question is uh about
the pivot table
so what is a pivot table
it's basically is a summary of table of
the data set i mean the data that is
there that can be you know multiple
number of rows and columns which has
different
data that has to be that is there in the
reports and you need to analyze those
trends and you need to create a report
and basically present you to the
management or in a presentation
so pivot table is a summary of table you
know whatever data is there you can put
it in a summarized format they are
useful if you have long rows or column
that whole values you need to try okay
so you have long list of data and you
need to summarize it and
put it in a
presentation or a you need to track the
values so
it's very simple you have to select the
data
and then go to the insert tab and select
pivot table
okay
and then it will show up like this and
you need to
select the table which is a
table or range and then you need to
specify where you want to put up this
pivot table okay
and it's quite simple and i can show it
to you in one of the examples okay
so
what you need to do is you need to
select this and once you generate or
as we have seen in the previous slide
you need to select this and you need to
select the output where you want to put
the
pivot table and then once you do that
you will see something like this and you
need to select these particular fields
and
put it in value so it will for example
you need to select the depth number of
depth you can just simply say click this
select this drag and drop it in the
values okay so these are the different
fields that can be put up in the table
okay we can show it to you in the
example here
so this is our data and we need to
show it in a pivot table okay select
this
and then go to the insert tab and click
private table okay
select that
and it will show you the
table or the range and now where you
want to put it okay i will put it in the
existing worksheet okay
and i'll just select which column i'll
put it
here for example and it will show you
this and click ok
so this is the table and now you need to
select the fields that you want to show
in the table for example we need to see
the continents the number of cases as
per the
continents okay i selected and put it in
the row and we see the immediately we
see it in a table
where you see the number of names of the
continents and now i want to see the
number of cases
and
i simply select it
and put it across in the values so this
is quite simple and very informative
very short and crisp
form of presenting the data in
a private table okay
so this is how it is being used and it
is being presented
you just need to go to the insert tab
pivot table and it will generate the
table and then you can select the fields
all right
the next question here is uh how do we
create a drop down list in excel
this is particularly useful when you
need to sort
particular data with the drop down list
where a number of
different variables are there and you
need to select one particular
field and sort the data so you can do
this by creating a drop down list using
the data validation
present in the data tab it's quite
simple you select the data and you go to
the data validation tab in the data and
click select data validation
so once you select that it will ask you
to specify a range so you need to select
what data you need to
sort and put a drop down so you need to
select this and click
data validation and you select the list
option which shows you that there is a
different option okay i'll show it
across in the excel for example what we
have here is uh some particular data and
we have different
variables we need to sort or put a drop
down list so just go to data as in as
said in the slides and go to data
validation
and click data validation now as you
click it it will ask you to data
validation settings okay and in the drop
down go and select list option
so it will ask you to specify the source
so when you asked to specify the source
just click this particular column
and click ok so here dimensioning the
source is
column b okay b
3 t b 14 okay
click ok and then it will give you the
option so here you can uh you can put
this in anywhere across the excel
and click the option okay
so this is the way to drop down using
the data validation option so in the
next example we will see so how do we
apply advanced filters in excel
we use the advanced filter option
present in the data tab so
this is the scenario wherein you have
multiple set of data
and you need to sort it and it's it's
actually huge data
and you need to sort a particular column
or a field
with this criteria
and you can select it and specify the
criteria and specify a range what you
want to
select or based on what criteria the
range can be specified
and you can just get it in a single
click
so
this is the option you have to go to
data tab advanced and you have to apply
the advanced filter and then you need to
specify the list range that is the
basically the source
then the criteria where you specify the
criteria present here i mean you are
specifying in this case we will take an
example where we are trying to sort the
data or the number of cases based on
number of deaths
and in a particular country
and we are specifying the output we the
copy to field is the output where you
will see the output so i'll show it to
you in the excel so here we have a
spreadsheet wherein you will see all the
uh data kobe data that we have and based
on the countries and the continents and
the number of deaths number of cases and
so on okay and it also has different
fields like the date year and month
so so here i am going to sort the data
which is particularly for europe and
which has deaths of more than 200 in a
day so how do we do it go to data
advanced and
the
you need to select copy to another
location okay and this is the list range
so it's basically given in this
countries okay and the criteria range
you have to specify this so i am going
to select this
as my criteria okay
and then
i have to put the output in one
particular cell so i need to select it
again
let's say here
okay
and then i just click ok
see
it's quite simple instead of running
through the whole thing
we can just do it with a simple
function okay
so it shows me the deaths which are more
than 200
and
for which particular country and for
which particular
continents all right so this is
basically
made very simple with this option the
next question is
you know you need to highlight some
particular cells using a particular
criteria in this case we are trying to
analyze or highlight those cells where
the total sales is more than 5 000
so what we do is we use conditional
formatting to highlight the cells based
on the criteria
it's a very useful tool in analyzing
data and
visually it helps you know you can have
a look at the
data in quick flash you will see the
data and it's quite visible using the
conditional formatting so how we do that
is i will show it to you
now
so as said in the slide we have the data
of the sales that is provided to us and
we need to see
who has done more sales which is greater
than the five thousand dollars so just
go to home
and you need to say go to conditional
formatting so for that you need to
highlight or select this go home
conditional formatting highlight
okay and you have different options here
you select greater than
and you specify the value right here my
criteria is 5000
dollars okay we can select which color
so let's go for green
okay
see this you will immediately see
the option you don't have to dig or
looking
deep into the data and find out which
one is more than 5000 or any particular
value
okay so conditional formatting now
moving on to the next question the index
and match function you must be familiar
with the index and match function and
why it is used basically index uh
function is a very powerful tool
wherein you know you
for example you have a table of planets
in our solar system and you want to get
the name of the fourth planet
mars so you can do it with a formula
using the index function and at the same
time
you can use the match function okay with
the match function together you can play
wonders with it okay match function is
another
function that is designed to find the
position of an item in a range for
example we can use the match function
to get the position of a word or uh look
or
in this case we have a name and we can
use the index and match function to
find the city
how we do that is
shown here
okay it it looks quite complicated here
when you see the formula but
i can show it to you in the excel and
explain it further okay
so here i have and i want to know
where these people are and where they
belong to
okay
so
let's see how it goes as we have seen it
and
we use the index function okay
index okay now when i have to specify
the
range okay
so the range is a2 and it shows it
selects the
name and i want to select it from a2 to
a7 okay e7 circuit
e
column e
seven
okay so as you see it highlights the
whole table
okay
now what i'm going to do is i want to
match it okay
match it with a condition i have i am
specifying a condition
a 10 why
because i have to specify a name here
and it will show me the
city where he belongs to okay
where it shows is a
2 okay if you see a 2 it shows the name
through a7 i have to specify the range
here okay not just one name we are
specifying the
whole range as you see if you put the
values it will show you the selection
okay
and what it should be it should be the
exact match so zero denotes the exact
match parenthesis is closed
and i am putting another match condition
okay what is this and this will give me
the output
what output is
okay
b
nine okay this is my
city b9 is the city where i'm trying to
find from okay
and what it should look for is a column
a a one through
e
one okay
it should select these
this particular
row and
what it should be it should be the exact
match again okay let's see how it goes
it will give you an error because you
haven't put the
value here okay so let's see
andrew okay
hit enter and you will see
the city where he belongs to okay
now let's see where anna belongs
enter let's choose dallas okay so this
is the
one other function index and match
function being used and it can be asked
in frequently in the interview questions
okay the next question will be uh how to
find duplicate values in a column
okay there are two ways that you can
actually do this and
one is
basically the very simple one which is
the conditional formatting and the other
one is we have seen this before count if
function okay how we do that you need to
simply select the data
and go to conditional formatting
and
select duplicate values
it's quite simple and there is another
way
which give you the color coded
conditional formatting again there is
another way that is the count if
function how we do that is again the you
have to put another column and put up a
counter criteria content function
wherein you see that you are specifying
the range
and
the
the value which is being twice or enter
duplicate
and you have to put up a condition i
will show it to you in the x
so here we have the data and i need to
find the duplicate values here so i just
select this
and as i said it's quite simple go to
conditional formatting
home and then go to conditional
formatting and select highlight cell
rules and simply go down and select the
duplicate values
okay it will give you what color you
want you can simply select red or
anything as you see the moment you
select you will see the
duplicate values highlighted
okay so i just cancel this and there is
another way
then count a function so i'll put
another column
where it says duplicate names and
i will put up a counter function here
okay
so let's see how a countdown function
works here to check the or find the
duplicate names
so as i said i will put up a formula a
function here for the count if
and we'll drag it to other cells okay
count it and uh
since it's an absolute
reference
i have to put up a dollar symbol
okay my reference here it will be h the
column here h2
okay
and again dollar because i'm using it as
an absolute reference
column
through
dollar symbol again
nine
okay so it drags still at the hole
it drags till the
all the names okay there h9 all right
and then
what i'll do is i'll put a comma
in
why i want to do is i have to
select
h2
okay this is my criteria i mean it is
repeating twice all right
and i have to
close the parenthesis and if it is more
than one okay
so this is my formula i just put enter
and it should say true so this is the
condition
and it is true okay i simply drag it
the whole thing
and whether events is uh repeated yes
it's true
andrew it's a duplicate entry false
me
is a duplicate entry and it says true
and as you see me and events are
duplicate entries so this is how we use
the countless function
and the conditional formatting to sort
duplicate entries in the date
now let's move on to the last question
for the beginner level and since we have
duplicate entry there is also
a problem to remove duplicate entries so
how can you remove duplicate values in a
range of cells okay to simply do that
you can delete the duplicate values in a
column by simply selecting the
highlighted cells and press the delete
button so you go in each column and you
see the duplicate values
select it and delete it okay
and this is one tedious way of doing it
and you can also after deleting the
values you can go to the conditional
formatting choose clear rules to remove
the rules from the sheet so this is one
way okay the next thing is again a
simple button that is there in the
data tab that is the
is one of the tools present in the data
tab which is simply called as remove
duplicates it's quite simple
and it's there in the data tools let me
show you in the excel
so here we are and we have this data and
we need to check and remove the
duplicate so as i said go to the data
tab and simply click on remove
duplicates and when you click on it it
will ask you you want to continue or
expand the selection i just say continue
with the current selection and remove
duplicates okay
select all click ok
to duplicate entries that were removed
previously we saw that events and
and away there any weather so that has
been removed
okay so
that's it for the beginner level and
we'll go to the intermediate level in
the next slides choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we are at the intermediate level
questions and these are like a higher
level or intermediate level
compared to the previous things that we
have discussed with the basic level
questions uh for the excel interview so
let's move on to the next thing
and
so there are there are some scenarios
where you enter the date or
some dates in particular data sheet
and you need to find out
what is the
day of the week okay so you might be
asking your question how do you find out
the day of a week for a particular date
so that is the function we we have a
specific function and that is the
weekday function to find out the day of
the week for a particular date
okay so as we know these are the seven
days of the week and
we just put the
function as it says
equals to weekday and we need to enter
the
column or the
area or the cell
address here so weekday is the function
and it will give you the
which which day it is of the week okay
we go as it says one it denotes sunday
okay
and three is again tuesday okay
so this is the function that is used to
find the day of the week
so now we move on to the next one
and there is a there might be a question
what are the wild cards available in
excel so basically excel sports three
types of wild card which are
asterix the star it represents any
number of characters it can be used in
different formulas and all like
multiplication and all so it represents
any number of characters okay the next
one next wildcard is the question mark
it represents one single character okay
you just need to memorize this in the
back of your mind that it represents one
single character okay whereas asterisk
is
it represents any number of characters
and the third one which is really used
in excel it is the tilde
it is used to identify a wildcard
character that is a tilde asterisk
question marks in the text okay and it
is very rarely used so you need to
memorize these three things that there
are three types of wild cards we can see
the functions of these in the later
sessions okay
the next one is
we have a
question here what is the data
validation illustrate with an example
you might be asked this question and you
have to know what is data validation
what is what is it used for and you you
should know how to set up in an example
okay data validation is a feature in
excel that is used to control what a
user can enter into a cell okay so you
have with the data validation you are
not allowing
a data kind of data that should be input
in the
cell okay for example you
have the authority and by setting up the
data validation that you can enter
either a number or a text or a just
number
and so on okay using the data validation
and where is it available it is in the
data tab okay select data validation
option present under data tools
okay and you just need to select the
particular
cells where you want to set up the data
validation i'll show you to you in an
example so this is how it looks like you
just need to go to data tools and click
on data validation and it will show you
and you have the options here allow and
if you click on the drop down you will
see different options like i will show
it to you in the example here okay
for this particular thing if i want you
know
this column should have only
names and it should have if you insert a
number you will be thrown with an error
okay you will get an error message
saying that this is not a valid option
okay
so
there are some columns where you have to
put only names or you have to put only
number so you can set this up with the
data validation
technique okay you just allow it or
customize it as per your requirement so
this is how it looks like when you set
up an app so here we have set up a data
validation saying that it should not
allow you to put any text okay so you
will get an error when you put a number
here the value does not match data
validation restrictions defined for this
cell
okay
so here as an example i have some data
where i am putting the names here and
i'll put the salary here i want to make
sure that you know we cannot
enter any
numbers here okay it should be only text
it should have only name so how do i
perform that how do i restrict any user
to
that they should not be able to enter
any number and you should only enter the
text okay so there is a function okay
you just need to go to data validation
click data validation
and here in the settings i'll go to
custom there are different options here
you can you can choose whole numbers
decimal list
day time so your these are the options
and i go to custom and i'm giving a
particular formula here okay what is
that it should be only text okay so it's
a simple thing it should be text and i
need to define the range okay so how
i'll define the ring i just select this
okay and
i select the range okay
so i have selected the range here
and if you go to input message
and error alert you can customize it and
here we are taking the default one and
this is the input message if you want to
set or customize something okay so let's
see how it works okay i have said this
and then i try to put a
number here
and it throws me an error the value
entered is not valid because we have set
a restriction a user has restricted
values that can be entered into the cell
so this is how the data validation works
okay the next thing is
you will be given a situation wherein
you have to
you will be given data and you have to
perform a function like
in this example we are taking a
condition wherein you will have data and
you have to specify the result based on
the data you have to
formulate okay so given below is a
student table
write a function to add password fail to
the results
column based on the following criteria
you will be given a criteria so this is
the student table you are giving the
student names marks and attendance and
then based on that
you will have to specify
a
next
formula
where you will see the result okay based
on the past
student data you have to put a pass fail
results in the column based on the
following criteria what is the criteria
and for example
here in this example what they're saying
is
you have to
say this the student is passed if his
marks is more than 60 and the attendance
is more than 75 percent okay so how we
perform this function as it says you
have to use the if function and check
with the and condition to fill the
results column okay
so let's see this in the example here
so here is the example and we will
perform the
if function and check with the and
function so how we do that is here okay
so i have to
put the if function here
okay
and check with the and function okay
and i have to specify the conditions i
have to satisfy where it should see the
or check the
conditions okay so we are checking the
conditions here and the marks should be
in row um in the column u
and it starts with u5 so let's see
u
five okay it will immediately go to
column u and five row five okay
and then what is the condition we are
satisfying here it should be greater
than
60 okay
and the other condition is
uh the column v that is the attendance
column okay and what is the condition we
are specifying v
5 should be greater than
75 okay
and we just close this conditions with
the parenthesis and now we have to
specify the result whether it is pass or
fail
[Music]
pass
comma
in quotes again
wait
okay
so let's see how this works okay
okay see this works okay the marks is 50
and attendance is greater than 80. so he
is
failed because his marks are 50 his
attendance must be more than 75 but yes
he is
he has not scored marks more than 60. so
we drag the same formula to the
whole thing and you will see the result
okay this is quite simple and you will
see this
formula and using the if and
check
and check with and condition okay now
moving on to the next question you might
be asked to
you know this is a simple function
wherein you can you will be asked to
calculate your age in years from the
current date okay so how we do that
there is a particular function and it's
very simple use the year frac or dated
if function to return the number of
whole days between start date and the
end date so you specify a start date
which will be
today's date and the
i mean the birthday
and then the end day will be
today's day for example okay and you
will get to know the age using the year
frac function and dated if function okay
so here is a small example and this is
how we use the
year frac function okay you specify this
function and then specify the input that
is the today's date and the
date of birth and the
today's date okay and this is one of the
ways to get it and there is also dated f
okay
this again it is day-to-day function and
you specify the input cells
okay so let me show you an example for
the same so here we are and
we have today's date that is the fourth
of may
and date of birth for anything it could
be
so i will specify the
year fraction okay
equals
here
rack okay
and then i should as soon as you enter
you specify the start date and the end
date okay
and i will specify the start date as
today's date that picks the column and
then i put the comma
and then the end date should be this
thing okay and just close it and it will
give you the
age
okay so this is the age for example if
you want to find out my age i don't want
to reveal my body but it's okay
okay
let's see if it calculates
i'm 32 years old okay
all right so this is one of the ways and
similarly you can use the dated if
function shown in the example all right
now moving on to the next question
you have nested if statements this is
very important and you will definitely
be
coming across this question how are
nested if statements used in excel what
are nested if statements the f function
can be nested i mean it can be loop when
we have multiple conditions to meet okay
it can be nested the false value is
replaced by another if function okay
you have specified some condition and
you are
putting up a condition and if that
condition is not there or not met then
if it will be replaced with another
if function so
the syntax will be like this below is an
example
so we
actually we use two if statements in
conjunction okay so here is an example
here we are specifying a condition
wherein you know
the result is excellent if it is more
than 80 and if it is less than 16 it is
bad or average so this is very simple
you perform one if condition and if that
is not met
it will go for the next if condition so
we are nesting two if conditions we are
joining two if statements
okay uh i'll show the same example here
in the excel
so here we are we have some data and the
students and their marks okay and we are
specifying a condition wherein
if the
result or marks are more than 80 the
result is excellent and if it is
less than 60 it is bad or average okay
so how we get this is we use two if
conditions if
statements
so
as we have seen it
if
if
now the first condition is
our source or the
source is b
two okay
so b
two
and what i'm specifying is it should be
greater than
eighty
all right i just close this
and the result should be
excellent okay
excellent if it is more than 80 and
if this condition is not met it will go
to the
next
if statement okay we are nesting another
if statement what is the condition here
for the next statement it will check b2
is
less than or equal to
60. you can specify any marks all right
so if it is less than 60 it should give
the result as
bad
or
average okay
specify anything and you
okay
and just close the double parentheses so
let's see how it works okay see
it works like this
now let's pull up the same
formula the for the other results okay
see
if it is more than 90 it is 90 it is
excellent so it is checking the first
thing if it is greater than 80 it is
excellent okay now in this case for mark
it is bad why because it will first see
whether it's excellent or not if it is
not excellent then it is check the other
condition if it is less than 16 it will
give you the
bad result all right
and similarly so on for the
other
marks all right
so this is how we use the
nested if statements
you are adding two if statement the
first condition and the second condition
with another if statement okay
okay when it comes to excel it is
basically involves a lot of data and a
lot of data to be analyzed
and we have some powerful tools which
are used in excel to analyze the data
one such
important tool is descriptive statistics
that is used to analyze the data so
we might come across a question and you
will be given a data or a table and you
need to find the descriptive statistics
of the columns using data analysis tool
okay so you will be given us maybe for
example anything and you will have a lot
of data you have to use the descriptive
statistics
option
in
excel for the data analysis okay how you
do that is you have to add a pack okay
you should be knowing that you need to
add a
pack which is called the analysis tool
pack which you go to
uh file options and then just click on
the add-in and select the analysis tool
pack click
excel add-in and just click go
then it will add the
option
and then when you select the data you
have to go to the click on the data
analysis option which will be
which will show up when you select the
add-in or when you add the
adam okay then you need to select the
descriptive statistics what we need to
do is we need to analyze this data and
it will show you the
values like mean and the
you can also customize you can you see
you have these data and for you to check
each and every row and find the mean the
smallest the
maximum number
and things like that so this can be
easily done using the descriptive
statistics for the data analysis
uh i'll show the same thing in the excel
how it can be performed
so here we are and i'll show you first
how to
add the
option to it okay go to add-in
select analysis tool pack
as shown in the slide and you need to
click go if you just click ok it will
not add so just click go and then you
need to select analysis tool pack okay
it will give you these are the different
options uh
for now we are selecting analysis tool
pack and then click ok as soon as you do
that you will see the data analysis this
option gets enabled
when you add that back so this is the
data that you have you need to find or
analyze using the descriptive statistics
so as you see it
click data analysis and click uh select
descriptive statistics okay and it will
show up the option like this and you
need to select the input range okay for
some reason it's already there and
if you want me to show i will show it to
you across you have to select the whole
data
okay this is my input range and you need
to select this labels in the first row
so that you know it doesn't take the
first row okay i'll show you
okay and now i'm putting the output in
another
worksheet okay you can specify or you
can filter by a new worksheet and these
are the
options that you can select so you can
you are getting a summary statistics
which is the default and you can select
the confidence level that is the mean
value and you can set it up by
whatever value percentage you want and
you are selecting the largest one and
the smallest number so all these data
will get analyzed and it will open up in
a new sheet and just click ok
and you will see this so these are the
if you see this is our data paid organic
social and revenue so this is uh
okay
let's make it more
precise okay
so with a single click
there all our data is analyzed okay this
is the mean value and this is the
minimum is zero maximum is so concert
this is the total and the number of
count is thousand so you don't need to
scroll down and check what is the
largest
amount that is paid so this is the
largest amount for the
paid okay and so on so for the largest
revenue generated all these things are
generated with a descriptive analysis
okay
descriptive statistics with the data
analysis too so the next question is
about a pivot table and this is more
refined or more advanced compared to the
last one that we discussed in the
beginner level so here you are asked to
create a pivot table to find the total
cases in each country belonging to their
respective continents you are giving you
are being asked to
put up a table of pivot table with two
variables basically each country and
their respective continents so again we
have the same data and you need to set
up a pivot table which shows the
continents in the countries with the
respective continuous the number of
cases
okay so let's see how we get this in the
example
so here we are we have the same data
it shows the days months here cases
countries
and their
continents okay
continents here and so on
okay so i'm
i'll go to the insert tab and select the
pivot table okay again the same thing i
will be asked to enter a input range
okay
so i select this
and since it's huge i'll just
put the number to be seven seven seven
seven
okay
now this is our input data and
where you want the output to be it's
already selected you can put it anywhere
i am putting it here okay just click ok
and it will give you the option to
select the fields now what we want is
number of cases okay which will show you
the value and the
countries
and
territories their respective continents
so
okay so this is how it looks like and we
have to check
now it is asking us to find the
countries okay so
with their respective continents
you see this you see africa as a
continent and you will see
okay
you will see africa
if you just remove this you will see the
number of on i mean the cases with the
respective continents and if you want to
include these countries
territories where their respective
continents you will see
assets if you just expand this you will
see the countries that are having the
cases in the continent africa okay so
countrywise sorted with the continents
okay this is
another advanced step to get the data or
show the data in the favorite table okay
another question that you might be asked
is a basic and we have already seen this
in the previous example that i have
shown how do you provide the dynamic
range in data source of a pivot table
you have to select a particular data
source in your input table
for to show up in the pivot table so you
have to select the input range but
how do you
create or how do you create a provide a
dynamic range in this data source so
just need to create a name table to
provide a dynamic range so
where is the data of your table so as we
have seen in the previous example you
will be able to select the input range
and you just need to put this value any
number
so that you know it will pick up the
dynamic range for your input source for
the table okay so now we move on to the
next one and this is about about the
pivot table again is it possible to
create pivot table using multiple
sources of data yes
yes you can create a pivot table from
multiple worksheets sometimes you will
have different data in different sheet
can you create a pivot table for
all the worksheet in a single pivot
table yes you can but there is a
condition there should be a common row
in both the table so you cannot have
different types of data there should be
a common row okay
so then only it will act as a primary
key for the first table and the foreign
key for the second table okay
so this is something that you have to
remember
and you need to create a relationship
between the tables and then build the
pivot table
so you have to analyze what kind of data
it is it should have a common row in
both the tables on both the sheets and
then you have to establish a
relationship between this table and then
build the table okay there is a visit
for that we will
see that later now let's move on to the
next question so the next question is
again you know with the pivot table uh
wherein you will be asked to further
refine or
you know refine your search and show it
in the data so here we have with the
kovid data example again you will be
asked to create a pivot table to find
the top three countries from each
continent based on the total cases using
the
coveted again we have done this before
we have created a pivot table for this
and we need to further refine it showing
the top three countries with the number
of cases
and i will show that same thing in the
excel and we already have created a
table and we'll refine it further to
show the top three countries which are
having the
highest number of accounts in the
respective context so here we are we
have the
table uh already with us and
i just click on the
show field list it will show me the
countries and territories what we are
asked is you know to show the countries
with the top three that is number of
cases
so you just need to go here and you need
to select the value filter there is a
filter which you can select with the
value and how i select top 10 and what i
need is top three it's very simple and
you just need to know these things okay
and based on the number of cases okay
this is our field already then just
click ok and it will show you the top
three countries so it's quite simple and
it is very important to know this
feel and how you play with the value of
the filters for each particular uh field
in the pivot table so it shows you these
things all right and now you can refine
it further with the continents and all
okay
so different continents and you can see
this so you go there and there is a
value filter you can set up all right we
have set up a value filter okay
okay now there is another one
how do you create a column in a pivot
table okay
like you will be given a situation where
you need to add one more column and show
it in the pivot table with a particular
calculation or with a particular value
and you have you don't have that actual
value in your
data but you have to calculate it and
show it across in the table so there is
another option which is called pivot
table analyze and you need to create a
calculated field from pivot table
analyze option
so when you go to your table and then go
to pivot table analyze you will see the
option to add a calculated field okay
just go there and click select
calculated field and you need to define
so in this example we are going to
define another
column where we calculate the bonus of
the sales and there is a particular
formula the formula is you put an if and
statement
and then you calculate the formula you
specify what is the bonus and what is
the way that you are calculating the
bonus and it will
particularly added another column to
your table so let's see how we do that
in the
table net so here we are we have this
table and i have inserted a
pivot table and i am putting it in
output here
okay
then you will get the table okay
now you need to select the
customer name
and the unit sold unit price sales
okay so we'll add another column to it
how we do that is this
go to pivot table tools and then you go
to analyze okay
click on field items and set okay you
need to select calculated field here
select that and we are defining a new
field here which is the bonus
bonus and
as i said we will put up a formula for
this and we will define it how we
calculate the bonus okay
with an if and statement which we have
seen before how we
uh put up a
and if and statement okay now i'm going
to say it as
like this sales my sales
should be
i'll specify a condition how they will
calculate the bonus if sales is greater
than 4000
and
the units sold okay i am trying to put
it as the units which also depends on
the units
sold
is greater than thousand okay for
example let's say a thousand a person
who is uh
able to
do uh
sales of thousand four thousand and the
units sold should be more than thousand
then the sales
what is this the bonus will be
sales
into that is the amount of sales he has
done
into five percent okay let's say five
percent bonus
and
sales
is
if it is two percent okay
okay
we are adding this field bonus
click add
okay
so we have added this and we have put up
a calculation for the formula and you
will see this
so this is simple way of adding the
column to your existing data and we are
doing the calculations and
showing it up okay so this is one way go
to pivot table analyze and field
items and sets you can select this
option and add it
okay you can customize this as i said
with adding different fields this is
pretty handy in analyzing the data which
does not exist in the table and you add
some value to your pivot table
okay the next uh question will be about
slicer you must be familiar with what a
slicer is in a pivot table and how do
you use it for the purpose of using it
and how do you
put up a slider in the pivot table so
how does a slicer work basically slicers
are used to further printer data in the
pivot table suppose you already have
some data
and it's for ease that you can do it by
just adding a slicer you can select
particular
data in or a field and you can see the
output for that particular field that
you have chosen
in the
slicer okay so it's very simple go to
the insert tab and select slicer under
filters okay
and then it will be like this okay
and here if for example you see this is
our pivot table we have added two
slicers to filter our table that is
month and countries and territory so
this will be the general pivot table
that looks like and we haven't added
another two slices that is month and
country so if you go for example if you
want to see
what is the
number of cases and some of the debts
for a particular month and for a
particular country you can just do it by
a single click and it will show that
particular data only in the table let's
see
and do this in our excel
okay
so there is a table uh pivot table
already created for this and i want to
add a slicer so how do i go ahead and do
this is i go to the
options and
insert slicer okay at the moment you
click on it you will see what are the
options that you want to add you can
select different fields and
select the slicer for it uh for this
example we are choosing month
okay this is one of our sliders you can
just put it here
adjacent to the
and again
this will be our slider okay
let's add another slicer here
okay
and this will be the countries and
terrorists okay
click on that and you will see two
simple
badges here that you can choose from so
if i want to know in the month of feb
how many number of cases were there for
particular let's see the moment i choose
the month it will show that particular
number of
the corresponding table for the whole
and now i want to further refine it to a
particular country so for example
australia okay so there were total
number of 18 cases and zero deaths
at the same time if i go for algeria it
is like this
so
as you see
it goes like this okay so this is one of
the very important tool that you can use
to show the data in a much simplified
manner and
ease
okay so the next question is about the
pivot table again what is the percentage
of contribution of each country in
continents to the total cases again the
same example for our code the covid one
in this time we want to show the output
as the percentage of contribution for
each country and continents to the total
cases
so we have the same data and we generate
a pivot table and we should show it as
the sum of the cases uh to be percentage
okay and this is how we do it
this is our
data and i'm going to create a pivot
table for this
okay
so it shows the table
and here i have to show
what is the fields that we need to
select okay
first is we're just selecting
the
cases and the countries and territories
okay
so
cases to be the values okay
okay so this is how it looks like
now when i see
let me show it to you see it shows the
number of cases now if i just want to
refine it further and see it as number
of
percentage percentage as the number of
cases okay so how i do it show field
list
i go here
and i go to
value field settings okay
then
again number format
show the value as okay
sorry
show the value as you need to select
this thing percentage of grand total and
then just click okay
and you will see
this to be the percentage so
it shows
the data in the form of percentage okay
this is very simple and you just need to
remember as we have seen before
show far field and then value field
settings okay this is the thing that you
need to check okay grand percentage
there are other options also
and you can select from whatever you
want to get in this case we are showing
it to be the percentage okay okay guys
now the next question is about uh in a
very important aspect of presentation
when you come to
tribute charts how do you create a
favorite chart in pivot tables
this is very
basic or very you know
important aspect of pivot tables that
you can represent a data in a in the
form of a chart and there are different
types of charts which i'll show it to
you in the
uh example okay so we have a data here
and we want to show it that in
right now it is in a table or form
okay we have put up a pivot table for
this and now if the same thing can be
put up in a pivot chart okay so what you
need to do is go to the insert tab and
select the pivot chart it depends on
different versions of excel that you
have different
forms or different buttons
so i will show it across to you and this
is how it looks like okay it's very
simple it can be a pie chart it can be a
bar chart it can be
different forms and we can see that in
the example here okay so let's go to the
example and
so we have the
pivot table generated here already what
you need to do is you need to select the
table
and go to
insert and
see the options there are there is a
column chart there is a line chart there
is pie bar
area scattered and other parts okay
there are different forms okay so right
now what we do is we will select the
column chart here
okay you need to select the pivot table
and click on the call of chart again
there are different forms which can be
seen
in some time now
so this is the basic form okay
and it will show you the countries i
mean that and it will show it as a form
of a chart okay
again you can change the chart type you
can change it to pi
okay
this personally is very good in
presenting or doing presentation and you
can select different forms different
styles okay we'll also show you the
percentage
so this is one form of presenting your
table
into a chart okay again bar type is also
there
so this won't suit here in our example
there are different ones i'm just
showing it to you
as how it looks like
so depending on your uh
i mean the aesthetic you can see and
select what kind of chart is best
suitable
okay
so this is how you put up a favorite
chart
in
pivot tables
okay
so this is one last for the intermediate
level and
what are macros in excel create a macro
to automate a task basically
you have some daily tasks that you
perform in excel okay
and
you can do this with quite ease using
the macros okay it basically is a
program that resides within the excel
file and it is used to automate tasks in
excel some daily tasks that you run like
running when you come across in any data
and you have to stop that data and you
do some daily
routines and by removing some columns or
adding some formulas
and you know
doing some adding some colors and
changing the fonts or be it anything
that you perform and you have to do a
repetitive task so all that can be done
by recording a macro and this is what
macro is used for in excel so
how you capture those steps in excel is
through a macro to record a macro you
can either go to the developer tab in
the excel and click on record macro or
you can use or access it from the view
tab okay so
these are the
ways to access macros okay just go to
the developer tab and click record macro
wherein you know when you click record
macro it will record the steps that you
are performing in each step and it will
capture that and you can save that it is
like a daily routine that you run and
you can do all these multiple steps
maybe n number of steps within a single
click by running that macro later on
okay
so you record a macro and run that okay
you do it through the developer tab
go to developer tab and click record
macro
and it records all the steps that you
are performing okay you need to name it
and you just need to perform the actions
and it will record the macro and you
just save it later on whenever you come
across the same daily task that you run
you can just click it by running that
macro okay
wow so in a single click it will perform
all the
actions that you have done or steps that
you have performed on that particular
excel sheet or any other excel sheet
okay this is very handy when you have
similar data and you do the similar task
each day okay
so this ends the
intermediate level and in the next v
slides we will see the advanced level
so now we discuss the advanced level uh
interview questions for excel
and when it comes to the advanced level
you will come across definitely you will
be asked about
what if analysis how does it work how
does it how does what if analysis work
in excel so what if analysis as the name
suggests
you have to have
an analysis done
okay with the help of different complex
mathematical calculations like formulas
and
using different formulas and
calculations
you can experiment with the data and you
can analyze if this particular input
changes what will be the scenario
how will your output turn out to be so
as you
can see
it is about different variables to see
how your changes would affect the
outcome of a situation so this is what
what if analysis is and the same thing
can be done with excel and how it is
done is you need to go to the data tab
and click on the what if analysis under
forecast okay so there are three options
and
[Music]
one is the scenario manager goal seek
and the data table so these are the
three situations or three tools which
are available in the what if analysis
in the data tab okay so goal seek is
basically for reverse calculations okay
and you have some
idea you have some set goal in mind
and you have certain variables and
what you need to do
and what you need to achieve to have
certain set goals okay you have you will
set a value for the goal and
with the goal seek option you can get
to know what value you have to achieve
to
come to that
level okay
so
this is what goal seek is
it is one of the simplest sensitivity
analysis tool
and
so for example you know that you know a
single outcome you would like to achieve
like you have a set goal that you have
to achieve this particular grade
okay and the goal seek feature in excel
allows you to
arrive to that goal by mathematically
adjusting a single variable within that
equation so you set the goal and you
will do the what-if analysis goal seek
option
to
know what you have to do or what you
have to achieve
for the set goal
the next option is the data table and it
is basically used for sensitivity
analysis
okay so
in this
scenario
you
the data tables allow the adjustment of
only one or two variables within a data
set
but each variable can have unlimited
number of possible values okay so
basically they are used for side by side
comparisons
in it makes it very easy to read the
scenarios okay one but you need to set
up the
data table correctly okay and
what you do is
you give the input in the table and then
you set up the formula
and for instance you need to calculate
the monthly payments for a loan okay you
provide the principal amount like
whatever amount you're taking two lakhs
three lakhs
and you set the interest rate in a
formula okay
and you set the term
in
and then you need to
provide different uh input options like
what loan amount that you're taking
and
you set the formula and go to data table
and
i mean go to what-if analysis and select
the data table stretches across
and then you will see the monthly
payment options or the monthly emi that
you can calculate there are different uh
things that you can calculate you can
calculate the target or the sales bonus
or things like that okay giving
different scenarios in the
variables okay but you need to set up a
data table it might be a little
challenging but yes it is a very
powerful tool okay
so the next one is the scenario manager
it is a bit more complicated compared to
the other two but then it is
more advanced than goal seek as it
allows you
the uh to adjust the multiple variables
at the same time okay
and
this is very complicated compared to the
other two
and it is even i mean it gives more
better output when it compares to the
other two what-if analysis tools
so here when you go to what-if analysis
and the scenario manager you have to
select the data and provide different
scenarios that is different values for
each scenario and then it will create a
it will analyze calculate and create
different scenarios okay so it becomes
very easy for you to analyze what if you
are changing the value
of your interest amount or the
term of loan or
your targets like
monthly targets or an yearly targets and
things like that and you just have to
uh see what the scenario will be when
you set this particular value
for a
table or for data whatever targets that
you need to set you can use this what-if
analysis in
excel for the different
scenarios and different calculations
okay these are very powerful tools and
you need to know this
now as we move on to the next one you
might be asked what is the difference
between a function and a subroutine in a
vba
okay
even though these two are used quite
frequently
there is a
pretty much different from each other
okay so a function always returns a
value of the
task it is performing okay so when you
are writing a module you will have a
function when you have a function it
will always give you a value okay for
example you are performing an addition
it using the function it will give you a
value for sure whereas subroutine it
does not return a value of the task it
is performing functions are called by a
variable okay
you can
set up a variable and you can call the
function okay whereas subroutines can be
recalled from anywhere in the program in
multiple types okay in many different
ways you can recall a subroutine like we
have seen
we write a subroutine and we put up a
button and we can when you click the
button it will recall the subroutine
functions are called by variable okay
you have to set up a variable and when
you enter it it will come up okay
functions are used directly in
spreadsheets as formulas whereas sub
cannot be used directly in spreadsheets
as formula okay this is very important
difference and the next thing is the
functions can be used to perform
repetitive tasks and return a value
whereas users must insert a value in the
desired cell before getting the result
of the sub so this is particularly
limited okay whereas functions can be
used to perform different repetitive
tasks and return a value user input is
not required whereas if you see the
subroutines user must insert a value
okay in the desired cell that too in a
particular cell which is defined in the
subroutine to getting the desired result
okay so these are the differences
between functions and subroutines now
the next one is
what is the difference between this
workbook and
active workbook in vba
so when you work on modules and
different excel spreadsheets and
workbooks you will have these different
workbooks open
and
there is a particular difference and you
might be asked what is the difference
between this workbook and active
workbook so as the name suggests this
workbook refers to the name of the
workbook where the code is actually
running from okay you are running a code
vba code and it is the actual
workbook where you are running the
code from and that is this workbook okay
and you have multiple spreadsheets open
and you're working on particular suppose
for example you're working on a sheet x
okay
and you active workbook is the workbook
that is currently active from the
different open verbals you have
different
open workbooks but you are working on
one particular
workbook and that is called the active
workbook so this workbook is the
refers to the name of the workbook where
the code is actually written whereas
active workbook is the one that is
currently open currently active okay so
this is the difference between this
workbook and the active workbook in vba
as shown in the example this is a simple
sub that is written a code that can be
written to find out which workbook is
the
uh
it which workbook is the uh this
workbook in the vba and the active
workbook as well okay so this is a
simple thing that you can run to
determine okay it shows the active
workbook and the this workbook okay
so as we move on to the next one
so this is the question how will you
pass arguments to a pbf function okay
there are two ways basically arguments
can be passed to a vba function as a
value or as a
reference so
this is an example that you can see
it is by reference the key word for this
is by reference okay
so when you are passing an argument by
reference the keyword should be by
ref
whereas
by value you are specifying a value and
the keyword is by
val value okay so these are the two ways
that you can
pass an argument in vba
so when you pass an argument by
reference in a procedure the variable
itself okay the variable itself is
accessed by a procedure and it is to the
location or the address in the memory
okay the value of the variable is
changed permanently by the procedure in
this case all right okay so to pass an
argument by reference you should use
buyer that is the key word before the
argument okay so in this example it is
clearly shown what is the keyword that
is being used okay
and by reference is the default
in the vba unless you specify something
else which in this case is by value okay
and as i said the keyword for by value
passing the argument by value is by dal
okay
so when you set the keyword by when
the variable
what happens is the
by value argument function or argument
[Music]
is passed through by value okay the
number function is called here
which means it assigns a value to the
variable x here okay
because the variable was passed by value
in the function any change to the value
okay any change to the value
of the variable
is only the current function so it ends
after it performs the
function okay then it reverts back to
the value when it is declared again
where it is set to zero so if the
variable has been passed by reference in
the function then the variable would
have permanently assumed the new
assigned value so this is the basic
difference by reference and by value
so now we move on to the next one
so there might be a question that you
will be asked that how do you find the
last row or a column in a vba okay so to
find a
last row sometimes you have long list of
uh data and it has like n number of rows
and n number of columns so
instead of scrolling down all together
to find the
uh
last row you can use this
vba code you can write this code it's a
very simple one and it will give you the
last row you will find the last row with
a single click okay let's see it in the
vba so here i have a sheet which you
know it has long list of
rows and instead of scrolling down i can
just find out the
last row with this
vba code okay i just click on this and
as seen in the slideshow i have just
returned it
and
you will speed it you just run it and
you will see the number of rows it will
give you the last row in the sheet okay
similarly we can do this for the column
as well okay in case if you have
long list of
large number of columns instead of
scrolling right
you can just uh run this vba and you can
see you can know the
last number of columns okay number of
columns so as we've seen in the last row
now we'll see the code for the finding
the last column it's the same thing
instead of row you will see it as column
all right and it when you run it you
will give the
it will give you the last column okay
now let's move on to the next one so you
might be asked this how do we check
whether a file exists or not in a
specified location
there is a code simple vba code that you
can write and you can run you can use
this utility to find out whether the
file exists or not okay and you need to
check whether the file exists and if it
does it will give you a message that the
selected file exists and if it doesn't
it will pop up with a message box saying
that the file selected file doesn't
exist so what you need to do is you have
to specify this
function okay and
check file exist this is what
it does okay you have to specify a
variable that is the store file name
where you will give the location the
location of the file and the name of the
file okay and then you will also specify
whether the file name is there or not
now
so it runs this and it will see
either the file name exist or the file
actually exist or not
and it will give the appropriate message
box we can run the same thing in my pc
and we can check it
so here we are i have put this and i
have done the same thing
and what i'm looking for is this book
two okay let me maximize it this is what
i'm looking for and the location is
desktop okay so let me run this and you
will see whether it exists or not okay
and it says this selected file exists so
it goes and checks whether the file
exists and then it will give you the
message so this is how we check using
the vb
so the next one is uh
you know there is a powerful tool called
debug
and you need to
you might be asked questions about how
debug works or how
you check the debug
okay to debug a vba code line by line
you can use the f8 key okay you can also
create a breakpoint to terminate the
execution so for this if you go to your
vba you will see the option as debug
okay you can use this
by clicking on debug or by pressing the
f8 key okay so what debug does is it
will show you the step-by-step execution
of your
steps okay it will check each and
everything and if there is an error it
will pop
okay
and the what is breakpoint is at some
point of time
you can check one particular step okay
you can stop the if suppose if there is
a thousand line codes and you want to
check on one particular step like maybe
800 step so just go to go to that
particular step and you can enter a
break point and it will show you what is
actually happening
at the that point that particular step
and you can see this in the locals
window or the watch window okay so let
me show you some simple example of how
this debug can be
used to check our codes okay
so here i have written a simple code for
this and it is basically
let me show you how debug works okay
this is the
let me maximize it and we'll see
okay so this is the debug option that
you can run and you will see what
happens okay this can be done by
clicking f8 all right
so step into is the option and you can
check
f8 and you can press f8 again it will go
to the next step all right and it will
show you what's happening actually uh
you can see this in the uh locals window
what's actually happening let me see
let me maximize it a bit
so that you can actually see
okay so when i press f8 okay
step into
you will see what happens in the next
step okay this is what is happening a is
empty
b is 0 i is 0 okay i step into it the
next step again so it goes here you can
see what changes happen i press
f8 again
so this is what is happening
all right so it is checking each and
every step so debug is the tool that you
can use to check the course whether this
is a very simple program but then you
will have some different codes where you
functions or routines that you can have
where you have thousand line codes and
you need to check each and every step or
some particular step so this comes in
very handy okay let me press f8 and it
shows what happens in which
you can step into each and every step
and
see what happens okay and now if i show
there is something called as toggle
breakpoint okay this one particular is
used by
pressing the f9 key wherein you will see
what is actually happening at some
particular step okay so how you do that
is you just need to go to a particular
step and click on the bar here and it
will get
highlighted into red so this is what is
happening okay so in the watch window
you will see that particular step will
be
magnified or you can see what is
actually happening in that step okay
so let me start it again
see what happens
i press f8 again
so here it sees
it actually shows you can toggle and you
can see what is happening in the watch
window at that particular step so module
1 abc the variant is empty so expression
is b this is what is happening at this
particular step okay so this is how
debug can be used
so now as we move on to the next one
well you might be asked to create a bar
chart with the given data using vba so
you will have some data
and
you can create a bar chart or a
any kind of chart with the vba we have
done it with the pivot tables and all
but then we can do the same with the vba
so it's a simple thing a simple sub that
you can write
and create embedded chart using chart
object this is the
sub that you can use okay you are
specifying a variable here
and ambiguity you need to specify the
embedded chart and which sheet you're
using and this is very basic and they
charge a chart objects like the length
the dimensions of the chart okay
and you need to specify the source okay
the source switch sheet for range so and
so you can specify the range here so uh
let's go and do the same thing in the
vba
so here i have the uh data and uh let
i've already copied the vba for it and
let me simply
run it okay
see
it creates a chart so this comes in very
handy
and you can see the as i have mentioned
in you have to specify the source the
dimensions of the chart and so on so and
so on okay you are specifying where it's
picking up the data from
and the columns i mean the range and the
dimensions of the chart okay you can
play with this and you will generate a
chart so
well this ends our presentations
and
so
this is how it looks like and we've seen
that so next question is about a vba
code again to calculate the area of your
rectangle using the vba function how do
you include a function to calculate the
area of a rectangle we all know that the
area of a rectangle is length into width
okay that is the formula we can execute
it with the by defining a function in
the vba
and we will define the same function
function is equal to area and it is area
as length into bit in this scenario i'll
again show it to you
how we do this in excel and
let's go ahead and do this
so here we are i will just go to the
developer tab and open the vpn
and i insert a module okay so here we
will define the function okay
function
as area okay
this is my function
and now i'm going to define the
variables okay
length
as
[Music]
double because
we may want to make sure that it takes
the decimals as well okay
and width
okay now what is the area
formula for example a equals to
length
into limit
okay
very simple
okay now
i go to my excel and
i'll define the area form function okay
let's take the
length to be
put in
a1 and the width to be put in b okay
now if i just put the value here
it will take 12
and my width is 36
3 and it shows the area to be
36 okay
11
so this is the area if you just go and
define it i mean try to enter area a1
and b1 it will not so we have to define
the function here we're using the vba
code okay now let's go back to the slide
and we'll discuss that so here uh it has
been shown as if you know we
have a
rectangle when the
width is not provided that is if the
rectangle is a square they will not be
given the width so we are defining again
length is double optional optional is we
are giving an argument that it is
optional width as a variant width as a
variant means it can be zero okay so we
are defining it as if missing width then
the area should be length into length
okay as the area is length into width as
we have seen okay so this is one way to
define a function for the area of a
rectangle
okay let's go to the next slide
so
you might be asked about a vba function
to check if the number is prime or not
we all know what a prime number is a
prime number is divisible by 1 and
itself
for example 2 3 5 7 11
13
17 and so on
and these are the prime numbers and
anything which is divisible by any other
number like 8 or 4 or 16
which has a divisor is not a prime
number so uh we all know this and we
will write a
vba code to
check if the number is prime or not so
this is the one that is given and we
will do the same in the
vba okay before moving ahead i will just
explain these
code and what we are doing here is
basically we are defining three
variables okay we are declaring three
variables one integer variable
okay
and we call it as divisors all right and
then the next one is the one long
variable long
as the number and i as long okay here
long specifies variables
because uh it has got the larger
capacity than the integer values okay
the divisor will be zero we are
initializing the uh variable divisor
with the value of zero okay the next
thing is we use a input box input box to
get the number from the user that is you
will input a
number when you are asked to
uh for the input box okay
so this is the
so when the number is entered we want to
check whether this number is prime or
not okay so how do we check that okay as
we all know the condition for prime
number is it has only two number devices
that is one and itself so what we do is
we start a
next loop okay
for i equals to 1 to numbers all right
so this is the start of the loop we will
define the conditions here
so now how do we actually perform the
operation of dividing we use the
mod operator okay this is one of the
important operator to check here the mod
operator will give you the remainder of
a division for example you have seven or
eight or mod by two
is equal to one because seven divided by
two
equals three with the remainder of one
okay so only if the uh only
if a number mod
i equals to 0 i is the advise divisor of
a number okay so in this case we want to
increment it by variable divisors by 1
so this is what we define it as okay now
so here a check is performed like
i equals to 1
and then
plus 1 i equals to 2 then plus 1 i
equals to 3 and then plus 4 i equals to
so as it goes on until it reaches the
number okay because for i equals to 1 to
number
okay
so this is what is starting of the loop
now you have to close the loop so how we
do that is next i okay this is closing
the
loop
so this is what the loop does now we are
we have defined the check now we have to
define the result how what happens if
the divisor is equals to 2 then the
message box number should say is a prime
number all right otherwise it should say
message number should pop up and say it
is not a prime number so this is how we
define it in the vba let's go ahead and
do this
so here we are i have already set it up
and this is the vba so let's run it okay
and it will ask you this is the module 2
because i defined it as module 2.
so the message box opens up and it asks
you to enter a value now
let's see
two
is a prime number okay
i run it again by pressing the
fake key okay
12
is not a prime number so this is how we
have in
we have coded up maybe a code or
function to check whether the number is
prime or not
so this ends our presentation
you